okay I think we're ready to
well thank you for quieting down so
quickly
I'd like to introduce my myself to you
I'm Rick Ladd I chair House Education
been on the education committee for the
last 15 years
and I come from Haverhill New Hampshire
not Massachusetts
and I'd like to welcome everybody to our
our hearing today
and prior to getting into the hearing
process there's some notices I'd like to
make we are in the general court room
here which is uh very important to our
state in fact the state of New Hampshire
was the first state the first place in
the United States of America to adopt a
constitution
now getting into the next part some of
the rules which regarding the governor
ourselves by here
as you know no signs are allowed in this
chamber at all and all political pins
when you come up to testify anything
such as that we don't wear them here
that's just the rule we've had for years
and one which I want to go through the
hearing process with throughout the
other thing that we just did we just
clapped
we won't have any clapping or any of
that or yelling or Screaming or saying
that's a great job anything like that
during the hearing process we have a
number of cards up here pink cards for
those who want to testify and that is
going to take some time to Wade through
all that this this hearing will most
likely go into the afternoon hours and
hopefully not much later than that we
will be taking a lunch break during the
middle part of the day and I will
announce that so everybody has that
awareness one of the things which we do
when we have a hearing at least we do it
in House Education we always provide the
Senators the opportunity to speak first
seeing that senators are quickly having
to go to in fact I had to testify
already this morning at nine o'clock in
Senate education on several bills they
are also on many different committees so
we allow them to come in first the only
person that can supersede that is the
governor now following the centers we
have the representatives because they
also have a similar type task there are
a number of Representative hearings
going on today house hearings across
street and yellow B so we want them to
move on and get on their tasks when we
get to the general public it's my
position that if we have parents in here
with children
and I know how hard it is I have a
little four and a half five-year-old
living with us in the house and he's
oftentimes way in front of me and I'm
chasing him
so if you have children please let us
know and we'll try to get you out of
here as quickly as possible
the hearing process itself we are going
to the another area that we do with the
hearing process in terms of House
Education the prime sponsor of bill has
always given more latitude as far as
time in which to speak they're the ones
that have gone through the process of
putting the bill together working with
various agencies Etc so they had the
opportunity to give a full speech other
than that we are going to enforce the
three-minute rule
three-minute rule will be going into
effect today every time I've had bills
in here when we're dealing with this
type of issue our Charter Schools or
similar type issues we've had to put a
three-minute rule into effect when we
get to 2 minutes and 45 seconds
this will come up you'll see this red
that's the warning that you have 15
seconds left
so please uh
go buy the rule here that's important
that we give everybody the opportunity
to speak and if we don't have that rule
we could be here close to midnight and
there have been some evenings in session
I have been here to midnight so it won't
be something new for me but maybe for
you it may be
no food is allowed in the chamber at all
no food
the only beverage we allowed in here is
water
and I hope everybody does hydrate and
take water seeing that's what my doctor
tells me to do so I'm sure that you have
the same Physicians telling you the same
um
when you leave please leave nothing in
the the uh seat in front of you where
you have a chance to put your paperwork
and all that please take all that with
you we do have groups coming in and
using this chamber after not today but
in later days we will so it helps out
the people have to clean the area up
with that I think we have uh on on
written testimony if you have written
testimony which is important and the
committee does appreciate that please
don't try to read it verbatim try to
summarize it uh if you can if you got it
down so you can read it in three minutes
fine uh you're ready then uh go for it
but uh if you have a copy of written
testimony the clerks right here have to
take records here and if you have
written testimony that written testimony
you go down in our Journal as an
attachment as part of the presentation
today and the hearing process so if
you've written testimony please provide
if you are up here repeating and
repeating what has been said earlier try
not to do that just say I support what
has been said to the the committee
earlier and do not just go down the same
Rail and and repeat that's also a Time
Saver for us
so with that I think we're
does the sergeant of arms have anything
else
we're we're good okay so with that we're
going to go ahead I'm going to invite
the prime sponsor now the prime sponsor
uh having the ability to read from her
record and going a little longer will be
speaking here other folks including
representatives and other Senators will
be doing the from the microphones uh in
the two aisles here so welcome Senator
Carson
you have the floor
thank you very much Mr chairman and good
morning and good morning to members of
the House Education committee for the
record my name is Sharon Carson and I
have the pleasure of representing Senate
District 14 comprising the towns of
Auburn Londonderry and Hudson and for
your consideration this morning I have
Senate Bill 272 FN and this bill seeks
to establish a parent's Bill of Rights
what what constitutes a violation of
such rights and a mechanism to notify
parents of their rights Mr chairman you
would wonder why in the world do we need
this bill why do we need it
and I would ask you all to take a step
back a few years ago when we entered
into the covid epidemic
School our schools were shut down
and parents ended up having the
responsibility to make sure that their
child was participating in their
education many parents became the
teachers for their children at home
and parents started to see some of the
things that were happening some of the
assignments that children their children
were being given and started raising
questions about them
but unfortunately parents for the most
part were shut out and ignored
if you were to go to a school board
meeting with questions
they didn't want to hear it and
oftentimes parents were not allowed to
speak and were not allowed to address an
elected board
and I ask all of you here today how
would you feel if this bill was proposed
and you did not have the opportunity to
address the legislature and give them
your opinion
so what it ended up happening was I
filed a bill that required that every
school board in the state of New
Hampshire and every single meeting they
had had to allow at minimum 30 minutes
for parents or their constituents in
their Community to address the board
that passed and is now law
so what we have here is also
um from the roots of it come from that
what this bill does is it determines
what is a violation of parental rights
and includes a neck mechanism of
notification for parents
this is not the first time we've seen
bills like this there was one last year
and it died in a committee a conference
but it is time to to legislate this
issue once again
Senate Bill 272 Narrows
um itself I guess you could say compared
to the bill that was filed last year and
it Deals Only with the parental right in
education
scattered throughout the RSA there are
different parts of those rsas that deal
with a parental rights in education and
one thing that this bill does it brings
it all into the same place
so if a parent wonders what is my right
here
they can go to one statute and get their
answer and instead of having to shuffle
through
the mountains of rsas that we have
I want to bring up the one point here
that I don't really want people to
forget that parents love their children
they care about their children
and they want the best for their
children
schools can't provide that to them
schools only have your children for a
few hours a day
but they are home with their families
the majority of the time
and what happens with to those children
once they leave school it's the parents
that are going to be there with them for
the rest of their lives so why why why
do we have to do this
well I'd like to point out to a couple
of things that have happened
and I think what was most troubling to
me are policies that have been adopted
by school boards in this state
that outright lie and deceive parents
and that is wrong that is wrong
categorically wrong how many parents in
this room have talked to their kids
about lying how lying is bad you
shouldn't lie
but yet why is it okay
for a school to lie to parents what kind
of lesson does that treat tell a child
that it's okay to lie
unfortunately
a lot of this language revolves around
transgendered students and I really want
to be very very careful here and be
respectful of everyone because I think
but just to give you a couple of
examples about this
School Personnel should not disclose
information that may reveal the students
transgender status or gender
non-conforming presentation to others
including parents and other school
Personnel unless legally required to do
so unless the student or the parent has
authorized such disclosure
secondly when contacting a parent or
guardian of a transgender or gender
non-conforming student School Personnel
should use the student's legal name and
pronoun corresponding to the student's
gender assigned at Birth unless the
parents student parent or Guardian has
specified otherwise
those are the types of policies that
parents are very upset about and they
want change and quite frankly I have
been contacted by a number of teachers
around the state who don't like this
policy they don't think it's right they
are parents themselves
and they wouldn't want someone lying to
them
about what's happening to their children
in school
don't forget for those of you who are
parents in this room and maybe even
students
cannot get as much as a Tylenol if you
have a headache without your parents
permission
why is this being allowed
why
and I ask that question why
thank you
well I think what we need to what I'm
going to do here is because we're
talking about a legal issue because this
bill would confer a right is to look at
the legal precedence for parents
that have a right
to direct their children
a parent's right to direct educational
and religious upbringing of his or her
child is violated by a state that
imposes itself between a parent and
pertinent information about a child the
constitutional rights of parents are
well established by a long line of
United States Supreme Court cases that
begin back in 1923 with Meyer versus
Nebraska and believe it or not this
dealt with whether parents have the
right to teach German I teach their
children the German language and the
Supreme Court ruled yes they had a right
to do that you have peers versus the
Society of sisters 1925 parents have the
right to send their children to
religious rather than public schools
Wisconsin versus Yoder
uh 1972 in which an Amish father had the
right to take his 15 year old child out
of school to complete education in the
Amish ways at home
Troxel versus Granville in 2000 parents
have the right to control access to
children by grandparents
choices about marriage family life and
the upbringing of children are among
associational rights the Supreme Court
has ranked as the basic importance in
our society rights sheltered by the 14th
Amendment against the state's
unwarranted usurpation disregard or
disrespect
that is from the Troxel versus Granville
and the Supreme Court recognized a
parent's right
why why is a school that is basically a
government-controlled school because
that's what it is schools are created by
government and paid for with everyone's
tax dollars why do they have the right
to usurp a parent's rights
why
a school that hides its actions toward a
child from the child's parent
improperly interferes with the parents
right to make important decisions about
that child indeed such action deprives
those parents of the right to make
informed decisions about whether their
local public school is the right place
all students
are subject to parental notification in
a wide variety of circumstances
reflecting the breadth of Student
Activity in a school and they apply
equally to all students
many New Hampshire schools have adopted
policies protecting students against
discrimination RSA 193 colon 39 for
example
these policies and others adopted by
schools prohibit sexual harassment
bullying and other in-school conduct
that could interfere with the child's
right to pursue education opportunities
if a child is being bullied or sexually
harassed because of his or her gender or
sexual orientation or for any other
reason for that matter
the school has a duty to take action to
protect the bullied child
the school will then have a duty to
inform the parents that the child is
being bullied
this is just an example of the need for
Action in relation to the student
pursuant to school policies
so if your child is being bullied
they'll tell you that your child is
being bullied but under the other
policies they're not going to tell you
why
so how as a parent can you help your
child if you have no idea why your child
is being bullied
just doesn't make sense
the United States recently decided the
case of Bostock versus Clayton County in
2020 holding that the Title VII of the
Civil Rights Act of 1964
extends its protection to transgendered
persons
following Bostock
it is nearly certain that the courts
will find that student transgendered
school students are protected by Title
IX of the Civil Rights Act and in fact
that issue is currently being discussed
at the federal level
New Hampshire
likewise prohibits discrimination
against students based on their gender
expression and that is RSA 19327
those protections exist to protect the
rights of students in school
they are not rights to protect children
from the child wearing decisions or
[Music]
we've also have another case Sterling
versus borough of Minersville
Circa 2000 this is a really sad case
and I really agree with the decision of
the Supreme Court
it was a young man who was 18 years old
who was expressing his sexuality and he
was arrested and he was threatened he
was threatened by the sheriff that I'm
going to tell your grandfather what you
were doing
and the young man was so upset about it
that he committed suicide
and they and the sheriff and the state
and the county was sued which is
appropriate
because one reason
as an adult he had a right to privacy
but we're not talking about 18 year old
students or older because they do have a
right to privacy
if they decided that they wanted to tell
someone
they're 18. they're legally adults
and he could that he or she could say
listen I don't want my parents to know
and the school would have to recognize
that right because they are legally an
adult but we are not talking about
adults we are talking today about minor
children
thank you
Mr chairman about there's a couple
things about this bill we do realize
that some students
we we recognize that
and what this bill does it adds in a
layer of protections for students that
find themselves in that type of a home
which would allow the school to document
that this child comes from an abusive
home or there's a history of abuse here
and it will be kept on file
with this with the school
to provide protection
[Music]
we need to recognize that students do
have some privacy rights in school
but what is left out
is the involvement excuse me to involve
the right of maintaining maintaining
their privacy from school officials and
fellow students not from their parents
and these privacy rights arise from the
family and involve the right of families
to maintain a degree of privacy from
government officials
it is the right of families to be free
from State coercion and interference
that is really at issue here
it is not Educators but parents who have
primary rights in the upbringing of
their children
school officials have only a secondary
responsibility and must respect those
rights
State deference to parental control over
children is underscored by the Supreme
Court admonition that the child is not a
mere creature of the state and that it
is the Citizen's responsibility to
inculcate moral standards religious
beliefs and elements of good citizenship
it is not Educators but parents who have
the primary rights and the upbringing of
their children and that is a quote from
grunke versus seep which was a case
decided in 2000.
again I ask you why why are we here why
are we ha why is this happening
why why is there this blanket policy
that is being adopted in districts
across the state
that leave parents out of this
discussion
as I said in the beginning parents love
their children they care about their
children they want the best for their
children
we know that that's not always true
but why is this affecting
parents who want to be involved in their
children's lives
who want to be there to help their
children no matter what they're going
through to be there for them and get
them the appropriate care because the
school can't authorize that care
it's only the parents
so I ask you what how does this work
you're asking students to live a double
life
one life at home being one person and at
and as a parent I can tell you that
there's nothing worse than getting a
phone call from a school
on a Friday at 3 30 in the afternoon
with them telling you
that your child was sexually assaulted
and it's now three weeks later
why wasn't I told was the question that
I asked
and I was told well we don't have to
tell you this is a courtesy call
that is what happened to my family
it was well over 20 years ago but it's
what happened to my family
and it's wrong my daughter thought she
did the right thing by telling the
so she felt she didn't need to say
anything to us
and I didn't give her a hard time
because she did the right thing but as a
parent I had the right to know what
it wasn't the school's responsibility
the first call should have been to my
family
but it wasn't made
and I don't want any other parent to
have to go through this
it's really and truly unfortunate
parents voices ask to be heard they want
to be heard and this bill will allow
that
it really and truly is thank you Mr
chairman thank you very much Senator are
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman
and I'd like to take a second and
recognize the fourth graders that are
coming into the balcony area welcome to
okay the next speaker up and excuse me
the next speaker up is Honorable Senator
Chuck Morse who is president of our
Senate last year and welcome back to the
house senator
thank you chairman Ladd and thank you
the members of the education committee
for taking a few minutes to listen to me
I am here today to speak in support of
Senate Bill 272. the parental Bill of
Rights as a father
I understand the importance of
protecting parental rights and ensuring
that parents have the information they
need to make informed decisions about
their children's education
and as the former Senate President I
know just how important this legislation
is to so many Granite State parents and
families
I thank Senator Carson for all the work
she's done on this legislation
at its core Senate Bill 272 is about
enshrining a parent's right to know what
their child is being taught in the
school in the conversations our children
and grandchildren are having with their
teachers
this may seem like a simple concept
but it is one that is often overlooked
in our education system
parents should have access to
information about their child's
curriculum as well as materials or
resources that are being used in the
classroom
this knowledge is essential to ensure
that parents can make informed decisions
about their child's education and can
provide the necessary support at home
in addition Senate Bill 272 also
protects a parent's right to up their
child out of certain activities or
materials they may find objectionable
this is a fundamental right that parents
should have it is one that has been
upheld by the courts by enshrining this
right in law
we have provided parents with the
insurance that their wishes will be
respected and that they will have to say
in their child's education
ultimately Senate Bill 272 is empowering
parents and ensuring that they have the
center of their child's education as a
parent myself I know firsthand
how important it was to be involved in
my child's Learning and Development
and I want her rights protected when it
comes to the Future family and my future
grandchildren
by enshrining a parental Bill of Rights
and law we are sending a clear message
that parents of valued Partners in the
education process and that their input
and participation are essential to the
accessibility success of our schools and
our children
I urge you to support Senate Bill 272
and to send a strong message to parents
across New Hampshire that their rights
are valued and protected thank you Mr
chairman thank you very much Senator
your driver Joey Logano is doing very
well this year
yes
good morning thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee
my name is Senator Daryl Abbas and I
represent District 22.
which is the towns of Salem Pelham
classdown and Atkinson
and I'm rising in support I've Senate
Bill 272
on behalf of the parents of my district
the parents in the state of New
Hampshire and as a proud parent myself
I'm asking the members of the community
to please keep an open mind
and focus on the bill that's in front of
you
and on both sides we're hearing a lot of
political rhetoric but I will ask to
focus on the bill that's before this
committee in its simplest form what does
what it does in its simplest form it
forbids
the educational institution the schools
the School Employees the teachers which
who are government actors
from
lying to parents who inquire with the
school about issues involving their
children that's all this bill does
is to promote honesty
and I'm asking everyone to think
in their mind about a plausible scenario
where a parent would inquire with a
school about their child's sexuality or
gender identity
and and those in that plausible scenario
you will have a parent who perhaps
suspects something about their child
in my opinion it is more harmful for the
school to lie to the parents
because that's going to confuse the
parents
and that can be harmful to the child who
perhaps is trying to express themselves
to their parents in subtle ways and
trying to get that message across but by
lying to the parent
in Mis in misdirecting them you can you
see where there's now a disconnection
between the parent and their children
caused by the school the school made the
problem worse not better by lying and
that's my my opinion
I ask that we keep an open mind
I'm a millennial and growing up I recall
that the schools always encouraged
parents
to work with the schools and to be
involved in their children's education
I'm not sure when that changed
but that was not broke
so I'm not sure why we think now it's
all right to now mislead parents if it
comes to any other activity in the
school
football wrestling whatever Sports track
and field
parents have always been involved
there's permission slips to go on fail
trips that's how the school's always
been I support that policy I certainly
don't support the school misleading
parents and lying to parents that's
inappropriate and I asked this committee
please support and ought to pass thank
you very much Mr chairman thank you very
much Senator any questions from the
committee
thank you
like to welcome honorable Senator Bob
Guida from Warren
Bob here
yep
thank you Mr chairman honorable members
of the committee for the record Bob
guided and Warren and former senator
from District 2.
for the not on my head the branch won
it's an honor to stand here before you
today as a former senator
and as a parent
and as someone who has served our
country in the armed forces and
protection of the values that we espouse
before us we have a bill in Senate Bill
272 which I believe should not even have
to be legislated
the foundation of every nation
is the family
and anything that jeopardizes or
threatens the family becomes a threat
ultimately to the survival of the
society
current law enables a teacher to
withhold information about the most
intimate
and difficult aspects of a child's
development
from those who were entrusted by God and
nature to rear that child
our Declaration of Independence speaks
to the laws of God and of Nature's God
I'm sorry nature and of nature is God
and we as men and women
amplify those with the laws of men
but when those laws begin to transgress
the laws of nature and of Nature's God
the rights and obligations of Parenthood
over children will you enable state
agencies okay without justification to
interfere with that process of parenting
without justification we are beginning
to sow the seeds of the decline
of our society those children belong to
the parents not to the school
there is no reason on God's Earth that
absent the compelling State
causes that are Exempted in this bill
a parent should not be told of things
about their child that are those most
intimate items that a teacher might
become aware of
teacher's job is done at three o'clock
in the afternoon a parent's job is never
done
okay
I appreciate the respect of those you
who might disagree but your job is done
with those children when you when they
I ask you to support this bill
pass this bill in the interest of Nature
and of Nature's God and the rights of
parents okay who are the primary
educators of our children both by
Constitution and by Divine ordination
thank you very much Mr chairman thank
you very much Senator Guida any
questions from the committee thank you
I'd like to call Representative Potenza
and then represent Petrino following
Potenza
well I didn't think I was going to come
up so quickly the good thing is I can
thank Senator Carson because all of the
Court Supreme Court cases just took
about a minute off my speech so
the framework of all the opposition that
has been testified
on all the parental rights I'm a member
of the house I'm a representative for
Rochester
so I've already testified on the house
bill version of the parental rights has
all been based on a premise of abusive
parents
where is due process
why have we forgotten there is due
process in this country
why have we forgotten about all of the
laws that are already protecting
children from abusive parents
I want to be clear about all of the
testimony that has been given which
there's tons and it's been over the last
two years
these are not new granted rights
these are the rights that we as parents
already possess
they are granted and rooted and are
god-given natural rights and by our
founding fathers in the laws of the land
our state and federal constitutions
unfortunately
based upon so many things that have
happened over the last three years we
are forced to spell out these rights in
a bill
because government entities have forced
parents into this position
there are numerous court cases as you've
already heard that solidify parents
rights as well there's a couple that
Cleveland versus Board of Education in
lafer and this was in 1974. this court
has long recognized that freedom of
personal choice in matters of marriage
and family life is one of the Liberties
protected by the due process clause of
the 14th Amendment
the 14th Amendment forbids the
government to infringe
fundamental Liberty interests of all no
matter what process is provided unless
the infringement is narrowly tailored to
serving a compelling State interest and
that's the protections that we have in
place for children that are vulnerable
that's the compelling State interest our
laws protect those kids
in a long line of cases the courts have
held that in addition to the specific
freedoms protected by the Bill of Rights
the Liberty that specifically protected
by the due process clause includes the
rights to direct the education in the
upbringing of one's children
I strongly support this Bill thank you
for your time thank you very much
representative
next person is uh representative Petrino
followed by representative Lynn and
representative Guthrie those other reps
may be ready to go
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee
I'm representative Peter Petrino from
Hillsboro 23 the town of Milford
you have heard testimony and you'll hear
more testimony that parental rights
already exist in numerous federal and
state statutes
that the New Hampshire child advocate
testified that this bill would put some
children In Harm's Way
especially those
who are members of the lgbtq community
and that even the governors one trusted
adult program
would be compromised
but none of this is swayed some to
realize how wrong this bill is
now I will admit that I have read
in heard of instances that would lead
some to believe that this bill is
necessary
and I'll even concede that there have
been instances in which parental rights
have been violated
but the fact of the matter is
that schools can't even give a child a
baby aspirin without parental consent
in every profession there are instances
of misconduct in every profession
when parental rights are violated those
responsible must be held accountable
and parents already have the right to
file complaints
initiate inquiries
and file lawsuits and believe me they
file lawsuits
my concern with this bill specifically
is with the provisions
which Begin by stating
the right to inquire of the school or
School personnel and to be truthfully
and completely informed that's when my
objection lies
it's understood that teachers answer
questions related to a child's academic
progress School conduct and anything
else applicable along those lines but
beyond that
as a matter of professional judgment
and good conscience
teachers may be hesitant and they may
even refuse to answer
instead a teacher may decide that it's
best for parents to inquire of the
principle the guidance counselor
school nurse other professionals with
certain expertise
more so
a teacher May at times believe that
revealing certain information to
particular parents may put a Child In
Harm's Way every situation is unique
and again should parents believe that
their rights have been violated
they already have proper recourse
the bottom line is this
no one
has the right to compel someone else to
do anything against their will
in this case forcing teachers to answer
questions that they may feel is
inappropriate
or harmful
if it is revealed
and when confronted with the possibility
of losing their employment and civil and
criminal liability
I excuse me Mr chairman I believe that
you said that senators and
representatives no no I said the prime
sponsor may have longer senators and
representatives have the same
representative Lynn
thank you Mr chair my name is Bob Lin
I'm a state representative from Windham
and I am here to speak in strong support
of SB 272
um a candidly and with respect to the
prior speaker I have to say that his
comments simply reinforce in my mind the
importance and the need for this bill
um it is it strikes me as just
incomprehensible that you have you can
have a circumstance where a child
goes to a teacher to reveal some
information
um that's that that is exactly the
situation that we're talking about a
child goes to a teacher to reveal some
information
um that perhaps they wouldn't reveal to
to to uh a stranger or to some to
somebody outside the school context and
that it's somehow should be all right
for the teacher to say I'm not going to
tell the parents that information now as
Senator Carson pointed out there is
there obviously needs to be an exception
to that circumstance where there is a
real concern
that that this if the school reveals the
information there's some harm could come
to the child I think those situations
are very very very rare but but I have
to concede that they probably do exist
and in those situations there should be
an exception so that the school is is uh
it does not have to reveal in in those
situations and in fact the bill contains
that language uh to allow the school not
to make disclosures in those rare
situations but I submit to you ladies
and gentlemen and Mr chair that what
that the real circumstance here I think
in the vast majority of cases
is that a teacher or the school system
believes that
it's okay to protect a child from having
to have not not from being victimized or
from Violence by the parents or
something like that but that it's okay
to protect the child from having to have
what may be an uncomfortable
conversation with their parents and I
submit respectfully that that's just not
the school's responsibility having
difficult conversations with your
parents is what we call life we all had
to have that during our lives and there
should be no legal reason why this why
we would allow a state or our schools
schools to be Exempted uh to to allow
students to be Exempted from that aspect
of life so I'm a strong supporter of the
bill I would just add very briefly that
um and I I that the there is a the
section of the current bill that defines
compelling State interest I think it is
it is worded incorrectly and I've spoken
to representative cordelli about this
um and I would uh I would suggest that
it needs to be changed and I have some
suggested language thank you Mr speaker
thank you very much judge any questions
okay thank you very much
thank you very much Mr chairs I'm
president Timothy Horrigan come from
Stratford County District 10 which is
the town of Durham and uh I think I
created a little bit of confusion
because I pressed the wrong radio button
on the website but I am in fact opposed
to this bill but as you see it's my
written testimony hopefully if I get far
enough into it my oral testimony I I do
acknowledge parents have rights and this
is something actually could be used as a
vehicle for certain things which I doubt
the Senator's responsive would be very
enthusiastic about but anyway and I'll
skip to the end of my written testimony
just very very quickly is that this does
include charter schools which a lot of
bills about public education don't but
it still doesn't cover the whole
universe of uh publicly funded and
subsidized education it says nothing
about the public Academy such as
Pinkerton or Rivendell in a
doesn't say anything about education
providers some of which are private
schools some which are the type of
entities who are being subsidized
through the uh
education Freedom account vouchers and
the other business tax credit thing and
certainly if we don't want public funds
being used for certain things in a
public school we probably don't want
them used for certain things and other
types of providers
and anyway also it would it would impose
significant new costs on public schools
so as such as an underfunded mandate so
I should think that should be enough for
21 20 to nothing Ito vote right there
that should be the end of the story for
a lot of people on the committee but
sadly I don't think it is and um just
very quickly say that I definitely
believe this is primarily directed
against LGBT trans kids and lbgt kids in
uh in general even though we're kind of
the proponents are kind of dancing
around that issue and um
so of course parents have rights but so
many children so many of the so-called
rights ostensibly guaranteed by SB 272
where right so parents simply don't have
children
even minors are people in their own
rights and they do have rights separate
from those of the parents and the
parents don't have the right to tell
their children how to think
um
well at least they can don't know the
right to tell the children what to think
um children have the right to think for
themselves no parent has the right to
tell an LGBT child not to be LGBT even
if such a thing was was possible and uh
just in general children have the right
to be who they are even their parents
don't approve and even non-lg even you
know CIS male heterosexual kids like me
um you know struggle a lot with their
identity in their teenage years and
their parents can't do everything for
them
and I'll also go back again once again
it's an unfunded mandate and once again
I
I would be amazed if uh
the fiscal note the education committee
during education did not bother to fill
out a fiscal note so uh
we had just asking this it's a totally
unfunded mandate and that really as I
said should be enough reason for 20 to
nothing itl however
we'll say there are things this could be
used as a vehicle for certain things
like well school funding possibly uh
updating curriculum standards or even
school safety such as we could use this
for a federal gun safety bill I don't
really anticipate that happening but
those would be Germaine amendments and
things you might consider so thanks
thank you representative questions from
the committee
if you have written testimony yes oh yes
represent McDonald
thank you Mr chair thanks for your
testimony in addition to everyone else
who's going to testify Yeah you
mentioned a financial burden yeah could
you just clarify for the committee where
the financial costs would be accrued for
informing parents which could prevent
costs from future lawsuits are not
informed so where is this cost that
you're talking about an unfunded mandate
I would say
well there's huge costs um it uh it's
going to uh it's going to create a lot
of cases where teachers are allowed to
tell things before they you know there's
going to be a lot more things that
schools have to track particularly the
part about one specific thing is the
part about clubs and student
associations which they currently aren't
required to track every Club association
or also attracting tracking what names
people are being called or even what
gender and also by the way this will
like make illegal a common form of at
least bullying that uh you know certain
CIS males students feel if they feel
like a
one of their male colleagues is not
sufficiently heteronormative you know
not sufficiently heterosexual they'll
often like call them A variation the
female variation of their name and call
the boy she and um
now schools are going to be required to
report that even though that's an
age-old form of bullying and you're
going to get some CIS male kids who
have appointed themselves you know
guardians of heterosexual Norms they're
now going to get in trouble which is not
entirely a bad thing in my opinion but
that does mean the schools will be
reporting a lot of behavior and dealing
with it that probably mostly now they
probably like chalk up the boys being
boys so you're going to get some uh
you're going to get like and you're
certainly going to get some CIS male
students are just overly enthusiastic
about their CIS male status and trouble
just because they're harassing uh
their their colleagues who they think
don't fit their standards of a of gender
identity but yeah so there's a lot of
costs and there's the education
committee refused to fill out the fiscal
notes I think that's not just one of
many reasons to be very suspicious of
this bill so nice I appreciate that
the list those concerns so I do
appreciate you saying that but I do not
see where a cost is associated with the
points you mentioned but thank you yeah
that's not my main reason the fiscal
impact but we do hear this committee
often turns things down even things with
really minimal or no cost because it's a
unfunded Monday we've had things that
are unfunded mandates that are like
versus not even a rounding error in
terms of the budget so thanks thank you
very much representative representative
Guthrie
thank you Mr chair and fellow colleagues
when I first read this bill I was
surprised that the number of rights that
parents already have I think even the
prime sponsor indicated all the irsks
that are already on the books so
I thought when I came here that my
opinion was going to be different than
everybody else but I think it's even
some of the information
is coming from the sponsors but
and I Mr chairman I be remiss if I
didn't say how good it is to see
democracy in action I wish we could have
this many people in the house we have a
regular session so I thank you for all
those who are coming on both sides so in
interest in that time I'm just going to
read my statement and leave it at that
and ask the committee to consider all
the facts and what is really in this
bill in their deliberations so I say
uh as I said before I'm Joe Guthrie uh
State Rep from Hampstead and I'm very
pleased to be here and I'm in favor of
both parental rights and
responsibilities but I oppose Senate
bill 272. I don't think there's a person
in this room this opposes parents rights
there's no reason to oppose marriage
rights my feeling is you already have
them
I would suggest that parents already
have the rights referred to in this bill
and that the bill is unnecessary this
bill is a mirror image of House Bill 10
which was heard by the children and
family laws committee and table by the
full House why was why should we
consider a second bill
this bill as written lists the right
parents already have there are more than
20 rsas referred to in this bill that
lists current rights and
responsibilities I am sure when parents
are involved in the PTA take an interest
in their school committee and through
teacher conference they are aware of
what's going on over there boys and
they already know whether or not their
boy or girl is failing to thrive they
don't need additional help from us if
there is a problem the prison rsas give
any help necessary I hope this committee
can agree that this bill could have a
weakening effect on a school systems in
New Hampshire public education is
threatened and has put Educators under
great strain
Senate Bill 272 reinforces that
perception we will be better soon
without action that divide us if we have
problems in any of our schools in any of
our cities and towns let's ask
what can we do to help
please reject this unnecessary Bill
thank you Mr chair thank you very much
representative
next representatives are representative
Mark balloon up represent a whole and
honorable Peter torosian
so that be the order
mark
oh thank you Mr chairman education I'm
Mark Malone I represent the town of
Epping LSA School principal at Epping
Elementary for 20 years and I was in
education for 40 years
what unites us here is again our concern
about children their upbringing in the
rights of parents
that isn't already
in practice or should be in practice in
good Public Schools
but I ask you why do we have a bill that
is divisive this bill is a wolf in
sheep's clothing there is so much good
that's written in this bill
but there's so much bad that can happen
now listen to the sponsor of the of this
bill who mentioned this the person who
was 18 who committed suicide when the
disclosure of his sexual identity
was about to be revealed or was
threatened
push that back six months to that
student is 17.
in six months
there was nothing that that speaker said
that would have protected that child a
school would have been would have been
required to disclose the same
information so what do you think would
we have a youth suicide problem do we
really want to
like I said we are united
in our concerned about the raising of
kids this bill devises
it is divisive and it should not be
passed thank you thank you very much
representative any questions from the
committee
thank you represent a hole followed by
representative torosian and then
representative selig
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee representative J.R Hull
serving the towns of Dunbarton Hooksett
Allenstown and epsom
I'd like to read the first section of
the bill pass the definitions
all parental rights are reserved to the
parents of minor children in the state
without obstruction or interference from
any school or School personnel
what we're talking about is a bill that
Fosters trust between parents and the
education system once information is
being withheld that then pollutes that
relationship that damages the
relationship between the parents and the
school system that Foster the current
system Fosters distrust by allowing this
bill to be passed into law we would have
greater trust between the parents and
and the school there should be nothing
to hide there should be no secrets last
year a very similar bill was put forward
and at the time of the committee of
conference there was a petition
circulated around I'm going to turn this
in his written testimony
over 1200 people signed that petition in
support of the bill that year which was
HB 1431 that was being supported by
reopen New Hampshire
I would ask that you would support this
bill as a co-founder of that
organization because it is important
that parents have a greater
understanding of what is going in the
school system thank you thank you
representative any questions from the
committee
welcome back
thank you chairman Ladd and members of
the edu House Education committee
I'm speaking today in favor in support
of Senate bill 272.
I believe it's a sad State of Affairs in
our state and quite frankly throughout
the country that it's come to this that
we need to have a bill like this but we
it's this bill quite simply is a common
sense bill that will ensure that parents
rights are upheld
and that parents
be involved with their children's
education
one of the proudest days I had in my
life and the happiest day was when my
two kids were born
I was there for both of their births it
was a miracle and quite frankly I
recognize and realize as a parent that I
have a tremendous amount of
responsibility and I shouldn't have to
and parents shouldn't have to give that
that uh responsibility away to the to
the government
we already have in law a mechanism for
parents where there's abusive situation
and where there's a problem in a family
to address that
and so I don't believe this will
interfere with that in any way
I as a ski coach I spent 13 years
coaching Timberland Varsity ski team
I saw student athletes on a regular
basis make bad decisions because when
you're young you do that sort of thing
and quite frankly many of them that I
saw go down a particular road is
students
once they became adults they they
changed their mind and and uh
and looked at things differently there's
a reason why you have to be a certain
age or drive a car there's a reason why
you have to be a certain age to smoke
cigarettes and to vote so
I stand Here wholeheartedly uh
supporting this bill and say that a
parent's rights should always Trump a
school administrative officials rights
unless there is a cause or a reason
again with his abuse so I want to thank
you for listening and on behalf of New
Hampshire parents please
pass Senate Bill 272. thank you thank
you very much
questions thank you representative seleg
reps honorable John Johnson Don Dodge
Johnson and representative Pat long in
that order
thank you Mr chair and members of the
education committee although I'm now a
state representative I used to be a
middle school and high school English
teacher been out of the classroom for a
while now and though he heard that my
job was done at 3 pm every day some of
my former students have just turned 40.
they're still in touch with me and they
continue to ask me for advice when they
need it
when I was a teacher I worked hard to
Foster relationships with my students so
they would feel safe and comfortable
talking with me about their problems
sometimes it was difficult to navigate
the situation with another teacher
sometimes it was because they'd had an
argument with their parents and needed a
safe space to vent so they could go back
and work through the issue
and occasionally it was to talk about
relationship issues they knew their
parents would not be comfortable with
in fact one of my specific
responsibilities as an advisor was to
create the type of safe space where
students could come talk to me to get
advice and guidance on how to navigate
challenging aspects of their lives
it was crucial I keep their confidence
because while they figured out these
issues
there were some occasions where kids
came to talk to me because they either
knew or suspected they were lesbian or
gay and wanted to figure out how to talk
to their parents about it they might
discuss their depression or maybe their
worries about their parents health
we would go through simple conversation
sample conversations and rehearse what
they were going to say
with me taking on different roles about
how their parents might react and
figuring out how to navigate it
in other cases kids might talk to me
about how to end a relationship with a
current partner in a way that wouldn't
be hurtful
if I hadn't had the ability to maintain
their privacy and their confidentiality
these kids would not have had a safe
Outlet
I now have two teenagers of my own I'm
very grateful to the other adults that
make up their Village these are teachers
parents of other children long time
family friends and others in general my
children do feel safe coming to talk
with me about pretty much everything
but they're also adolescents who have
times when they need to talk things
through before they talk with me or
their dad
because they have these other adults in
their life they know they can get the
support to navigate whatever life throws
at them
but finally I want to close with the
story from my own Community from five
years ago
we had a young man with an incredibly
promising future he was raised in a very
tight-knit religious family
he tried to come out to his family
he was seeking his parents love
that was denied
in his desperation and grief he took his
family's Minivan and drove at very high
speed into a barricade on I-95
it broke our community
teachers aren't trying to hide
information from parents
we're trying to make sure kids grow up
to be independent adults
teachers aren't telling kids to hide
anything
we're just trying to give kids a safe
space to be themselves
and for those parents whose children
choose not to speak to them perhaps the
conversation they should be have is why
their kids don't feel safe to talk to
them
I urge you to oppose this misguided bill
thank you very much representative any
questions from the committee
thank you
honorable Don Johnson then
good morning committee
my name is Don Johnson and I'm from
Laconia
I have a story to tell you how many of
you are parents
how many would you
would be horrified to get a phone call
from your school that your child didn't
get to school that day
you spend all day reaching out
asking everybody have you seen my
daughter
no one knows
you finally make a phone call and you
hear that the child is all the way
across the other side of the state
you have no idea why
you get there you try to get your child
to come out so you can take them home
and come to find out she thinks she's a
boy but you have no idea you can't help
her because you don't know the school
was telling her don't tell your mother
will keep it your secret
this child was tormented internally and
she had no one to talk to because the
schools were telling her keep it to
yourself don't tell your parents
will come to find out the mother was
horrified to know this that she could
not help her daughter
she pulled her daughter from the school
district
the doc she put a daughter in a good
counselor that she paid for not the
state
and guess what that daughter did not
want to be a boy she wants to be a girl
she is a beautiful young lady right now
she is thriving it's taken three years
for her to realize as a teenager in
middle school we all go through
crazy body changes and you don't know
what's going on doesn't mean you need to
change your sex
there are two Sexes male and female and
that is it God put us on this Earth to
be male or female and to get a phone
call like that that you have no idea
where your parent your child is
because the school has told you not to
say anything that's horrifying and I
would not wish that on any parent in any
way
so please pass this bill let's protect
our children let's protect the parents
and let's keep America great
thank you
representative Pat long and then
representative Sharon Packard
thank you Mr chairman uh and honorable
members of the committee
I'm Representative Patrick long
representative Hillsboro District 23 in
Manchester I speak in opposition to
Senate Bill 272 I'm sure you'll have
several opinions on this subject matter
so I'll keep my testimony brief
uh one of my concerns is uh with the
dismantling of trusted adults
part of the state at three years old my
parents weren't capable of raising me
my father moved out of state and my
mother was diagnosed with paranoid
schizophrenia leaving seven of ten
siblings that were still children
as testified earlier creatures of the
State of New Hampshire
um
I'm of the opinion that trusted adults
in my life enabled me in considering
positive advice not always taken however
but considered the trusted adult program
I believe is is one of the best I had
nobody to turn to except for teachers
coaches janitors anybody that an
orphanage could Supply with me
um
so that that is one of my concerns I
believe that the language in Senate Bill
272 Begins the erosion of The Trusted
adult
another concern is with the violation of
school Personnel from parents
specifically the fee shifting if parents
win the violation
the parents shall receive its attorney
fees and court costs
why wouldn't the taxpayer receive the
same consideration if we're going to be
suing school districts taxpayer paid
then why if a parent loses why wouldn't
the district receive their full costs
for for this
so that that's the other issue I have
so in closing I've also I've often heard
that bills from bills at a solution bill
is a solution looking for a problem
Senate Bill 272 is a solution that
creates several problems thank you Mr
thank you very much representative
welcome it's yours today Mr chairman
thank you
good morning
I want to sit here stand here in support
of Senate bill 272.
most you remember I was the Prime
sponsor of House Bill 10 and
unfortunately that got defeated in the
house I'm hoping and praying this bill
what this bill does
it protects children
and reaffirms parents fundamental right
to know what is happening in their
children's lives
it reaffirms a parent's right to be
truthfully and completely informed
if the school is taking part in their
child's Identity or transition
it protects students from unsus from
suspected unlawful abuse by preserving
the authority of the division of
children youth and families and other
child welfare agencies to exercise their
responsibilities on behalf of any child
that is in danger at home
what this bill does not do
it does not endanger students regardless
parents are responsible for the
upbringing of their own children
that's what Senate Bill 272 does but
text parents rights and ability to be
100 involved in their child's daily
lives
we support the parents right to know
what is happening to their children in
school
and I and most parents know
what the best decisions are for their
families
we support parents who want to be
involved in their children's lives and
take an active role in their education
irresponsible
rhetoric perpetrates the lie that school
Personnel know more than we do
it was a time when parents were being
labeled as terrorists and being attacked
simply for wanting basic transparency
opponents of this legislation say it is
dangerous and harmful
the only dangerous and harmful is
believing that parents do not have the
right to protect their own children
these are our children
not the states or the school districts
it's up to us to protect and raise them
with the help and assistance
of school officials not the other way
around
this is what Senate Bill 272 does
and that is why it must be passed thank
you Mr chairman and I know you have a
lot of other people so I won't take any
questions thank you very much Mr Speaker
representative Sullivan and then
represent love
ooh
looks like Greg is there a
representative Greg here
welcome thank you Mr Mr Speaker yeah my
name is uh Jared Sullivan I'm
representative from Grafton District 2
which is Frank keoni and Bethlehem up
north
um I come here today to sort of share my
story and the story of a close friend of
mine so my story is I'm actually a
bisexual man
being bisexual obviously for those you
don't know you're attracted to both
genders and it took me a while to figure
that out that's like that was a long
journey for me to figure that out and
was I gay was I straight was I confused
those are all the questions that ran
through my my mind there were times when
I was truly debating killing myself it
wasn't a serious oh that's very serious
but it wasn't a constant thing that I
was struggling with but there were
moments when I definitely felt that way
and it was because of the confusion of
what I was it took a long time to figure
it out and
if I had had a teacher had to force uh
be forced to tell my parents I think
that that would have been very
detrimental to me as I was trying to
figure out what I was it took me until
my adulthood to figure out what I was
and then I was able to comfortably talk
to my friends and family and get the
support that I needed from them at that
time and it wasn't always easy
my story would have been bad if if I was
outed by it by a school but I have a
story of a friend who is from a very
wealthy family and he knew from a young
age that he was gay
he grew up in a Mormon family they were
not he knew they were not going to
accept him as gay he was very clear to
him he said that from the beginning he
knew his game when he was young and um
so he had he's like I said he's wealthy
he had a trust fund that was set up for
him and upon 19 he was eligible to get
that trust fund because presumably he
could use it to go to college or
whatever so when he turned 19 he knew
he'd get that trust fund he came out to
his family and boom he has completely
cut out of his family and so I asked you
on the committee
is that abuse in the way that we think
of it if a teacher heard that story if
they knew he were gay and they were
asked by under this bill by his parents
whether or not they thought he might be
gay and then they outed him he was cut
out of losing his trust because he
wasn't yet 19 couldn't afford to pick
College because that's what it was set
up for would that be considered abuse I
mean it's not physical but it's
certainly emotional abusive socially
he's financially much worse off and we
know how he would have taken he's been
taken out of the will as well presumably
there would have been Millions we're
talking a family with hundreds of
millions he's been taken away from his
his will as well so I ask you when we
say that all families all parents love
their children
but it's not always unconditional and
this is a good example of it so I do ask
you to think of different perspectives
it's not just the cut and dry abuse that
might be physical that we can all see
with bruises on their faces but
sometimes it's it's it's a deeper level
of abuse that still leaves a child
harmed thank you thank you very much
representative any questions from the
committee
thank you uh representative love you're
there thank you Mr chair and committee
members and represent Andrus go ahead
represent love thank you Mr chair and
committee members uh my name is David
love I'm a representative from
Rockingham County District 13. and uh
you know uh I'm here to express my my
strong support for senate senate bills
uh two seven two seven two the uh the
folks here in opposition tell us that
the trans and gay gay children may be um
may be abused by unaccepting parents if
teachers uh can't withhold information
about a child's sexual orientation or
mental illness from parents
well we already have child abuse laws
that protect all children from from
abuse
these laws mandate teachers to report
suspected abuse of any child the dcy flr
enforcement and uh if if they suspect
that these these parents would be
unaccepting and possibly violent towards
the child they would have known long
before any any issues come up
you know many public schools and Schools
teachers and the school libraries are
using sexually explicit curriculum in
books using profane and obscene
materials and books with topics and
stories about sexual intercourse oral
sex anal sex straight sex gay sex
transsex bisex all kinds of sex okay
these are in our school libraries now
okay um
and they want the parents to have zero
zero say in what the children are taught
none whatsoever you know uh the fact
that we need this law to clarify our
existing uh our existing laws is uh is
upsetting to a lot of people
um
you know these these children are the
parents children and uh
they have the say in what the way they
should be brought up in parent and and
we have to we have to stand by parents
rights Sigmund Freud the father of
Psychiatry so that sexual issues or
major causes of psychiatric illness and
without a law to stop our school
teachers from literally
practicing Psychiatry that's what
they're doing when they're counseling
these kids okay with psychiatric illness
um you know we'll be subjecting children
to years of mental anguish
the family unit is a Bedrock of American
freedom and families issues and health
belong in the hands of the family not
someone with a teaching degree
medical doctors tell us that a little
bit of knowledge is dangerous
teaching degrees have minimal psychology
classes class requirements and I'll bet
zero Psychiatry training
the fact that we in New Hampshire need a
law like this and we do is proof that we
that we have certainly entered the
Twilight Zone may God help the children
of New Hampshire
please pass this Bill thank you very
much representative
questions from the committee not seeing
you thank you
representative Greg
good morning chairman and board members
thank you for your work on this and
thank you for taking my testimony I'm
Alicia Gregg one of the representatives
from Nashua I speak in opposition to SB
272 just as I did to hb10
with approximately 35 percent of our
population here in New Hampshire
experiencing domestic violence according
to the New Hampshire Coalition against
domestic violence and that's only who's
reporting so that's 35 percent we have a
problem it is not rare as a matter of
fact looking at the panel today seven of
you based on this statistic will have
are currently in an abusive relationship
or already have had an abusive
relationship
we need to ask ourselves what parents
are we helping with a bill like this who
is not having conversations about
important things with their kids
certainly not parents that have good
relationships with their kids my
children's biological father would have
been thrilled with a bill like this I
know most if not all of you have heard
me testify on this floor about the
situation that my children and I
survived
his view of his family was one of being
his property
he thought none of us had our own
autonomy especially our children
he thought he deserved to know every
facet he got our texts and emails on his
phone he always had to know what was
happening
this bill does not protect kids in
abusive homes because you don't know my
children and I were in a situation that
the experts involved said was one of the
worst cases of domestic Terror that they
had seen not resulting in a death during
the relationship
when my children's teachers found out
they were absolutely shocked none of
them had any idea
that they had this home life domestic
violence is a largely hidden epidemic
protection for our children is not found
in the file cabinet with a note on it
what better way for New Hampshire to
draw that line and say we are for the
unity of families we are also for the
safety of our children knowing the high
numbers of our vulnerable that need a
safe space than by rejecting this
damaging bill please hold parents
accountable and give them the honor of
building those relationships with their
kids thank you questions from the
committee
represent Andrus and then representative
Perez
thank you Mr chairman Louise
representative Louise Andrews Merrimack
County District 5 Andover Danbury
Salisbury Hill in Webster I am here as a
parent I'm a parent I'm a grandparent
and there's not much you can tell me
and fighting with the school some
parents do is nothing new back years ago
when my children were in school I had
one that hated the school it was too big
for her but there's no choice I had to
fight with her every day of the week and
my husband to tell her you are going to
graduate from school
when she was 17 going on 18 in December
she had all her credits in
and she wanted to go to work
my husband and I agreed
and she was going to go to work with me
we had to literally fight with the
school
for that child
was almost 18 to leave because they said
she couldn't graduate in June well guess
who won it was me as a parent
and when my children I gave birth there
was no teacher there in the birthing
room with me
when I stood up day and night with my
children because they are unhealthy
there was nobody there standing telling
me what to do and what not to do I stand
for every parent that they have the
right
to bring up their children as they see
fit and I'm going to leave with this
does any school system personnel
have the right to withhold
a child's health
or emotional well-being and I'm not
going to take any questions because I
know you live live limited to time but I
ask you all support SB 272 thank you
represent Perez then representative
Phillips
welcome
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is state
representative Maria Perez and I
represent District 43 in Milford pattern
parents rise over already exist house
bill
1612 was passed in 2018 giving the
parents the right to have the
information from the kids
first of all that's already and exists
second of all I want to say to the
people who already
speak in support of this bill
shame on you
I don't have to read any speeches I'm
going to speak from my heart
for people to say that school board
members
not being allowed parents to ask
questions nor allowing the parents to
have the right for information that's a
lie
I've been going around to school boards
to witness myself what is happening in
school boards
these hateful language is national
movement
against the right to people to have the
right
to
learn history
Real History the real history and now
they go in after the transgender
students the lbut community
let me tell you something this language
has been given wise Supremacy groups and
they're proud boys
the right to come to our communities
to use a hateful
to try to scare us
let me tell you we're not going anywhere
the lbdt community and the transgender
students there are humans like everyone
in this room
they are humans who deserves to be
respect
they are humans who had the right to
live freely
and I can tell you
I'm going to open my scars and it's hard
that I have to open the scars for people
to realize that parents not always right
I always have used sexual abuse by my
own father
and they only haven't that I had it was
when my my father used to told me I'm
gonna kill you mother with a machete if
you say something to the school when I
was sexually abused by him and people in
the community stayed quiet because he
was a well-known
with money and money by The Silence of
the people in my community
shame on the people who think that this
bill we protect the children no it's not
going to protect the children it's gonna
it's gonna put the children myself
and in powerful situation where parents
they're already abusing children and
this is going to give the parents the
right to continue abuse on the children
representing your time is up thank you
Mr chair I I will ask
the committee to but know about not on
this bill this is a hateful Bill we
don't need it in our state
thank you uh representative Phillips
then representative Cannon
thank you hi Emily Phillips here I
represent Fremont Rockingham District
Seven I stood outside a year ago holding
a bill I'm sorry a poster to support the
previous parental rights that did not
pass and I said what else can I do I'll
run for State Rep here I am
um there's no shame to support this bill
I think it's more in that we that that
was just mentioned I
was on the school board for three years
I'm currently homeschooling my two
developmentally dis delayed children
because the bill didn't pass last time
okay so the second time if we don't pass
this what kind of mass Exodus will we
see from the public school system in New
Hampshire I can't even imagine I I
follow the school board the enrollments
are down this is a bare minimum that
must be passed by this committee we must
pass it okay we want to have a minimum
level of trust with parents and the
students and what is going on in public
school we cannot allow this to not pass
okay that's what I want to say I have
the privilege of getting to go first I'm
sorry I'm taking time from other people
in the public to speak because they want
to be heard too
um please support this bill as proposed
pass it we have to we can't we need to
support the system right this is the
bare minimum people are going to pull
their kids out of the school if this
does not pass I assure you and guess
what if it doesn't pass people who are
watching us at home people here pull
your kids
I am working full-time I am a State Rep
I am homeschooling three three kids
there are other options for you reach
out school choice we have options my
kids go somewhere four days a week I run
a family business it can be done save
your kids if this does not pass but if
it passes
give it a chance okay like I would
re-enroll my kids just so we can get
their services okay just so they can get
support because they need it I would
re-enroll my kids in public school if
this past I'd consider it thank you very
much
representative Cannon and then
chair
and members of the committee
my name is representative Jerry Cannon I
represent Stratford District 12 at
Somersworth and Rollinsford
in my third term in the house
it used to be on the school board as
when Nick mention of the school board
board of directors and a corporation
and the
School Board doesn't control down to the
individual course construction
courses that are taught in the school
they provided Direction and the school
march to those orders
I'm concerned about this bill
for a number of reasons one of them is
I really appreciate parents having
rights that are that are discussed in
there and there are there are rsas that
already support a lot of what parents
should be able to do
I'm concerned that one person one set of
parents
rights May conflict with another set of
parents rights and it concerns me that a
teacher is going to end up having
multiple course plans to try and teach
students in their class because one set
of parents don't want to be their child
to be taught one way and another want
in Somersworth we struggled for six
months to put together a transgender
policy
the policy we ended up coming up with
was good not complete but good
and we support in Somersworth we support
transgender children who have their
parents support
and the teachers are told they need to
address those students by the name they
identify as by the gender they identify
as and by the pronouns they want to use
it does leave a hole for those children
that aren't supported by their children
but
children that are having trouble trying
to talk to their parents that's what I
had a problem with back in the 1960s
I was a mediocre student
but I couldn't share what was going on
with me with my loving parents and I was
current because the community wouldn't
understand and I would embarrass my
parents
I didn't come out until I was 45 years
some of the problems
associated with school especially for
gender identity is is that in the case
of ask talking to a teacher
who should be using
their the name
listed on the system
is that the name that they may be given
by the student might be the name that
the parent expects them to be called
it may not be their legal name to start
off with but they may be in the process
and part of the challenge is a child in
school with a gender identity concerned
is going to be
in the process of working with doctors
and psychiatrists and therapists and
their parents represented you running
out of time run out of time
thank you
um
I'm going to leave the rest of my
text for you yeah if you can give us a
copy I'd appreciate it representative
uh good morning Mr chair and members of
the committee thanks and members of the
committee for having to
be those that have this very difficult
decision to make
I'm here not to tell you how I feel I'm
here to tell you that I promised my
constituents
that I was going to vote for them
not my conscience and there's a lot of
talk here when you're a representative
about should I vote my conscience or
should I not
I'm not going to do that I'm going to
vote for my constituents and what I'm
telling you folks on the committee
the people in Bristol and Bridgewater
the majority they have spoken to are in
favor of this bill
it's as simple as that and the
conversation that I get from that is
when people hear
that a teacher may not have to tell a
parent something about their child they
literally say what are you kidding me
that can't be right
that it can't be right that a teacher
can withhold something from a parent
about their child so I'm here to ask you
I'm telling you I'm here to support this
for my constituents not for myself and I
ask you to do the same thank you thank
you very much representative Senator
welcome
thank you
hi everybody my name is Heather Raymond
I'm the current state rep for
Hillsborough District 5 Nashua before
running for this office I've dedicated
my life to serving children and families
in my community I was a forensic
interviewer working with the New York
State Police to interview child victims
of sexual violence for five years then
when my family moved to New Hampshire I
worked for dcyf as first an assessment
worker and then a foster care case
worker then I worked for Casa as a
program manager supervising Court
advocates for children in foster care I
stopped working a full a few years ago
due to a brain tumor but I continued my
advocacy for Children and Families by
running for the Board of Education in
Nashua where I served as the president
for several years the clerk and I'm now
the chair of the policy committee so my
narrow areas of expertise exactly
coincide with the matters under
consideration and SB 272
let me Begin by reminding this committee
that I spoke on the sister bill hb10 in
the well last month many of my concerns
for hb10 are transferable to asb272 this
bill has been opposed by every major
child advocacy group in the state
including Nami New Hampshire Waypoint
Seacoast Outreach and most importantly
the office of the New Hampshire child
advocate the legislature created the
Office of the child advocate after a
number of high-profile child deaths in
the state to help us attend to our
mandate to prioritize the best interests
of children when considering legislation
sb272 fails this critical test because
it seeks to seeks to undermine the
current mandated reporting law to dcif
by creating a new higher standard for
school Personnel when considering child
safety SB 272 requires that the reporter
have clear and convincing evidence for
concerns and institutes a new unfunded
mandate for documentation the current
threshold under state law for dcyf is a
preponderance of the evidence
this will increase the danger for
children in abusive or neglectful
households anyone watching the news
these days knows that New Hampshire has
a problem with parents who take things
too far the last thing our community
needs is to make it easier for abusive
parents to utilize institutions to
further control and harm children
the second test for consideration
regarding bills for bills regarding
children in schools is whether the bill
is in the academic best interests of
children
sb272 fails this test this bill will
undermine our children's success by
requiring teachers to focus on tracking
students romantic and personal lives
instead of leaving those private family
matters alone and sticking to their
academic content areas it should be
noted that items a through S in the
proposed Bill are already in State
Statute and I printed this information
for the committee's review
this is already representative
education's website
if you have written testimony we'd
appreciate that thank you
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
Mr chair for the record I am Senator
Deborah alchiller from District 24. I'll
provide my testimony at the end you've
been asked today to keep an open mind
and you've been told children are the
possession of parents and indeed I urge
you all to keep an open mind and
remember that children are people
they're not chattel parents are
responsible for their children they're
supposed to provide them with care and
keeping provide for their medical care
shelter food and clothing can we
legislate parents to love their children
can we legislate that parents should
protect their children no we can't in
fact you heard today that teachers are
now going to be responsible for
reporting out to parents so that
children must engage in what has been
described from this microphone as
uncomfortable conversations what could
possibly be uncomfortable
would it be because some parents
wouldn't approach what has been called
an uncomfortable conversation with Grace
understanding and open minds you have
heard from my colleague from this
microphone that this will make the
problem worse
what problem
are parents having problems they need
the legislature to solve this bill
states that parents May Sue an educator
for declaratory damages if they believe
the educator has violated this upcoming
law this bill is designed to assume that
every parent has just somehow missed out
on the opportunity to talk with their
children about their gender identity
think about this as a parent and there
are lots of us in the room here today
did you create a gender neutral home and
specifically create spaces for your
child to explore their own identities
was that provided to you
I would Hazard that the answer is no we
live in a society that assumes certain
gender norms and only one percent of our
population doesn't conform to that
standard and even fewer have the
opportunity to figure out who they are
with their family and community support
for that exploration parents have rights
sure they also have responsibilities if
parents were all excellent we wouldn't
need a Department of Youth and families
we wouldn't need an office of the child
advocate we wouldn't need child
protection laws we wouldn't need the
safe adult program the sad reality is we
do parents need to take responsibility
for their own relationships they
shouldn't need to be pumping the other
adults in children's lives for
information right
they should we they should be working to
keep the lines of communication open
right they should be treating their
children with respect due to any human
being just trying to figure out who they
are who they want to be and how they
want to live their life if a parent's
relationship is so weak so tenuous that
it is threatened by a teacher using a
new nickname for a child who is doing
the business of growing that's the
parents problem suing Educators because
parents haven't created a safe space at
home to have so-called difficult
conversations is nothing short of
ridiculous and I urge you to reject this
legislation thank you thank you senator
representative Popovich Mueller then
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee and everybody in the audience
for being here obviously this is one of
those bills that does attract a lot of
controversy and it's good to hear
everybody speaking politely and kindly
for or against it at the end of the day
we are here to
express our thoughts and let the people
who are going to vote you know vote
their conscience
I'm speaking as a republican from
Windham but more specifically there is a
republican from Windham that while being
on the school board
pushed for the very controversial
transgender rights you know jbab policy
and got it passed so I'm not your you
know predictable person let's put it
this way I voted for that because I felt
it was necessary to protect the rights
of those kids who need to find their own
way
but to address a couple of the things
that were said earlier
this bill as proposed does not have
anything to do with changing the
requirements for mandatory reporting the
clear and compelling interest in the
bill refers to the circumstances in
which the school does not meet the
threshold to report the dcyf but decides
internally to violate certain parent
rights those are very separate parts of
the legislation
I will also say that I don't think that
anybody speaking here should be ashamed
or embarrassed just because they're
expressing a point of view other people
may disagree with this is not the way I
feel politics should be conducted and
this is definitely not the way I
approach legislation
you do need a bill of parental rights
because at the end of the day there are
quite a few School administrations who
feel that they don't necessarily have to
serve their parents and protect their
rights but they have to do things
because they know better than the
parents
and this is not the right culture yes
there will always be edge cases there
will always be parents who may not
necessarily do the right things that's
why we have the dcyf that's why we have
the provisions in this law to address
those cases but overall we should
respect the rights of the parents to
control their kids education remember
Public Schools we have laws that require
kids to be educated we are mandating
that people get that education and
therefore we should give them the rights
to control that education in certain
ways
so the last
point that I want to make is that there
is a very controversial provision in the
law according to everybody I speak with
in regards to the school being required
to disclose if the kid is openly you
know um came out of the closet at school
and to keep that a secret from their
parents All I'm gonna say in regards to
that provision is I have no idea why
it's controversial because I cannot
think of one situation in which a kid
comes out at school
and everybody in town doesn't know about
it in a few weeks seriously schools
gossip everybody talks and I see the red
flag which means I'm reaching out of my
the end of my time so I want to just
thank everybody for taking the time
every member of the committee knows how
to reach me if they want further
comments and I'll leave it at that thank
you thank you very much representative
representative Raymond followed by
um
okay so represent representative uh
she spoke okay sure Mana
thank you Mr chairman honorable
colleagues I stand today in opposition
to SB 272 section 3A States the nothing
in the bill shall authorize a parent of
a minor child in this state to engage in
conduct that is unlawful or to abuse or
neglect his or her mine or child in
violation of General law this is an
argument we heard many times today and
with regard to hb10 we are assured that
any parent who abuses their child will
be punished
punishment of the perpetrator means
little when we should have been focusing
on helping to prevent the abuse in the
first place
the American Academy of Pediatrics has
reported the transgender youth are
significantly more likely to be
psychologically or physically abused
than their cisgender peers the center
for American progress reports that 20 to
40 percent of homeless youth are gay or
transgender compared to only five to ten
percent of the overall youth population
leaving aside for a moment the fact that
the vast majority of psychological abuse
goes unreported and unpunished punishing
an abusive parent after the fact does
nothing to undo the damage they have
caused it certainly does nothing to heal
the wounds they have left behind
most children can and will talk to their
parents if they have questions about
their sexual orientation or gender
identity and most parents I believe will
listen to and love their children even
when they make choices their parents do
not fully understand or even like
children who do not have those support
structures and who genuinely fear the
repercussions of revealing their true
selves however need safe spaces where
they can be themselves and laugh and
love and grow even if it is not within
the family
we are constantly told the parents know
their children but why do we not also
hear that children know their parents
certainly far better than you or I
sitting here in Concord
if one of my children felt for whatever
reason they could not come to me to talk
about intimate questions and concerns I
would of course be hurt
but my child is not my property
my love for my child and my
responsibility to care for and nurture
my child does not give me property
rights over them
I would want them to have a responsible
adult whom they trusted with whom they
could talk I would want what is best for
them I would want them to get the care
that they need period
we heard testimony from a number of
young people on HB 10 who said that they
could not have spoken to their parents
about their sexual orientation or gender
identity for fear of abuse or being
kicked out of their homes
they said that they did not know what
they would have done or what they might
have done to themselves if they did not
have a place to go every day where they
felt free to be who where they were
with people they trusted and respected
to talk to
why are we not talking about their
rights
that's what we should be talking about
today I want to talk about is rightfully
the child's this is an inalienable right
which is inseparable from the rights to
life liberty and pursuit of happiness I
strongly urge you to vote ought not to
pass thank you very much representative
good afternoon Mr chair and committee
thank you for taking my testimony I'm
here today to ask you to um i.tl this
bill
there are two types of people in the
room here today those of us who have had
the experience of coming out to our
parents and those of us who have not
I employ the committee to listen to
those of us who have lived this
experience we're United in telling you
that this bill is dangerous and it puts
trans children in danger and let me
explain why
the fear of rejection is overwhelming
and that fear is greatest When It's
associated with your parents let me say
that my mother was not the first person
I came out to and she wasn't even the
second
children become aware that they are
somehow innately different when they're
very young different from the siblings
different from the parents
and they learn to keep those differences
secret when they're very young as well
they learn that the society stigmatizes
being LGBT
they hear the queer jokes they see the
news about hearings like this and they
internalize the transphobia that they
see in here in society
coming to terms with being different in
this way is a frightening process and
the fear of rejection can often push
children to do self-harm a child needs a
safe place to learn how to accept
themselves before they come out to
others outing a child before they're
ready especially to a parent can drive
that child to self-harm and indeed to
Suicide the suicide rates for LGBT
children are four times higher than
their heterosexual counterparts and I
have no doubt that if the language in
this bill becomes lower somewhere in the
state of New Hampshire a child will kill
themselves and their parents will spend
the rest of their lives wondering why
I say to you today that if there is a
one chance in a million that legislation
you enact will drive a child to commit
suicide you must vote itl
thank you thank you
representative Perez
Christine
thank you
I am a freshman representative from
Londonderry New Hampshire I had
absolutely no intent content of speaking
today but I am here as a legislator
because parents put me here
I spent two years speaking for parents
at school board meetings at Town
meetings
then they asked me to run they asked me
to run because they needed a voice here
I am the voice of those parents it had
nothing to do with any particular
type of child any particular gender it
had to do with the fact that there were
many reasons why these parents felt that
they did not have a voice in the schools
that's why I am here this is about the
parents
this is about
all the children all the children we
cannot provide I had a grandfather say
to me we cannot provide
equity for a hundred percent of the
people the children and the parents a
hundred percent of the time but we need
to provide safety for all the children
all of the time especially in sensitive
situations
parents are the number one lovers of
their children we don't all agree with
them we all get angry with them but more
are far more parents out there that
accept their children
for who they are
always think of those parents they need
a voice too please pass this bill my
constituents were heartbroken
heartbroken that the house
parental rights Bill failed
thank you very much and the last speaker
we're going to have before we take a
break here for lunch will be Diana
Martin she is from the state of New
Hampshire Administrative Office of the
Courts
welcome
I apologize you caught me by surprise
for the record my name is Diane Martin I
am the director of the administrative
office of the courts and I am not here
to take a position on the policy related
to this bill I am just here to ask for
an amendment I shared the amendment with
the chair and members of the committee
yesterday
and we also shared this with Senator
Carson
we are looking to uh
amend the bill to remove RSA 186 colon
11 comma Roman numeral 9C
the reference in section c
the intent of the section of this bill
is to provide that the chapter not
applied to a court law enforcement
officer or government agency responsible
for child welfare acting in their
official capacity
the statutory reference we are asking to
be removed is a duty of the State Board
of Education and not a duty of the
courts and so we would ask that that
provision be removed to clarify this
bill
any questions thank you very much are
there any questions from the committee
we do have a copy of that so we'll share
with all the committee members thank you
very much and at this time we are going
to take a a break for our folks to
stretch up stretch a little bit and have
a bite to eat then we'll come back in a
go ahead and take further testimony what
I'll do is I'll just work through these
cards and if somebody is here please
stand up and let us know you're here and
you can come to the mic
Karen Hill's not here
so Karen you're a city councilor up in
Lebanon I am yes welcome thank you I'm
also the Grafton County Treasurer it's
nice to see you representative
members of the committee
I was not expecting to be called so
quickly so I just will pull up my
testimony here it is
thank you
I'm here today to testify in opposition
to this legislation known as the
parental Bill of Rights we've heard
people say that parents know what is
best for their children they have said
that this bill protects children
but it's time for us to face reality
there is a child safety crisis happening
in New Hampshire
Harmony Montgomery was five years old
when she was murdered her own father was
charged in her death
Brielle Gage was three years old when
she was beaten to death by her mother
and those are cases that dcyf was
actually involved in there are far more
that go unreported and unaccounted for
these children would certainly have
benefited from State resources and
attention being focused on the plight of
at-risk children in New Hampshire and
the current biennium there were 22 dcyf
positions proposed an emotion was made
to cut that in half and to only fund
them if needed
the state is literally ignoring and
underfunding a known group of at-risk
children if people want to protect
children in New Hampshire there are some
very practical and real steps that we
can take
this bill is not one of them
in fact nearly every single right in
this bill is already existing in state
law and provided to parents if a parent
wants to know what classes their child
is taking if they want to know what
books are being assigned and films are
being watched if they want to prevent
their child from participating in sex
education they already have the ability
to do all of these things what this bill
actually does is to Target one
particular group of minors for
surveillance in school
this is outright discrimination and it
is inconsistent with New Hampshire
values of freedom and equality not only
does this bill fail to protect children
it actually harms them
my own 16 year old testified last month
against both SB 272 and hb10 and is not
available today due to school
obligations so in conclusion I will
reiterate the first-hand testimony that
my own child previously provided
my name is Zoe Hill I am a 16 year old
Junior at Lebanon High School I am here
today to oppose SB 272 this bill will
not directly affect me because I am
lucky enough to have parents who support
me and my identity as a trans kid but I
know multiple people who could face harm
if this bill passes they are out in
school but not at home because their
families might not accept them if this
bill passes and their parents found out
they are trans then their homes would
become an even more dangerous place for
them in conclusion please oppose this
bill for the sake of trans kids all
around the state
thank you thank you
next person uh viriana Mullen is she
here
dear hello house committee members my
name is obviously I'm not with Lake
Williams but I am Kathy Rago and Lily is
unavailable today so she asked me to
read her testimony which can we speak a
little closer to the mic yeah is that
better yeah
okay dear House Education committee
members my name is Lily Tang Williams I
am a Chinese American growing up in
communist China
and lived there for 23 years
every child in China belongs to the
state parents have no rights I was
subjected to the whims of central
planners and their forced indoctrination
the CCP had full control over education
from curricula to standards from testing
to data collection from Secret student
files to mandatory vaccinations in
schools
here's my child portrait in middle
school which I will give you when I'm
done and which was used in my student
file my parents had to pay for the
annual portraits and submitted them to
the schools this file which no parents
were allowed to see collected and track
students data including but not limited
to grades speeches behaviors rewards
violations punishments physical mental
health class religion Etc these records
were transferred to the colleges or
employers and called Personnel files
when we graduated from high school I was
forbidden to see my own record and I'm
unable to see it now in the past these
records were kept on paper now they are
digital what concerns me is that what I
saw in China and why I left is also
happening here in the United States the
fact that I feel I must testify to
support a parent's Rights bill is really
rather amazing and concerning but I
think this bill is absolutely necessary
in today's political climate and
tomorrow's it clarifies and protects one
of the most ancient rights of all human
rights parental sovereignty the deepest
human bond is between parents and their
children the bond between parent and
child must be protected and not torn
apart by any political agendas in
America children still belong to their
parents not to the government not to the
institutions not any Collective groups
parents must have the right to know what
their children are taught in schools
schools should not be political
battlefields or indoctrination centers
they should be places of Joyful learning
focusing on academic subjects like
Reading Writing Math and Science but not
places of social engineering with
divisive political agendas and age and
appropriate content
our kids need us more than ever they are
the most vulnerable innocent and
precious human beings and need our love
guidance and protection my parents could
not protect me in China because they had
no rights but this is America where
children belong to their parents I urge
you to vote Yes on this bill Lily Tang
Williams
thank you
sorry about that wow I'm just really
thriving today
um
you gotta get really close that's cool
there it's on now it's on all right is
everyone awake after lunch uh good
afternoon Jennifer Jones office of the
child advocate
um so I'm here today
um to reiterate the beautiful testimony
given by Cassandra Sanchez uh the child
advocate here for in the state of New
Hampshire and although the office of the
child advocate understands and respects
parents fundamental rights we have a
statutory Duty under RSA chapter 21v to
protect the rights of children and
that's what I'm here to talk with you
about this afternoon
so you've heard already
um you know testimony from
Representatives here that spoke already
the beautiful testimony provided by
representative Raymond and her robust
background in child welfare I too have
that a similar background in that I was
a child forensic interviewer for many
many years interviewing nearly 2 000
children here in our state who came to
talk with me about abuse and or neglect
and I can tell you
with a reasonable degree of certainty
their ability to access a safe and
trusted adult to talk about what may
have happened to them is Paramount in
our ability to keep children in the
state safe
I can tell you that oftentimes they
would go to a teacher and tell them
something had happened when they didn't
feel it safe or appropriate to tell a
parent and this is not
a testament to the child's relationship
with the parent it's that they were able
to access somebody that they didn't have
the same emotional connection to
somebody that they could go to and say
something's going on and I need to
process and talk with you about it can
you help and you also heard a beautiful
testimony
by representative Perez who talked about
her own history as a child sexual abuse
victim you talked you heard
representative long talk about the
importance of one trusted adult and
that's what we're here to talk about
today in the context of the office of
the child advocate is the best interest
of children here in our state and so we
stand in opposition to this bill and
thank you very much next person up is
thank you Mr thank you Mr chairman and
thank you members of the committee my
name is Dan Richards I'm from Aetna New
Hampshire which is a village inside of
Hanover
please support I urge you SB 272 this
bill is about one thing and one thing
only
the truth
citizens will try others will try to
convince you that 270 that SB 272
targets certain categories of people
that it puts children in danger and that
parents can't quote unquote handle the
truth
they are wrong
the reality is that policies throughout
the state of New Hampshire require
School Personnel to conceal information
from parents and when directly
questioned lie
this is unconscionable
and it must be stopped
what our elementary school age children
first and third grade we're at SAU 70 in
Hanover I'm also a 1991 grad
there were concerted efforts by school
Personnel to conceal and exclude parents
from accessing information highly
relevant to the education of our
children especially surrounding topics
of sex gender and race
our new associate principal Nan Parsons
broadcasted the community that she was
going to have quote unquote difficult
conversations with our children lead a
social transformation of the school and
form a book group that compared the U.S
to Nazi Germany when I asked what she
meant by this she refused to answer on
our exchange ended with the
superintendent accusing me of borderline
harassment simply for wanting to know
what was going to be taught to my kids
at no time was I in civil or
disrespectful
to this day no parent knows what changes
are being implemented in the school
curriculum and what leadership plans
because they will not tell us
recently friends reported that their
kindergarten was being told to draw
himself like when he got out of the
tubby or out of the shower with a
specific and explicit focus on drawing
I also resubmitted a letter to this
committee detailing the pornographic
material in the school libraries which
is being actively promoted to students
but is hidden from parents because it is
not included
in the card catalogs accessible to
parents for review the graphic images of
young boys fellating each other young
girls tasting each other's vaginal
juices boys engaging in Circle Jerks
before being forced to drink cups of
semen is unacceptable
if you don't think this is happening
I can assure you that it is I have
pictures of the entrance table of our
Middle School library where these books
are displayed
and promoted
there is also a school policy jbab which
has been mentioned previously
which instructs school officials to
conceal information regarding gender
issues from parents and to lie to them
if directly questioned as you can
imagine we are completely we completely
disagree with any policy instructing
School Personnel to lie to parents there
are dozens of lawsuits occurring around
the country including in Manchester New
Hampshire or a girl with socially
transitioned in secret
I urge you please to support SB 272 let
us restore trust in the schools we love
our schools we want to be able to
educate our kids here
please vote to affirm it thank you thank
you uh next individual is Quincy and
then ciao Kelly following Quincy's
from the New Hampshire Asian American
coalition
um
hello can you hear me
okay
is this mic on over here or
it's on hello testing okay thank you I'm
gonna have to be right up against almost
not touching but
thank you dear House Education members
my name is ciao Kelly I'm from Vietnam
I'm a Vietnamese American who fled
communism I came to New Hampshire as a
political Refugee almost 30 years ago I
am here to represent the New Hampshire
Asian American coalition to support SB
272 the parent parental Bill of Rights
in education
is a Civic and social organization
providing positive voice while
supporting and helping Asian Americans
Asian Americans in the is the second
largest minority group in New Hampshire
with the three percent of the population
and four percent after the Hispanic our
group has many members who are
immigrants who fled totalitarian regimes
like China and Vietnam we came here
because we believe that America is the
land of the free and Home of the Brave
where we came from the parental rights
do not exist nor are they protected all
the oppressive regimes believe and act
as if all children belong to the state
not the parents and treat them as
birthing machines
therefore parents have no say about
their kids education and they don't have
the right to access their kids personal
data
Communists always indoctrinate kids and
turn children against their parents
if parents dare to correct their kids of
what state teaching is wrong then they
can be arrested and thrown in prison
without any due process
We Believe parental rights are the
fundamental human rights and they must
be protected
parents have the right to know what is
taught in schools ask questions and
inspect school materials parents have
the right to access and review school
records timely and attend the children's
class as Observers
parents have the right to make all the
medical decisions for their children one
quick example I used to be vaccinated
many times on both of my shoulders with
shots that I didn't even know what they
were
my parents were not aware of any of
these events and never mind about giving
consent there is no such a concept about
parental consent in Vietnam
nurses just showed up in our school and
all the kids have to line up to get shot
with thou disposable needles
so nurses use the same needle for all
kids
only God knows what kind of disease was
transmitted via those needs no you're at
the end of your time right now oh sorry
thank you so I urge you to please vote
Yes on this Bill thank you so much we
really appreciate it thank you
hi I'm Quincy I'm sorry I was just in
the hallway when I was called what is
your name again Quincy from Dover okay
Quincy from Dover go ahead hi
um hello Quincy pronounce she her hers
from Dover
um I'm here to testify against SB 272
again because of its blatant homophobic
and transphobic nature
in addition to being an overall
ridiculous attempt to undermine teachers
ability to teach and support their
students
I'm queer took me a lot of years to
figure that out
it was something I was always passionate
about even before I identified that way
queer and trans rights so there were
rumors flying around school about me
being gay since I was in Middle School
um including you know teachers
questioning and wondering that
um
it would have really been detrimental to
my mental health if that information was
shared with my parents before I felt
comfortable talking to them
um I am lucky to have more Super
supportive parents than most but I
wanted to be really sure because you
know kids are figuring themselves out in
many many ways and I think it's kind of
jumping the gun a little bit to have to
report on every single thing that
children are figuring out to their
parents
um
coming out is a big deal you know no
matter what
um so outing students is harmful I want
to be clear we've heard a lot of talk
today about hard conversations we are
talking about the potential for violence
and abuse I know there are laws around
it we know that still does not prevent
all children from being abused by their
parents especially the rates at which
queer and trans youth
experience that
um I talked to my parents when I was
ready in college on my own terms and I'm
really grateful for that
um I think of my younger siblings still
going through the school system here and
how I want them to have the freedom to
figure themselves out
I would also add if you have a good
relationship with your child if you
demonstrate that you are supportive
loving and non-judgmental you wouldn't
need to force teachers to report on your
child's every move to you
teachers support students not
indoctrinate them
teachers support students often even
when their parents don't so I ask you to
please not take that support away and to
vote itl on this Bill thank you thank
you very much
the next two speakers are going to be uh
viriana Mullen followed by Laura speak
and Laura will need a chair
until we get the chair there's the chair
okay
mostly the chair is there so that if my
chronic dizziness um
kicks in I have somewhere to sit that's
not the floor
um
hi my name is Laura speak I live in
Windham I grew up in Meredith I went to
the same high school that my mother and
my grandfather did
I am in fact a fourth generation local
um
I submitted
quite a lengthy written testimony last
night
um technically this morning
but what I want to read aloud today are
the words of
a transgender child who cannot be here
today because in 2014
she looked at her life decided it wasn't
I'm going to try to get through it
without crying I am sorry for how
triggering this content is but it is
important that you hear the words of the
people that this law would affect and
hurt
if you are reading this it means that I
have committed suicide and obviously
failed to delete this post from my cue
please don't be sad it's for the better
the life I would have lived isn't worth
living in because I'm transgender
I could go into detail explaining why I
feel that way but this note is probably
going to be lengthy as it is
to put it simply I feel like a girl
trapped in a boy's body and I felt that
way ever since I was four
I never knew there was a word for that
feeling nor was it possible for a boy to
become a girl
so I never told anyone and just
continued to do traditionally boyish
things to try to fit in
when I was 14 I learned what transgender
meant and cried of happiness
after 10 years of confusion I finally
understood who I was
I immediately told my mom and she
reacted extremely negatively telling me
that it was a phase that I would never
truly be a girl that God doesn't make
mistakes that I am wrong
if you are reading this parents please
don't tell this to your kids even if you
are Christian or against transgender
people don't ever say that to someone
especially your kid that won't do
anything but make them hate themselves
that's exactly what it did to me
my mom started taking me to a therapist
but would only take me to Christian
therapists so I never actually got the
therapy I needed to cure me of my
depression
I only got more Christians telling me
that I was selfish and wrong and that I
should look to God for help
when I was 16 I realized that my parents
would never come around and that I would
have to wait until I was 18 to start any
sort of transitioning treatment
which absolutely broke my heart
the longer you wait the harder it is to
transition I felt hopeless that I was
just going to look like a man in drag
for the rest of my life
on my 16th birthday when I didn't
receive consent from my parents
to start transitioning I cried myself to
sleep I formed a sort of Fu attitude
towards my parents and came out as gay
at school thinking that maybe if I eased
into coming out as trans it would be
less of a shock
although the reaction for my friends was
positive my parents were pissed they
felt like I was attacking their image
and that I was an embarrassment to them
they wanted me to be their perfect
little straight Christian boy your time
is up okay
her name was Leela Alcorn and I
encourage you to research her words
thank you
Sam Diaz augustino
Sam
hello thank you committee members for
listening to me today
my name is Sam D'Agostino and I am
discussing Senate Bill set 272. I'm a
trans non-binary person 18 attending
Nashua Community College and a previous
student of the New Hampshire High School
System
this is not my first time testifying
before the New Hampshire House of
Representatives my first experience was
back in 2019 as a 14 year old freshman
and support of Bill 263 a
non-discrimination bill for K-12
students that included protections on
the basis of gender identity
since the beginning of my high school
experience
and coming out as transgender I've had
to defend my right to be safe and
respected as a student for myself for my
friends and for my peers across the
state
five years later I'm here to protect the
Youth of my community that are somehow
stuck in the same position
I'll be supporting them today by sharing
my experience they could not exist in a
future with this legislation
from as early as the first grade I
expressed feelings of queerness and
gender non-conformity
despite many efforts of trying to
express this feeling my mother told me
not to express these feelings in public
or at school out of concern for my
safety
the summer before my freshman year of
high school I decided if I wasn't given
permission and support to be myself I
would have to take the steps to be
authentically me on my own
I knew going from my small Middle School
of Waterville Valley to the larger
Regional High School of Plymouth New
Hampshire I had a clean slate to
introduce my true self
I emailed my teachers ahead of time
asking them to use my preferred name and
pronouns and let them know I read the
syllabus
it was not until open house night that
my mother found out I was going by these
different name and pronouns
she greatly resisted the social
transition but it was the time that I
had come out in school felt the support
of my teachers and my friends and the
joy of being my true self that gave me
the strength to resist back and express
within a year of being myself my mother
began to learn understand and support my
identity for which I am lucky as a
parent she was finally given the right
and ability and opportunity to meet the
adult I was becoming and my coming out
is the reason we still have a loving
strong relationship today
if we are to allow young adults to sign
up for classes get a license to drive
influence medical decisions apply for
college and ultimately make choices that
will affect their career an entire
future trajectory then we must allow
them to make decisions about how they
are dressed and feel most authentic
thank you thank you for your testimony
are there any questions from the
committee now see you thank you very
much if you have written testimony would
you please provide it to the clerk
uh Allison Dyer followed by Sandra
Gagnon
hi Allison Dyer Nashua New Hampshire I
submitted a length year testimony but
I'll just read a portion
so I as well as many parents have stood
for our local school boards and state
legislators across the state to claim
the right parents rights we have been
met
by government officials who declare
themselves the
ultimate determiners of what is best for
our children are told the rights that
we've stated that we thought were
enshrined by such things as the 14th
amendment that they don't apply in this
instance or the coverall word and
education FERPA
forgetting there is a difference between
privacy and secrecy this includes
growing instances of schools actively
hiding curricula or critical information
about our children's mental physical
health from parents a Time old adage
Still Remains
safe adults don't ask children to keep
secrets
why would our taxpayer-funded education
system want to keep secrets from parents
in communities in which they live and
work
the simple fact that the pressure of
keeping a secret can prevent a child
from telling someone something important
or it can get in the way of keeping them
safe or it can cause hesitation when
asking for help
feel like that's the pause that
opponents of this bill need please also
remember that it's natural for children
to worry about their parents in
uncomfortable situations with some of
their social ideological or identity
issues but their discomfort is never
dissuaded our schools from informing
parents of things like declining grades
absenteeism conduct problems and all of
these cases our schools know that
parents are best equipped to manage and
support their children
so please support SB 272 so we can all
unite around protecting all children and
uphold common decency standards in our
Public School environments thank you
thank you very much
uh Sandra Gagnon
can you hear me okay yeah followed by
Beth scare
I'm here to testify as a parent and as a
former teacher
we've heard that SB 272 does have an
exemption against teachers forcibly
outing a student in the case of abuse
I want to speak to how difficult it is
to know if outing a student a minor
student will put that child's mental
health and possibly their life in danger
let me tell you my family's story
my eldest child
in high school was starting to learn
about her sexual
and gender identity
she first thought she might be bisexual
she came later to feel that they were
non-binary or genderqueer
and the final realization was that he
was trans male
my son had every reason to believe that
with two very loving parents he would be
accepted in Love no matter what
my son knew that I was very supportive
of gay and lesbian rights
but my son intuited correctly that I
really didn't understand about trans
and it was another year or two before I
learned about that
when my son felt I was ready he came out
to me when he no longer had to fear
being rejected which can cause a child
when rejected by the most important
people in lives to become depressed
potentially suicidal
at the time my son was not ready to come
out to my husband his father
at that time
my husband Wayne the father
was dealing with terminal cancer with
only two to five years given to live and
no possibility of cure
my son believed and I think rightly that
I know my husband would have eventually
accepted and loved my son our son
but he would probably have
a year or two of coming to trying to
come to terms with it and be fully
accepting
as many of you know stress when dealing
with a serious health condition can
for my son to come out to his father my
husband during this cancer Journey
and then to possibly see the cancer
symptoms worsen and death come more
quickly
would have been devastating to my son to
think he might have hastened that death
would have put my son into depression
and possibly led to Suicide over
feelings of guilt so my son chose not to
come out to his father my husband
teachers cannot possibly know all these
circumstances
that a minor student has to consider
when deciding if and when to come out to
their parents your time has run out so
let me ask legislators to please trust
that the child knows best the right time
to come out respect that and please
oppose SB 272. thank you is Beth scare
thank you for taking my testimony my
name is Beth scare and I'm a mother from
Nashua and first I want to say that none
of nothing in this bill forces teachers
to spontaneously come out with
information to parents
it says that if the parents ask the
teachers have to tell the truth about
pronouns gender and
name changes
that's why I have a backup okay
in 2017 Bruce Lent taught a social study
teacher at National High an advisor to
the school's gay straight Alliance Club
was arrested for sending nude pictures
of himself to several male students and
engaging in sexually explicit
conversations with them and soliciting
the students to send them nude photos of
themselves
he also solicited them to meet with him
to engage in sex
in 2021 popular Concord High School
teacher Joshua Harwood was arrested on
child sex abuse image charges
prostitution and endangering the welfare
of a child like Bruce langtott he was
soliciting sex with male students he had
formally taught in Nashua as well
teachers sexually abusing students is
not uncommon these teachers are too I
know the details of it because of their
association with my city of Nashua
Google teachers sexually abusing
students in New Hampshire to find many
more such cases
most many of those testifying say they
are concerned about protecting lgbtq
students and that we should
automatically trust teachers to do the
best for their students and these
teachers can be trusted to keep secrets
from parents
the truth is that no one cares about
kids more than their parents teachers
are human infallible and they have much
less invested in the well-being of
students
and they have their own interests at
heart
many say this bill
undermines trust between students and
teachers but those same people think
nothing of undermining the trust between
those students and their parents by
allowing teachers to hide information
from parents
children hide a lot of critical
information from parents when they are
taking illegal drugs cutting themselves
starving themselves binging and purging
driving recklessly and the list goes on
by the same logic I have heard from many
the fact that the child is hiding these
things from parents means that the
parents can't be trusted with that
information that is ludicrous
and because they fear what teachers are
hiding from their kids parents are
fleeing Public Schools if you want
public schools to thrive then you need
please vote ought to pass on SB 272 to
support our parents and students thank
you
questions from the committee
bill
hello okay I'd say it's nice to see
everyone again however
we're here for obvious reasons my name
is Bill Blum
been here far too often to defend myself
and my community
that I am so
deeply involved in
I am from Portsmouth New Hampshire
um
let's just summarize briefly where we're
at here
this bill
SB 272 is very similar to the one that
was here in a full house vote
a month ago I set up in the gallery
front row witnessed the
the vote
it did not pass a lot of the words the
same a lot of the words in that version
are the same in this version
why are we here wasting our time why are
we here talking about the same thing
we talk about parental rights uh listen
they're not my daughter is not my dog my
daughter is my daughter we are all human
beings we all breathe the same air
some of you on the other side of the
microphone might have different license
plates than the people on this side
doesn't matter we're all human beings
let's Express let's respect each other
as such do not force someone to tell
their coming out story
because that is a sacred sacred thing
that I kept secret for 43 years however
over the last couple of months the only
thing you needed to hear my coming out
story was a stable internet connection
or the ability to get yourself into this
chamber or across the street to hear it
sorry I'm a little animated
the
one thing that I want to say is is if
the parental Bill of Rights is already
established why do we need to allow to
clarify that there was already a law
that says you can't drink and drive a
car do we need a law that says you can't
put a beer in the cup holder and open it
no let's be a realistic people
and I will close simply with I got a
call from the school last week that did
not tell me about my kids preferred
pronouns it did not tell me about their
name change it told me that someone
quote threaded to go threaten to go to
the school and shoot it up
people
this is the house education committee
can we really take the time and focus on
what's important here
can we focus
on making real change
my thought
is hopefully your thoughts as well that
I our kids leave with the ability to
Simply breathe and Thrive and my prayers
are that you will not discriminate
against marginalized communities that
has happened with people of color people
of
gay bisexuals and now to transgendered
people thank you thank you very much
Anne-Marie Banfield
good afternoon members of the House
Education committee I am a parental
rights Advocate New Hampshire focused on
academic excellence
parents who struggle to be a voice for
their children oftentimes run into
lobbying organizations that are well
funded and hire high-priced attorneys to
fight against them I have no Financial
stake in any advocating that I've done
on behalf of parents and I've been doing
this for 20 years I'm here today because
it's the right thing to do
School administrators have high priced
legal teams that can be extremely
intimidating to parents the balance of
power has been against parents for many
years even if parents have a good case
the legal cost to them versus the
superintendent who uses taxpayer money
and attorneys results in parents giving
up they pull their kids out enrollment
numbers are going down there's I mean
you can look at the numbers
Public School enrollment numbers decline
private school and home school numbers
go up
parental rights bill would help shift
some of that power back to the parents
which would help stop The Exodus from
the public schools so that's something
just to keep in mind
um
so let's be honest about the lack of
student privacy in our Public Schools
right now
everyone seems to think that personally
identifiable information is private it
is not
who knows who who knows or who how many
times if a child comes in and decides to
use a different name at school all their
teachers know all the children know
children go home tell their parents
their friends know
but now we're telling the schools don't
tell the parent so everybody knows but
not the parent
not only that the schools are told
School Personnel lied parents not just
keep the information from them but
they'll actually lie to them
I want to know if you know these people
I'm going to say their names Jim foth
Megan Phillips George Tremblay Chris
Chan Lisa Colby they're just a few
people
who have access to your child's Mental
Health Data
that Keene State collects it in the past
in Antioch University
and Plymouth state
so all this information is going out to
all kinds of people
but again we're going to tell parents
nope we're not going to tell you this
information we're going to lie to you
you know that all of these universities
are collecting this mental health
information without parental consent or
without the student's consent
there are people all over the state with
access to information on these students
but this one time the parent comes in
and says what's going on with my child
they're being told you are to lie to
the data security systems
um
allow this other people to access this
information I urge you to vote
ought to pass on this if everybody is
getting this information why not parents
why are why are we Drawing the Line at
parents
thank you thank you
any questions from the committee
uh next speaker Ariel Hayes followed by
Laura Condon
hello my name is Ariel Hayes I use she
her pronouns I am one of the
co-directors of the youth success
project and I worked as a case manager
at Waypoint which is the runaway and
homeless youth provider for the state
for two years I'm also a queer person
and I have experienced unaccompanied
homelessness and I'm here today to talk
to you about how this bill if it were
passed would increase our rate of Youth
and Young adults experiencing
homelessness in this state
something that I have learned again and
again through my work in this field is
that not all parents are good parents
and that young people are often taken
advantage of they're used to
um meet their parents needs and are
often abused in ways that we've already
established today can be subtle and may
not become known until after they are
18. we are not always good at catching
when young people are
experiencing abuse in the home until
after the young person is over 18. not
all parents are good parents and lgbtq
youth are at an increased risk of
homelessness they are 2.2 times more
likely to experience homelessness when
compared to their peers and 64 of lgbtq
Youth had had experienced stigma or
discrimination within their family and
this is National Data from Chopin Hall
at the University of Chicago
and ex being a transgender young person
is not a choice these young people are
facing serious mental health suicide
um and discrimination in the home and
they need supportive people in a school
environment and this bill would take
that away from them
um and these statistics exist without
this bill being present
young people become more vulnerable when
they're homeless too lgbtq youth are at
an increased risk of being forced to
have sex being physically harmed by
others maybe needing to exchange sex to
get their basic needs met and these are
compounding risk factors and young
people are often kicked out of their
parents homes
um if their parents are not supportive
and not ready to support them
um when they
come out
and if this bill becomes law it will
make teachers and school administrators
responsible for outing a young parent a
young person to parents who are not safe
and supportive
I'm not being dramatic these things
happen they happen to an estimated over
16 000 young people in this state each
year and bypassing this bill you would
be taking away a Young Person's right to
keep themselves safe
we have enough homeless youth in this
state we do not need more I urge you to
oppose this bill
thank you
Laura Condon
good afternoon
my name is Lane Lloyd I'm a resident of
Durham and I'm testifying in opposition
to SB 272
the last time that I stood in this room
it was for a fourth grade field trip and
in ninth grade I started Pelham New
Hampshire's first gay straight Alliance
Group dated for the first time and
changed my name socially without the
context and connotations of gender and
sexuality these are activities that
almost any teen might partake in however
these things did concern my mom and she
thought I was too young maybe influenced
by my peers or the internet
and most importantly thought that being
gay or trans meant being isolated
marginalized and miserable simply put
she didn't want my life to be harder So
to avoid conflict we entered a mutual
don't ask don't tell period which lasted
several years
um well decided to come here and testify
I talked to my mom about this bill 15
years or so after the fact I wondered
what she might think now she responded
that these conversations should be on
one's own terms and timelines not the
governments simply put the state doesn't
need to have a seat at the family dinner
table
because my school did not compulsively
Force conversations that we weren't
ready for I had the opportunity to take
enough breathing room to find out who I
was to live my life as I felt more
comfortable and to make more lifelong
friends at a school club like all the
other kids
when my family and I finally did decide
to have these conversations I came into
it as an established and confident
person with a lot more life experience
there was living proof that looking and
acting as myself meant living a happy
and genuine life as opposed to the scary
and lonely life that they had imagined
and feared for me
today my parents and I have a healthy
and communicative relationship and we
run a small family business in Derry
together
I want this to be possible for all kids
and teens and their families for youth
to have the same opportunity as everyone
else to decide when to have tough
conversations and if they are not in
danger to be able to put trust in
qualified adults at school and being
LGBT in and of itself is not a danger
uh I was lucky to have a guidance
counselor who could provide a listening
ear and basic support the way anyone who
works with children and teens does for
small and large problems alike
no teacher introduced the concept of
same-sex attractive attraction or gender
non-conformity to me my guidance
counselor didn't say did you know that
some kids changed their names and you
could too
she didn't say that I could start a gay
start Alliance I asked her
um it's totally new neutral information
but no one presented me with it I at 14
went to them no teacher unprompted ever
tried to steer me towards a particular
future other than a happy and healthy
one at no point Did a New Hampshire
Public School indoctrinate me into a
gender identity or sexuality I learned
what being gay meant the way that many
kids do which is being teased by other
kids for looking like it
as my own feelings developed I realized
they were right about me but safe
interested adults in my school helped me
to see that they were also wrong in the
ways of the matter my teachers were not
keeping secrets from my parents they
were keeping confidences with me
SB 272 is a thinly veiled attempt to
fearmonger about transgender people in
order to chip away and have run out of
time all right well thank you you're
more than welcome
Leo wallesco and Then followed by Kelly
Warner
hi I'm going to ignore everything I have
written down because it's all been said
so many times before
I don't want to just repeat things over
and over again I have a master's in
education I've spent eight years up till
this point in public schools middle
school and high school
and I rise in support of this bill now I
love
the young people that I've worked with
and they love me
and I think that any adult that tells a
young person
that people don't like you or they're
trying to attack you is not doing you a
I don't pretend to understand why
the only kids that came to me talking
like this had autism
but it doesn't surprise me when I read
the studies that show that they're far
more likely I don't know why
but it is the truth
I don't know why they have four times
higher rate of committing suicide I
don't know why but it is the truth
I know what it's like to be a survivor
of suicide to be left behind by someone
who committed that horrible act and how
you feel responsible that maybe there
was something you did or didn't do
that could have changed things
and we hear people here are afraid that
young transgendered people or gay people
are more likely to commit suicide
suicide is not going to take place at
the school
they don't have the time or the privacy
to commit the ACT it's going to take
place at home
this bill does not require a teacher to
out every kid this bill says that when a
parent
is worried in some way for some reason
and ask me directly
I'm to tell the truth
if I know and I do know that they're
more likely to commit suicide when they
identify
and I have a parent that's worried
asking me to lie as part of my
professional duty is unacceptable
I we can't fix everything the schools
can't fix all these problems we can't
even understand them all
but adding something bad
is not going to help
asking teachers to lie
directly lie when asked a specific
pointed question
is a bridge too far
you know this used to be a calling and
people used to do it for their entire
careers they were teachers for their
entire 30-year working career that's not
the case anymore it's now five to seven
years
why
we don't need any more teachers driven
from this profession by being asked to
do things that are against their
conscience
so I I ask you to support the Bill thank
hello my name is Juliette depietro I
live in Manchester and I was asked to
come here today to speak to you about
why sb272 is an important bill to pass
into law
I am a nurse who has worked in the field
of medicine for 30 years
I fully support a state law supporting
parental rights there are many medical
Provisions listed in SB 272 that support
our rights as parents
it includes a provision that says that
the school personnel must respond in a
truthful and informed manner if School
Personnel begin to proceed with
affirming or intervening with a child's
gender identity
some of this could involve a level of
mental health counseling
Federal Law requires parental consent
when assessing or providing Mental
Health Services in school you can find
that in every student succeeds act which
was signed by President Obama in 2015.
there are many good medical reasons why
it is important that no one in the
school lies to parents about their
children's Behavior if it's okay to lie
to parents about their children for one
reason where does it end
medical journals and research paper all
agree that any medical and psychological
interventions is to be carefully
analyzed and parents and children need
to be well informed this is apparently
not being utilized by the Manchester
school system which is why they are
currently being sued by a Manchester
parent
gender dysphoria can result in a child
being placed on puberty blockers a
parent has a right to know what is going
on in school in Manchester the public
schools are undermining the social
psychological and physical well-being of
a child who is gender confused
in the medical field parental
involvement is critical when children
are experiencing gender dysphoria
Manchester is also now including Medical
Services inside the schools through
amascag health
how will medication be dispensed will
they provide puberty blockers to
students will parents even know if their
child is prescribed medication at school
the FDA has warmed of the possibility of
developing pseudotumor cerebri after
beginning medical treatment
symptoms mimic brain tumors due to
increased pressure in the skull this
leads to headaches anger rage depression
to name a few
Mental Health Systems increase after
medical intervention and includes
depression social phobia anxiety crying
irritability and anger and increased and
increased aggressive behaviors
will school Personnel withhold
information if their daughter was given
puberty blockers like testosterone and
was experiencing The Rage of psychotic
episodes that comes with these medical
interventions
emergency rooms are now seeing children
who are having psychotic breaks and the
parents are looking for answers these
are terrifying crises that require
parents to know what happened and why
every parent has a right to know
please vote Yes on SB 272 thank you
thank you very much and a reminder for
folks if you have written testimony you
can help us if you drop it off with the
clerk here
now if we can enter it into today's
hearing Kate McCarty followed by Betsy
Harrington
could you take care of this and see
what's going on out there there's so
you're lying no yeah
yeah I talked to her in your speech I'm
testosterone is not a period of a
transgender
these people have no idea Sergeant these
are you Kate yes welcome if I wasn't
nervous before
[Laughter]
thanks
go ahead hi I'm Kate McCarty and I'm a
resident of New Hampshire and a parent
and I oppose sp272
I feel like this whole thing could be
solved if we listen to the experts on
the subject the experts say this is a
terrible idea most reasonable people
listen to The Experts but here we are
here's a quote from the National
Children's Advocacy Center
there are many worries for a child abuse
Survivor that can silence them research
and surveys indicate disclosure rates
may be as low as 16 percent to 25
percent and fewer than 25 percent of
victims are said to disclose immediately
following the abuse
kids don't run around telling people
that they're being abused at home it's a
secret they keep often from their
closest friends remember those friends
that for some reason never let anyone
come to their house
yeah
so imagine I'm one of those parents who
are not supportive of their lgbtq child
or maybe violent toward their own child
for being different they exist I know
this and more importantly you know this
it can be difficult to picture
especially if you are not one of those
parents but they're out there we've all
read the stories we've all been shocked
by the depravity of their abuse it's not
a secret
when you come from an abusive
environment you learn very quickly to
mask it's a survival tool it's a
Lifeboat on rough Seas you use it until
you're safe if this bill passes you are
not only going to endanger countless
children who have been hanging on by a
thread sitting in that Lifeboat just
trying to make it until they can live on
their own terms but you have also signed
off on countless suicides make no
mistake teachers are often those
lifeboats
these kids are tired they deal with
lockdown grills cyber bullying climate
change all while navigating the most
confusing time of their lives the one
that we call adolescence and now they
can't even turn to a trusted teacher to
say hey I'm scared and confused can you
help me please don't do this they're
running out of lifeboats thank you
Betsy Harrington hi I'm Betsy Harrington
I'm from Deering
I am a mother of three boys two are in
public school now in high school one is
adopted and had an IEP and was very
difficult to manage through the school
system
I would never approve of Secrets why
would I send my kids to a place that
kept secrets when I could just send them
somewhere else or homeschool them so I
feel like we're destroying the system by
creating this
States sanctioned Secrets like that just
seems bizarre to me as a sex offender
counselor and a therapist I I feel like
we need to protect the kids I'm finding
pornography in my kids school I brought
it to the school there is no challenge
policy at SAU 34. so I know all you say
that all this is unnecessary and these
laws that are in this bill are already
happening they're not I cannot challenge
this book is gay which has embedded
hyperlinks to match.com and Grindr in
the section of the book that says how to
use sex apps so if I can't stop my kids
from getting misinformation about sex
from the school why would I send them so
I feel like by allowing these secrets
you're going to send me away and I heard
other parents that came up and said that
they'd stopped sending their kids to
school for this reason we're here as
parents because we love our kids we have
we're not giving them to you
obviously any parent who could say no to
that would say no to that
so I'm not co-parenting with you and if
you guys decide to keep secrets then
I'll take my kids out like these other
parents have you ruin the system
I love my kids and I love every one of
you I care about you I don't want to
erase you I want you to be represented
I just don't think we should be keeping
secrets if I called the school now the
school's not supposed to call me to tell
me that my kids gay or choosing a
different pronoun
if I called the school and I asked you
hey is my kid having any issues like do
I need to maybe bring him to a therapist
or something I would hope that you would
and now who's really going to be
suicidal who are you really helping
let's be real you have to protect the
parents here or we're just going to give
up on your silly system
please support SB 272 thank you thank
okay
welcome Lori hi thank you thank you to
everyone everyone who came I know
everyone on both sides of the issue feel
a lot about the issue
um a lot of what I prepared is
already been said I want to concentrate
on two things though
this is literally a bill which will not
only allow teachers in school
administration to lie to parents
but it actually encourages them to lie
to parents
just so you know I'm I'm a parent of two
boys one grandson I have a ton of nieces
and nephews who I care deeply about
there's not one teacher in any of their
school systems who care more about them
than I do
there's not one school administrator who
loves and cherishes that child
more than the parent does
I want what's right
for my kid and if my kid comes to me and
says that he's gay or he's trans or I'll
deal with that as a matter of fact I did
deal with that
but for the experts to say that parents
don't understand or Christian parents
are going to be evil to their children
it's just not right
by opposing this bill you're giving
people the permission to lie to parents
think about that I mean from from a very
young age we teach our kids don't lie
don't lie
and now you guys are actually hiding
things from them
the second part the second point I want
to bring up is that just to bridge on
what somebody else said
for a school to know that somebody is
coming out as trans or lgtb
cue um
with the high suicides rate sometimes
four times as likely to commit suicide
and just sending him home without
parents even knowing
you're asking these kids to live a
double life
not only that but
you're telling these kids you can be a
boy now but just make sure you're a girl
at home so what happens over school
vacation what happens with a summer
vacation these parents have no idea the
trauma and and the instability they feel
inside there's no help for them at home
it's not the government's right to lie
to parents
thank you
Jessica Bowman or your over here Denise
Woodward okay welcome thank you very
much thank you everyone for having me
I prepared a little something I come
from a different Viewpoint than most
people I think with my background
so I'd like to start out by giving a
little bit about my background
first and foremost I am a Christian
I was a former teacher in the public
school system here in New Hampshire
I am also a retired nurse and a member
of the LGBT plus community
I brought two very successful children
in this world and they are not parents
themselves
as a parent
I would like to know that my children
and grandchildren would be given respect
from their teachers and school systems
to continue with an open dialogue when
it comes to their education and
development
we have developed teacher parent nights
for a reason but it doesn't end there
open and honest communication with
parents or parents
and a teaching staff should create a
team for the same cause a well-rounded
student and hopefully an important
member of our society
as a former New Hampshire certified
teacher for 20 years
and in our New Hampshire systems here I
I taught in two of them as a high school
teacher
I have the utmost respect to my fellow
teachers I understand the daily battles
and victories that they go on that goes
on in a classroom every day I support
and salute you with the added pressures
that both parents and teachers undertake
at any given time throughout the
Academic Year
pressure comes from all directions it
could be violence lack of performance
academically discipline or a new
educational regime
these are all difficult times for both
teachers and parents we need to work
together as mandated by our codes of
Ethics division is weakness and
disruptive towards our ultimate goal the
students
this means every student is our
responsibility
both parents and teachers remain as
integral Parts excuse me integral parts
informing that child and awarding
opportunities for success that's what we
want
and I was that teacher that kids came to
in my life
and I never turned a kid away and I
worked with gays trans abusive kids
everything and they came on their own
volition
and to say it ends at three no that's
when it starts for a lot of those kids
they come after school they want to talk
to you
as a member your time is up now okay I
was going to just do that but I'm going
for the bill please let's re-look at
this and do those amendments and make a
difference and bring our community
Jessica Bowman filed by Francesca
portenza
Jessica not here
Francesca
I am here to support Senate Bill 272
because I love and I trust my mom and my
dad they are my parents
how could schools Keep information about
any student when the parents
specifically ask for it
it's insane to me
it's sad to watch all of this testimony
teacher's main purpose is to teach like
reading and writing and arithmetic
rights
I know that when I was bullied in sixth
grade at a public school none of those
teachers nor administrators told my
parents and I was bullied for many
months
one day I locked myself in a bathroom
for about 45 minutes because a group of
boys were harassing me and yet no one
really cared until after all that time I
was finally found and my mom did get a
phone call from the school but yet guess
what they didn't give her really any
much information until I had to tell my
story
that was in 2019 at supposedly one of
the best schools in the district
this is why we need this spell coming
from a very concerned teen who cares
about all those other kids and teenagers
I fully support this Bill thank you
okay Leonard
flusher
welcome thank you
I'm Len Fleischer an elected member of
the Chesterfield School Board I've been
a teacher a school psychologist a school
counselor a child and family
psychologist and a retired professor of
education at Keene State College
my experience with children in schools
strongly informs me that this bill is
deeply problematic even dangerous it's
antithetical to best practices in in
Child and Adolescent education and
psychology
this bill uses disingenuous language
about rights to conceal what appears to
be another purpose to disparage and
dismantle public education and Educators
in New Hampshire it takes what appears
to be a suspicious stance about school
administrators and teachers setting in
place of false cloud of mistrust and
misinformation about their ostensible
motives and supposedly keeping
information about students from their
parents here's the truth
in my 40 plus years experience with
public schools and now as a school board
member I have never once known known of
an effort to keep anything related to
curricula books or presentations by
teachers that was denied to parents
parents and families in my experience
were always encouraged to learn more and
be involved with their children were
learning
there are clear and open policies and
procedures supporting the rights of
parents to engage with teachers and
administrators with school personnel and
my fellow Chesterfield school board
members take seriously
ESPYs 272 has language about the rights
of parents to learn about what students
might confide
confidentiality is a fundamental and
critical right of all people including
children and essential to effective
Counseling in my experience which
includes literally thousands of
counseling sessions with school children
there are relative handful of situations
where students were not encouraged to
involve their families
however within that small minority of
cases where at home stories of incest
physical violence and rejection of
students who were exploring gender and
sexuality in those situations it could
be literally dangerous were teachers and
counselors to be mandated to reveal what
was told to them in confidence this
isn't a critical and Essential Best
practice for educators in the real world
SB 272 if implemented would actually put
school children at risk for serious
domestic harm it also will harm schools
and the noble profession of teaching
parents rights has become the term of
choice for Nationwide efforts to censor
School curricula banned books suppress
the teaching of actual history and
criminalize School teachers and
administration
I implore you to reject this Bill thank
you very much
filed by Claudia
itzel
hello
I'm Liam Romano I'm here to be the voice
for two great Catholic and conservative
parents who love their child who is
transgender yes it's possible
it's because the guidance counselor
reached out to the mother after talking
to the child in Middle School
a meeting was held
about what name they would use and they
used a nickname
so the child wouldn't be a all freaked
out or upset
and then they decided that the nurse's
bathroom would be the appropriate place
for this child during this time
the parents bought appropriate clothes
so that the child would not be in female
attire
and they also
this child went through high school and
was involved in extracurricular
activities has great friends and a big
support system his biggest supporters
are his Catholic conservative parents
this child's parents have gotten their
child mental health support and Health
Care decisions have been made together
pushing off drastic measures until
adulthood
all the while giving a voice to their
child and talking about what's going on
within their family
I'm here to support the teachers that
came forward to this
this couple who were struggling with
this and they did not want to come up
and speak and out their child so these
parents just want rights just like these
transgender students I support this bill
they support this bill you should all
support this bill parents
our parents and they birthed these
children the state does not have any
rights the schools do not have any
rights teachers are there to teach
it's great that they're speaking with
these with these children and it's great
that you know they have that ability to
welcome any kind of conversation but the
parents should be in the know they
really should
thank you thank you very much
as Claudia here yes I'm right here thank
you good afternoon good afternoon I'm
Claudia Estelle from Acworth I've taught
in public high schools in New Hampshire
for over 30 years and I speaking in
opposition to this bill
um I'm parent parents have rights I
agree with that as a teacher I always
felt that I was part of a team with the
parents and the student and other
professionals to work for the best of
the child communication is a very very
important it's always been part of the
policy of all public schools that
parents have access to the curriculum
can come and ask questions can come
visit the schools whenever they want to
it was my duty to also communicate with
the parents about the curriculum about
their students progress
but I do need to tell you and most of
the time that worked very well I mean
their parent-teacher conferences are all
these their emails and so forth but I do
want to tell you one story which was
very disturbing
um
I had a student who was not working well
she was her progress was deteriorating
she wasn't completing homework she was
withdrawn and I do what I usually do
which is to call home and see if we can
work as a team to help this child I left
numbers of messages I didn't reach
anybody no one got back to me one
evening I called home and the father
answered and the voice was so hard and
so cold it reminded me of another parent
that I had spoken to in a previous time
in my career who had been an abusive
so the next morning as soon as I got to
school I I went to the administration
and I said I'm worried that there might
be abuse in this family that's my
responsibility as a teacher to do that
they said
the a relative had just also called in
saying that they were concerned about
the same issue the child was pulled from
school I never saw her again her parents
took her out of the district and the
rest of their family they moved away
impeding any ability to have an
investigation to follow through on this
so in my
innocence I guess my efforts to reach
out to her parent who I would think
would be her first protector I was
actually reaching her abuser
and what I didn't know because she
hadn't shared it with me undoubtedly
made her life worse
so too often children and teens suffer
alone with their doubts and questions
and concerns leading to anxiety poor
social connection deteriorating academic
performance depression and sometimes
suicide mental health issues are at all
time high in our school population has
come up okay thank you
thank you very much I'd like to invite
sorry
hi my name is Russ Ann Chester I am a
citizen of Bedford and um I am a former
State of New Hampshire employee I work
for dcyf
I had this all prepared and as I've been
sitting here
um kind of threw that out the window
but I'm coming here today for a child
that
cannot speak for herself
or himself
um
Desi and her mom
were people that
um were in the system Desi was a foster
child she grew up in the foster care
system she went from home to home to
home
and I was her I was her one trusted
person I was so excited when Desi came
to me and said I think I'm in the wrong
body I embraced that
and I took that child to I I worked with
the school I worked with mental health I
worked with nami New Hampshire I worked
with the national child Alliance and we
were going to do everything we could to
at 16 years old
she chose to have a double mastectomy
she started questioning
that maybe she'd made a mistake
but she didn't come to us
and I found out
because I was one trusted person
I got the suicide note
I only found out in Desi's death
that the reason why she was feeling that
she was
um she was experienced gender
I don't know what it's agenda dysphoria
was because her abuser her groomer was a
school staff person that we all trusted
and that's the bottom line it's not
about any of us hating on any other
human
it's not about any of us being righteous
and
Wicked Christian or Wicked Wiccan or
whatever
there isn't a I worked for dcyf for over
17 years and in those 17 years I had two
parents
that I can say that they had they
admitted
that they didn't love their children
that they had their children through
therapy and everything that they they
reproduced
because one of them had Munchausen by
proxy
that parent had munchened house and by
proxy and the other said that she had
her child specifically so that that
child could be used as sacrifice now in
17 years I had two parents your your
time is up thank you and I'm open to
hello
my name is Ariel
I am a transgender woman and resident of
Bo New Hampshire and I'm speaking an
extreme opposition to this hateful Bill
SB 272
I have sat here all day listening to
countless testimonies is from people or
who have used our either extremely
hateful or extremely misguided
head what I'm gathering is that this
isn't about protecting kids this is
about controlling them this is about
what Morgan them and to become whatever
I have met a lot of trans people in my
life both adult and children and from my
experience trans children know
themselves better than any any other
person possibly can
and and I can speak as someone whose
mother worked as a preschool teacher for
several decades that her job is not just
to quote teach reading and writing her
job is to foster a safe space for
children to experience love to
experience kindness to experience
compassion for others to experience a
judgment-free Zone but most of all
to establish trust with an adult who is
not their parents now when we go around
saying that I teachers can just go and
abandon that trust us abandon a child's
trust us and put their and put that
child at risk for for any possible abuse
or homelessness or even suicide for that
matter because they don't know what
their family life is like
like I I I'm Sorry by failing to see how
and
you know
it's frustrating that I have to come
here here just to ask for my basic
rights as a human being to be respected
okay because people that I don't even
know can't even see my worth
and can't even see the worth of the
Jenny yes thank you my name is Jenny
Broderick I'm from Milford New Hampshire
I am currently uh have been for the past
20 years home educating my own children
um
when I was in high school having
experienced the high school world and
kid culture is what it's called The
Secret World of kids
um I had decided that I didn't want my
children to
um
to have to be separated from their
parents in the sense of
not having communication and those types
of things so I chose from the time I was
in high school I already knew that I
would home educate my own children
um
I have friends and family whoever do who
do not home educate their own children
um
my concern my purpose for being here is
not to control or to dominate A specific
group of people or even a specific group
of thoughts and feelings
but my concerns are literally as a
parent
that myself having the ability to
protect my children
I have
two stories so one is of a transgender
girl
who was in school in Oregon
her teachers had had conversations with
her she was not transgender at the time
she was encouraged to without parental
consent without parental knowledge
to go to a doctor off of school campus
she was driven there by a teacher
taken in to get a Gardasil vaccine she
was given this vaccine and returned back
to the school by the teacher
she returned home and she said hey get
Dad guess what happened to me today
and she proceeded to tell her parents at
that point that her teachers had set up
an appointment for her taking the taken
her to a doctor they did not know
and she was given a vaccine
a month later
this young lady had begun to experience
extreme anxiety
and just said to express the differences
in personality that she was experiencing
she wanted to go to Japan she wanted to
go backpacking in Japan and she wanted
to go camping and she wanted to explore
the world
this young girl ended up
having such high anxiety a month after
this Gardasil vaccine that she could not
um as a result she she is now actually a
young mother she struggles taking care
of her own child because of her anxiety
and all of the difficult things that
she's going through
um
prior to that vaccine she was not like
that she was a firecracker your time is
up oh thank you very much
you're welcome
I'd like to invite representative Janine
notter
thank you I represent Hillsboro 12. I'm
just here to add my support to the bill
I was in committee all morning so I
couldn't be here when the other
legislators were testifying but I just
came from a luncheon where I heard from
a 18 year old who transitioned when she
was 12 and then de-transitioned
and you she'll be she should be coming
back so you could hear her story I hope
you listen to her
thank you that was it you're welcome and
we have another representative that
is she here
welcome
thank you Mr chair
my name is Lewis Bay
and I'm a state representative from
Dover
I'm also an officer of the nhdp
African-American Pacific Islander caucus
I'm an immigrant from the Philippines
you can probably tell by the accent
my Asian American family is Roman
Catholic
I am a supporter of the lgbtq plus
community
and I oppose
I reject the notion that all Asian
Americans in New Hampshire are in
support of SB 272
thank you Mr chair
you're welcome
hi thank you very much
um my Mr chairman my name is Louise
Spencer and I too am against this bill
and would urge you to um
I tell it but I am speaking today
reading testimony from Ashley derosers
who is a city council person from
Rochester
sorry I ran over from over there and I
have to catch my breath I'm too out of
shape
um
so in preparate and this is now Ashley
derosier's testimony in preparation for
today I attempted to write testimony to
speak against sb272
as an experienced public speaker elected
official and mother I could not muster a
paragraph or even a sentence to explain
why
however I didn't have any wiser reasons
to give yet
my parents love me I know this they told
me every day of course they love me this
love that fueled them to protect us a
love so powerful they had to control
their children and their environment
an environment that was riddled with
control authoritarianism and fear
an environment that was filled with
physical assault sexual abuse Cults and
educational neglect
an environment and educational setting
with explicit homophobia transphobia
sexism and racism
in an environment that controlled every
aspect of myself and by seven other
siblings lives
an environment with no Community for
many years I have asked myself and my
parents why
my father and I regrets his actions and
sees the harm caused we talk frequently
we have grown I understand now that he
was scared and as many of us are here in
this room
today Senator Carson along with others
have repeatedly asked why
stating that it's only about one thing
and that parents love their children
citing situations that are already
addressed by state law including a
parental Bill of Rights
if it was only about a parental rights
and love then why is the only thing
different about this bill is that it
calls out gender identity sexual
orientation and transgender people
as a child of parents fueled by love and
protection only to control myself and my
other seven siblings artistic expression
was my only Outlet it remained so today
so this is my message via poem to
Senator Carson and representative of our
Live Free or Die state that seeks to
support this bill
so the poem is
ah it's you you must be the pros and
choices while stifling hundreds
thousands of voices you cry cry your
your time is up okay we'll submit the
bill I mean the poem I I would encourage
all of the members of the committee to
read it it's a very powerful bill that
touches on the experience is that I read
in the testimony thank you uh Tammy
McNeil
good afternoon at this point I guess it
is
I had written I could have written hours
of testimony on this
um I'll start off with just what I came
up with that I would like to change 30
times listening to people speak in this
room
I work 10 plus years as a school
psychologist in two large elementary
schools in Massachusetts
I've have a trans sister-in-law we've
welcomed several trans people into our
lives love everybody don't judge anyone
that's how I approach raising my three
children working with others
um so I just want to really talk about
my background so you can see where my
stance comes from help two young
students probably about 18 years ago
little young kids that just didn't feel
like they belonged in their body
I did not work with them until I had
parental permission
as a school psychologist there's a chain
you follow you need parental permission
parents need to be involved we're here
to work together as a team and I again
I'll go off this now I listened in this
room to so many eyes I I mean me this
room is so charged with emotion and I
get it everyone has a story but we have
to be aware of how that affects us and a
lot of people don't have the training to
understand hey I'm a teacher I was
trained for this again I love teachers I
was asked by many to come here because
they don't want to keep lies with
families and they're not realizing
they're bringing all their baggage to
how they're dealing with that child as a
psychologist I have Beyond a master's
degree to understand take that all out
look at it from a different lens so we
have to really pull some of the emotion
out and say how can we serve our
students and that is with the family of
course there are kids that are going to
be the exception but we do have
other places to get them help we have to
focus on how to best educate our
students we're the education committee
secure kids that are comfortable because
they have a team around them
are the best educated the most able to
deal with this this is not just a trans
bill it is let's come together work
together just this week found out from
my sophomore son hey Mom you know
there's a lady at the high school I
don't know what she's called but she's
the lady you can go talk to about when
you drink alcohol or do drugs and she
won't tell your parents I was like well
I mean and I'm a school I'm in this
world of education and I'm like wow this
is the kid's perception we won't tell
your parents lie to your parents no way
once you tell kids to lie anxiety stress
pressure you mess them up royally so
thank you for listening to my testimony
thank you
hi a quick preference addressing an
earlier speaker's comments teachers are
actually leaving the profession because
they are underpaid undervalued and
overworked now back to my regularly
scheduled comments
good afternoon chairman Ladd and members
of the education committee my name is
Michaela damater and I'm here today to
speak against SB 272. I am the mom of
two children who attend public schools
in our community and I have had the
pleasure of regularly volunteering at my
daughter's Elementary School I also
serve as a member of the Dover School
Board I want to be clear that I
represent myself only today though my
perspective is broadened and enriched by
my time spent serving in this public
office
like you I am tasked with evaluating and
approving policies that govern the
actions of the community I serve like
you I need to consider the intent behind
policies and the possible outcomes
whether intended or unintended like you
I take my job very seriously
the Bill's sponsor repeatedly referenced
the fact that parents love their
children and want what's best for them
of course they do I don't disagree what
the senator failed to mention though is
the responsibility of parents to talk to
their children directly and Foster a
home environment where their children
feel safe to share details of their
lives
the question at hand today is whether
schools should be forced by law to
reveal a student's transgender status to
parents even over the express objection
of the students the decision you must
make is whose rights matter more here
the student's right to safely share
information with a teacher that the
student may not wish to immediately
disclose to parents or the parents right
to compel a school to reveal information
their children have not given permission
to share
at no time have a parent's rights to
talk to their own kids ever been in
question or at risk of being removed
public schools are educating a student
population that is increasingly burdened
by mental health struggles I directly
see and hear evidence of this every
single week I'm volunteering in our
schools I challenge anyone to find a
teacher or administrator who would
disagree with this teachers work very
hard to establish a safe environment
where learning can happen this bill
removes a teacher's ability to provide a
safe confidential space for their
students who may disclose information
about their sexual Journey this is the
unintended consequence we must not
ignore this bill assumes it is a
school's job to step into and force the
conversations in Revelations parents and
children should be having within their
own homes at the right times for those
family members I do not support SB 272
it takes away a school's ability to be a
safe haven for students who may not be
experiencing that same Comfort at home
or who want to be in control your time
is up thank you of when and how this
good afternoon I'd just like to take a
moment to speak in regard to this bill
I'm in support of the bill I'm speaking
to the bill because every person that
I've spoken to in my district Carroll
County 3 since I was elected this past
year has been in support of parental
rights I'd like you to consider that
I can tell you something I'm learning we
foreign
thank you my name is Stephanie Cauley I
am a transgender woman I am also a
mother of three children and I live in
Conway
um my three children
went to public schools in the Conway
School District at Pine Tree and at
Kennett
and I can tell you I very much believe
in parental rights
in the ability to be involved in their
school
education plan with um
the teachers in the school however I
oppose this bill
with every fiber of my being
I also believe that parents have a
responsibility not just rights and as a
someone with responsibilities that means
you generate
a family value that says everybody's
welcome and that your truth is always
welcome here and that you will be loved
and supported regardless of who you are
who you love who you hang out with
so I oppose this we already do have
rights as parents I know this because I
raised three children for 17 years they
were in the schools
I volunteered in the schools I went to
teacher parent meetings I went to open
houses I spoke to my parents to other
teachers via email phone and in person
so I knew what was going on these rights
already exist this is a thinly veiled
attempt to create a chilling atmosphere
which will drive transgender kids
on the ground to a place that I existed
back in the 1960s and 70s
so I urge you to oppose this bill I
think it is
aimed at trans children and I there's
enough anxiety depression and suicidal
ideation homelessness among trans
children that this will only add to that
problem
thank you thank you
Dr
okay
there's a carrier card it's Carrie yeah
I'm Dr Kerry Mendoza from the foundation
against intolerance and racism I'm the
medical director uh of our medicine
Division and I'm also an emergency
medicine physician and I'm here
um to speak for this this bill
um
it's important to understand that with
the Mental Health crisis right now it's
a very complicated what we're seeing
with the Trans Community is there's a
new cohort of patients that seems to be
caught up in a social contagion it's
mostly young girls
and we're seeing they have pre they have
a lot of mental health disorders that
then they're getting caught up in the
medical community and schools hiding
information
is really a medical intervention and
that shouldn't be done in schools
um it's similar to say using the Pain
Scale in schools if we said hey we want
to find excuse me kids who may suffer
later from Pain conditions and what if
we do the Pain Scale in school it'd be
similar to what happened with the opioid
crisis so I feel very strongly that
parents should be informed as to what's
going on with their children and so I I
really urge you to support this Bill
thank you thank you Carrie
hello thank you
well there's more than one Jennifer
Smith
that's never happened wow are you both
well you know
who was Jennifer well the real Jennifer
please stand up
they're both Jennifer and Smith
common name uncommon person I always say
okay
hope that doesn't cut into my time thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
my name is Jennifer Smith I am a retired
medical physician
I'm also a transgender woman
and I really want to just kind of remind
you about what a powerful emotion shame
is
and that parents often try to shame
their children into behaving the way
they'd like them to behave
well unfortunately
some parents
will try to shame lgbtq kids
who may not yet know who they are I
certainly didn't know but I had the Good
Fortune of having
family and community that was not into
shame but in fact
I learned in high school in a religious
high school that I did have gay teachers
and that they weren't ashamed of
themselves
and that was critical although I do know
from one of them who I spoke to quite a
bit
that another parent
also of a gay kid
had spent a lot of time trying to get
one of these faculty members removed
because they considered that person
inappropriate that person was wonderful
and not a threat
in any way shape or form
and I think when we send a message that
it's okay to shame your kids
to try to get them to be something
different than they are and are
beginning to understand I didn't truly
understand myself
because of the general culture of Shame
around until I was
around 40 and that took a lot of time
from there
and I don't think anyone in the school
system is ignoring bringing parents in
when that's appropriate but if a child
wants
to talk with others in a club
for lgbtq kids and their allies
they're going to be reluctant to look
for that support and try to help figure
it out
by the time you're in late middle school
and high school
you really are what used to be
considered an adult yeah you need to
learn a lot more about the world but
you're responsible for your own actions
that's why the bar mitzvah is at 12 or
13 but mitsu as well
and I think it would do a lot of good to
have this bill killed
or maybe retained and worked on if you
really think there is a way
to do this that is safe and won't
increase
isolation depression and potential more
suicide and we have a suicide crisis
right now
so please your time's up thank you
you're welcome
not here
okay
I think I'm the right person to follow
Jennifer
I mean the other Jennifer
thank you for letting me speak today I
just want to lift up the voices of
everyone who has spoken a well-spoken in
opposition to this cruel bill and I hope
that you all as lawmakers can see
through the sound and the fury
signifying worse than nothing it's
signifying fear
fear leads to hate and that's what this
is it smells like it it looks like it it
next speaker is
Andy Bemis well I'm Katie Lennon okay
yeah yeah then Andy Bemis
and and I'm a d transitioner and I live
in Lowell but I work worship and do
business in Nashua and so I'm an active
Community member of the 603 and I'm here
in support of SB 272 today
it's like many children and teens today
I identified myself as transgender for
years and when I started to feel
confused and ashamed about my developing
body I asked everyone in my life to call
me by a new name and use male pronouns
to refer to me so in other words I went
through a social transition from female
to male
everyone in my life immediately affirmed
my new identity either out of full
support for it or just to stay neutral
and not cause any issues but the
constant affirmation both active and
passive solidified me in my transgender
identity no one meant to lock me into an
identity that would later leave me
broken or shamed and more confused than
before they were really all just being
nice
but the social transition eventually
wasn't enough and I soon felt I needed
to take testosterone and when that
wasn't enough I had a double mastectomy
and when that still wasn't enough I had
a total hysterectomy including the
removal of my uterus cervix Fallopian
tubes and both ovaries there's no point
of contentment during a gender
transition we get fleeting moments of
euphoria But ultimately One Step leads
straight into the next and I thought
that in the end I could really become a
man but all I became was immutilated and
abused version of my old self
social transition is a big deal and
we're lying when we say that any of this
is reversible this is a big decision
with lifelong consequences and New
Hampshire doesn't even require that
parents be involved if the roles of
mother and father don't include
authority over the emotional social and
physical future of their children the
roles no longer mean anything
like me transgender identifying youth
have a high risk for depression the
Trevor Project which is an LGBT advocacy
group reports that 45 of LGBT teens have
seriously considered attempting suicide
in the past year
more than half of that number is
transgender identifying youth teachers
and school administrators are mandated
reporters and if a child suspected to be
four times more likely to attempt
suicide than the other students his age
his parents have a right to know and SB
272 will ensure that parents are
notified if their children are
identifying with a high-risk community
and will allow the parents to decide the
next best step for their child please
vote in support of SB 272 and I'm happy
to take any questions thank you
my name is Andy and I live in Concord
I'm opposed to this bill which frames
situations that most of us would
consider gray areas in strictly black
and white terms
I have two kids who are in the mvsd
school district it's a little redundancy
if I learned that my kids schools were
reserving information from me because
they were about my kids because they
were concerned for my kids safety I'd
first consider whether I might have said
or done something to raise a concern
in any case I wouldn't worry about
whether my kid was trans gay or
otherwise different because lgbtq kids
are beautiful and brave and should be
loved celebrated and supported that's
the most important thing I have to say
today if any kids hear hear that you are
beautiful and by the way since it came
out if you are a child with autism you
are beautiful and wonderful and perfect
I wouldn't worry about what would happen
if my kids changed their minds my kids
have changed their minds about ways they
used to identify the only irreversible
effect is that they know themselves a
little better
if a teacher was legally compelled to
tell you your kid is using different
pronouns what would you do for them
if you take them to a therapist and that
therapist says recommends gender
affirming care as the vast majority of
doctors in this country would do you
listen to that doctor
do you truly want your child to be happy
or you do you just want them to be
normal
all children should feel safe and loved
for being themselves that is our
responsibility someone else said this
but I have heard so much about parents
rights and so little about our
responsibilities Allah can't make our
kids trust us or teach empathy that is
our job
when I attended a hearing for hb10 last
month one of the Bill's supporters
threatened me with sexual assault I
later learned that another speaker a
self-described d-transitioner is a
registered and admitted sexual offender
and this morning members of white
nationalist groups stood outside in
support of this bill because I guess
white nationalists are so concerned with
parents rights I heard a great deal then
today about the powerful lgbtq movement
to indoctrinate children with a radical
ideological agenda here's my agenda all
kids should feel safe loved and free to
be themselves of course this bill is one
of almost 500 targeting lgbtq plus kids
in the country right now and though we
make up a relatively small percentage of
the population trans and non-binary
people get a disproportionate amount of
attention a Media Matters study from
2021 found that over 60 percent of the
discussion on Facebook related to trans
issues was on right-leaning news pages I
think I speak for most of us when I say
why are you so obsessed with us thank
you
good afternoon Mr chair and everybody on
the committee thank you for hearing me
speak today I am here as a mother and a
parent who is in full support of SB 272.
I've sat in this room all day today and
I've actually heard both sides and I
have friends in the trans Community I
have friends in the LGBT community I am
Catholic I am a Christian I don't judge
anybody what I'm hearing today in this
room and it's I've really soaked it up
like a sponge as I'm hearing a lot of
what ifs and fear I appreciate all
teachers that are in school and what
they do for kids when I was in school
years ago the the role between the
parents and the teacher was so important
when there was something wrong with me
in school I did go to a teacher or who I
needed to to share like hey I I need to
talk to somebody I'm not really sure
about going to my mom but they worked
with me and they allowed me to fix
things with my mother and my mother was
appreciative as a single parent to know
something was going on with her kid
the fact that they want to that there's
several and hey you guys can have your
own opinion you guys over here can have
your own opinion I feel that we are
being misled in this whole bill it seems
to be that we are focused on one
particular group we are not I am a
parent who wants to know when there is
something wrong with my child I don't
care if they stub their toe or fall up
the stairs in school or fall down the
stairs
the thing that I'm hearing a lot about
is parents have rights already there's
plenty of laws for them they find out
plenty um they they know everything they
need to know what I am hearing is that
there's one particular thing that needs
to be kept out of the parents no and
that is their sexual connotation
why is that I come from a school
district that is very controversial we
are all over the news and I applaud a
lot of teachers believe me I have
friends who are teachers all over the
country and they don't like that they
have to keep secrets from parents that's
what we're talking about folks we're
talking about secrecy when there is
someone who is abused a child in
particular if they are mentally sexually
or physically abused
they keep that Secrets they're told by
their abuser to keep that secret
why are we asking teachers to keep
secrets from their parents we have a
teacher who is a person that someone can
go to Just pled guilty your time is up
thank you you're welcome
thank you you know I was really supposed
to be one of the first
but they wanted to save all those cards
for other people well
um so you already have my notes maybe at
the bottom of your pile it's the paper
that has William Shakespeare in the top
right corner holding a pen instead of a
sword
so I have been a teacher for 40 years
and um
but now I'm out and I mean out of school
and uh
I want to say I'm here to present the
rare case when Democrats and Republicans
agree
I saw it by accident uh recently I was
watching a one-year-old Senate session a
full session
and they were debating the 100 million
dollar fund for the victims of child
abuse
and at the 5 Hour 34 Minute Mark our
Democratic senator Whitley began
describing the quote horrific abuse the
stuff of nightmares
kids subjected to indecent exposures
being forced to watch unquote
and then Senators Lou D'Alessandro and
Waters echoed her disgust stating that
no amount of money can wipe away the
scars from these abuses
the only disagreement between the right
and the left was that the Democrats
wanted more than the 100 million for the
victims
Senator Whitley stated the reason
that these children were able to be
abused was there was she said there was
no parental involvement or they had no
parents
we can all agree that's why the kids
were abused
and what Senator wetley described is
currently going on in our state-run
schools and libraries and that gentleman
Mr Richards from over there I felt very
embarrassed that he had to say those
things going on you know some people
will say oh that's agent appropriate for
kids I'm 69 and it's still inappropriate
for me to have to hear that stuff or for
him to say it
so thank you Representatives you've
stayed all this time and I thank you for
your part in making New Hampshire so
special
thank you so much
um I I took a personal day to be here
it's been a great way to spend one of my
three personal days
um my name is Chris Putnam Puglia and my
pronouns are they them and I'm
testifying on behalf of myself as a
school librarian
and I oppose SB 272
I have a master's degree in information
science with a concentration in school
libraries and I've been a librarian for
18 years nine of those in New Hampshire
Public Schools
I have an experienced educator license
for the State of New Hampshire
every educator in New Hampshire must
abide rightly so by Professional
Standards
laid out in a code of ethics in a code
of conduct
if this bill passes Educators would be
forced to break both of those codes
I'm going to read the actual words of
the code here for you that are relevant
the code of ethics for New Hampshire
Educators principle 2 responsibility and
commitment to the student
recognizes and respects confidential
information acquired in the course of
employment regarding individual student
safety education health and personal
information of students and their
families
students and names their nicknames their
pronouns and the clubs that they are in
are personal information if we're
required to disclose those we are
breaking our code of ethics
the code of conduct for New Hampshire
Educators among other things says
in fulfilling responsibility to students
a credential holder shall maintain a
professional relationship with all
students both inside and outside the
educational setting and make reasonable
efforts to protect students from
conditions which are harmful to their
health and safety
unfortunately it is a reality that for
some students being outed will cause
them harm to their health and safety
I urge you to vote against this bill
please do not make us violate our
students privacy
please do not ask us do not force us to
compromise our students health and
safety
do not pass this bill that would require
us to break our code of ethics and code
of conduct thank you thank you very much
I'd like to call Deb kozil
Mr chair I missed my call before can I
be re-included in the queue
representative Stapleton
we do have a card on you we did call
so you're back in the hall now yeah I'm
thank you Mr chair
my name is Walt Stapleton I'm
representative of Sullivan County
District Six
there's been a lot of pro and con today
and you know there is a growing divide
in our culture
that is evolving into a Chasm of
dichotomy and controversy
in other words always versus new ways
rights of personal
choices and rights versus Community
left unaddressed those that Gap will
only widen
I have a little different viewpoint
today
this bill is a mandate for parents
teachers and schools to communicate
and work together for the sake of the
child
what we've been describing here is a
great lack of communication
wall of obfuscation
that's not serving the children
and that's our first Focus
in any situation of stress for a child
we have to communicate so that that
doesn't worsen into depression isolation
so again this is a mandate for
communication
for these divisions to come instead
together
and communicate to one another
parents to teachers teachers to parents
so please support this bill as a way for
better communication thank you thank you
good afternoon
thank you chairman and members of the
education committee for your wrapped
patient and considerate attention
I am a resident of Concord and I was
privileged to be a 30-year 33-year
employee of the New Hampshire judicial
branch where we handled thousands of
abuse and neglect cases over the course
of my career
most of the people certainly most of the
people in this room and actually most
people who have children
truly care for their children love them
and are gentle and kind
and those families are probably the
kinds of families where children will
ultimately feel comfortable sharing
their journey through their sexual
identity
but I am here to remind you
that there are a lot of homes there are
some homes not the majority that are
abusive
and the children in those homes are
fearful they do not have the liberty of
coming out and speaking to their parents
they are scared
they depend on us
they depend on you
you will never know who they are
you will never know
their pain if they experience profound
rejection from their families
you will not see the connection
if they commit suicide
it would be perverse
to require our teachers in this state to
report suspicions of child abuse to the
abuser
this is no different
please protect the children you do not
see thank you
thank you
welcome
good afternoon
my name is Chloe Cole and I speak in
favor of this bill
I come to you today because our most
vulnerable are being targeted by an
Insidious ideology that is silently and
slowly propagated throughout much of
Western culture
I fell victim to this ideology when I
was only 12 years old
the effects of which how wreaked havoc
on my on my entire body and I'm still
feeling the damage today and I will for
as long as I live
this has become this is because I am a d
transitioner a former transgender child
who has been through the medical
transition process not quite unlike the
trans kids that radical trans activists
are trying to create
I was fast tracked by doctors who
behaved more like abusers and meet
butchers than medical professionals and
do medical transitions into medical into
a medical transition starting at 13 when
I was given puberty suppressants and
cross-sex hormones before they took my
breasts away from me at 15 years old
I don't know the status of my fertility
I don't know if I can carry the term I
don't know how many years this has taken
off of my life I have no idea because
the medical community has failed me
repeatedly at every turn
I wish just a child
I didn't deserve any of this
but I have to live with chronic physical
and psychological pain because of this
my voice will always be lower and weaker
than it should be parts of my body have
been masculized permanently and because
my puberty was disrupted when I was
barely a teenager
I have stopped growing and I will never
develop quite like I was supposed to
I'm still suffering the consequences of
the atrophy of my reproductive and
pelvic organs I will never be able to
breastfeed and I have no idea
for how much longer these big wounds on
my chest will be leaking fluid every day
after every morning and after every
shower I have to dress up these wounds
with bandages so that this fluid doesn't
stain my clothing and bedding
no child and no adult deserves to go
through the pain that I have if this is
the outcome with fully supportive
parents with the best resources possible
do you really think it would be any
better if we hide it from parents the
best data we have on social transition
to minors from the AAP says that once
social transition is affirmed around 90
or more will continue on to
medicalization
in another study if the child's identity
is not affirmed the vast majority of
kids will desist before the age of 18.
they grow out of it when they're just
given the chance to be kids
how are teachers and school
administrators qualified to administer
complex psychological interventions like
social transition knowing that by
initiating this intervention it will
lead to lifelong medical experimentation
we have a chance today to turn the tide
in New Hampshire it is of the essence
that we fight this because there are
vulnerable children many of whom are gay
or on the Spectrum children just like me
who are counting on us don't wait a
decade until there are hundreds of me
standing in front of you this is our
last chance thank you thank you
b-r-e-n-n-a
or we do need a little bit of that zener
blows or you know the old cursive
writing or manuscript the Palmer method
go ahead
because of so many of the things I've
heard
The Last Story
was heartbreaking
that was an individual with a story we
need to remember that each of these kids
are individuals with stories
and with all due respect I do not
believe that most kids choose to
detransition when they grow up in fact
what I have read is that very very few
of them do
and while my heart breaks for anybody
that is hurting for what has happened to
them my heart also breaks
for the people that I have seen testify
again and again and again please listen
to us is what they say today I heard
some particularly cruel things said and
I watched a young person put their arm
around another young person in the lgbtq
community we are subjecting these kids
to so much hurt and like it or not the
truth is
othering the transgender community and
demonizing public teachers has spread
across this country
it's out there we see it we see it at
political rallies we hear all kinds of
terminology that is false meanwhile and
I have done some research looked at
statistics if you look at a school of a
thousand kids there are probably five
who are gender non-conforming who cannot
go to a parent for whatever reason not
because the parent's going to shoot them
maybe the parent is going to say get out
of the house maybe it's the shame maybe
they just need time and yet we are
putting all this effort
into the four parts of this bill
that might hurt those five kids out of a
thousand why are we doing that why
aren't we talking about what we should
be talking about a good education for
all kids finding ways to finance it that
is fair finding the kind of Mental
Health and Social Services that these
kids need
two of the speakers that I heard one
listed all of the professional
child-oriented organizations that are
against this bill listen to them
and please listen to the kids who have
gone through it if they dare tell you
unfortunately a lot of them don't
we're in a hurry kids are getting off
I appreciate you taking my um I am in
support of SB 272 my name is Therese
brasterash I'm from Loudon New Hampshire
I have two little boys who are going to
get off the bus here shortly I want to
First say that I do not see this bill as
a transgender
sexual orientation Bill whatsoever and I
think that that has been the majority of
the conversation here today
um what has been brought to my attention
is that there's surveys that are being
given to our children in the schools in
which the schools get compensation for
that have a lot of information or
questions in them that a lot of us
parents would not want our child to be
asked the question as to is there
someone of the same sex they would like
to be intimate with without our
knowledge we don't want to see things on
our Chromebooks where it's asking a
young man to ejaculate into a Mountain
Dew bottle or be retaliated to drink
someone else's ejaculate and not know
that that's on their Chromebook we want
to know what's in our libraries we want
to know what our kids are being subject
to we want to know what they're facing
during their school day and that's being
withheld from us
quickly my testimony we're telling
children to lie to parents
is that not creating just more stigma
like don't we want the community to
embrace these children with wherever
Pursuit of Happiness whatever their
uniqueness is
why would we want to foster a narrative
and the rhetoric of you need to keep
this quiet versus
be proud you know tell the world who and
how you feel
and we are mandatory reporters I've
heard a lot of training that needs to
happen here because if a child is
subject to incest or abuse or neglect
that needs to be reported as a foster
mom every single time
um
are we telling the children not to trust
their parents and to keep lies from them
but yet to trust a government employee
zoom out on that one for a moment
what happens when you're in China and at
age five you go off to a boarding school
and you as a parent have no say in what
those are government employees want to
feed to your child
what if it is completely
against their ability to pursue
happiness in their own unique way
is that what we want to Shepherd our
community and our culture to
do we all not just want the ability to
pursue happiness in our own unique ways
if a child is fearful about coming out
we are already mandatory reporters if
that child is put in harm in doing so
do we not want to make certain that this
population this is a big one for me I'm
a nurse
I know my license I know the boundaries
of where I'm supposed to practice if I
go beyond that I can harm someone if
this demographic is truly 40 chance of
suicidal ideation time is up I would
just say we need to make sure those
children get to True professionals to
help save their lives
they are wonderfully and beautifully
made and I would hug every single person
in this room there is not time for hate
but these children deserve to have
like to invite Elaine Zhao
XI
ayo
foreign
my name is Elaine Xiao and I go by date
them pronouns I'm a sophomore at
Dartmouth College in Hanover and I would
like to testify in opposition of SB 272
I want to start by saying that I won't
pretend I know what it's like being a
queer identifying public school student
here in New Hampshire I want to clarify
that Chloe Cole the D transitioner who
spoke earlier and also spoke at my
school yesterday is not a New Hampshire
resident so I will proudly admit that I
did not grow up here I grew up going to
private school in the Bay Area
California pretty much as sheltered as
you can get I was lucky enough to
inhabit spaces at school where my
queerness would have been accepted
without much question if I so chose to
claim it
but I didn't I only came out as
non-binary and started socially
transitioning a couple months ago I only
allowed myself to explore my identity
after settling down in college on the
opposite side of the country where I
knew I could have a fresh start away
from everyone who knew or thought they
knew me I still somehow managed to
internalize a harmful rhetoric that I
couldn't possibly know what I wanted for
myself and that therefore it would be a
waste of time to treat my queerness as
anything but a phase and now it's all
catching up to me while I've got a
degree to pursue and a future to plan it
feels like there is never a right time
to sit down breathe and figure out who I
am
passing a bill like SB 272 would only
cut down on this precious time it would
deny young people the safe space to come
into their own identity without fear of
judgment that is before they enter into
the real world and face ever more casual
and blatant bigotry it would enlist
teachers and other peers to police
gender Norms within the highly vague
parameters of any I quote circumstances
which a reasonable person would
understand to be for the purpose of
facilitating a change and gender
I ask who gets to decide what counts as
socially acceptable femininity and
socially acceptable masculinity why are
we reinforcing these dated oppressive
binary stereotypes in the first place
lastly the bill would directly endanger
the young people most at risk for harm
the parents most likely to invoke the
right to know about their child binding
their chest at school are probably the
ones most likely to punish them for it
furthermore we're crucially for getting
here that school is not an equally safe
space for all speaking as one of the few
and maybe the only young queer person of
color here in this room I don't need yet
another reason for people to surveil me
single me out and instill shame in me on
the basis of my minority identity so
while the policy may have been
formulated in the name of protecting
children it is clear that it only
further jeopardizes Us by threatening
our basic rights to autonomy and privacy
it takes a lot of Courage especially as
a young person to stand in defiance of
compulsory norms and live as a true self
I'm I just urge you all to vote in
opposition of sb2 thank you
do you hear me okay go ahead Julie Smith
from Nashua I support this bill
transparent is a compound word the first
part trans which is Latin for a cross
is what the opposition wants the
committee to concentrate on the second
is parent as in the theme of this bill
it is no accident that this bill is
about transparency I'm asking the
committee to ignore all the out-of-state
and paid agitators gathered in the
capital today trying to Brand this bill
as lgbtq ABCDEFG
instead please indulge my request that
you swap out that theme for something
else any other issue that we can all
agree on that requires parental
notification as per the moral compass
though not a comprehensive list some
suggestions are new and unusual behavior
declining academic performance or
symptoms of a medical problem
and I urge you at this committee to
visit prageru.com and watch their
five-minute video preferably at the
beginning of an executive session to
vote on this bill
about the Dark Art of framing because
that's what's going on
as it has been for hours here in this
room
and all of New Hampshire and in the 49
other states
once alert to that strategy
the committee can recognize it being
applied to other bills as well so it is
a good investment of time
as someone without kids who's forced to
pay for the education of other people's
kids I support this bill because I
object to the culture war against
parents admittedly 40 years ago I would
not have felt the same way but it was my
own parents who lectured me about the
assault on the family unit being a big
part of the Marxist Playbook
everyone is the secrets their secrets
and sick people rarely get well if they
don't know they're sick and their
sickness is kept secret from those best
in position to help them their parents
one year ago
on the originally scheduled date of this
hearing Jr took a picture of me at the
mic
for this committee which made the union
leader
that was the Senate hearing for HB 1131
that bill was essentially also about
parental rights while it was in this
very committee during a blizzard on
February 25th of last year we heard
about a student suicide attempt that
student's parent
who was previously a school candidate
made a point to make the journey here in
a blizzard
to be heard as did many others don't you
think that's evidence enough that nearly
every parent loves their kids as Senator
Carson had pointed out earlier
kids were not property of the government
and schools need to stay in their Lane
I have no representation in the house
therefore I am counting on this
committee to support this bill Second
Chance time is up please vote yes thank
you
hi everyone I did submit written
testimony and I had a whole speech
prepared but I've been sitting here
today taking this all in and um I'm
gonna wing it
my name is Lisa Rappaport I am a member
of the school board in Portsmouth New
Hampshire I would like to just kindly
remind everyone in this room no matter
what you believe you actually do have
right you have a right to vote you have
a right to vote for school boards who in
New Hampshire have one job which is to
set policy for local schools we have had
a policy in Portsmouth for many years
now that offers broad protection from
discrimination and surveillance for
every single one of our students
including our lgbtq students this law
would decimate Portsmouth policy and
policy in many other schools across the
state policy that was set by locally
elected school boards who were chosen by
the people who live in those communities
who send their children to those schools
and I fully respect the right of anyone
here who doesn't want to send their
child to public school or who doesn't
like the values that I have to
vote me out that's your right I hope you
don't but you can and you do have a
voice I have been an active PTA
volunteer the entire time my kids have
been in school I have shop around field
trips I have volunteered in classrooms I
have been on a first name basis with
every single teacher my children have
had the entire time they've been in
public schools and I just have to say it
has been so emotionally challenging to
sit here all day and listen to people
evoke totalitarian regimes to talk about
our teachers and our Educators who are
working their asses off in a really hard
circumstance every day for not great pay
and they deal with a lot of grief
my dad was a public school teacher my
dad is a holocaust Survivor I'm wearing
today on my left hand my grandmother's
wedding ring and she survived Nazi
Germany so I think you have to ask
yourself which side of History you want
to be on here do you want to be on the
side of the proud boys and the neo-nazis
or do you want to be on the side of
people in the state of New Hampshire who
respect personal Liberty I'm not saying
that I should have a right to choose the
values for anybody else's family I am
asking you to respect the fact that our
public schools are supposed to serve
every single family including families
of Faith including families who do not
want to have their kids be gay I mean I
hope that parents can support their kids
but we need to include all people in our
public schools and this bill doesn't do
that this bill says that my children who
are non-binary both of them and who both
came out to me in their own time and in
their own way and who would have been
here today but they didn't want to miss
school
it says that it's not okay for them to
be who they are it says it's not okay
for them to go to the GSA and talk to
their friends and talk to their teachers
and just share experiences and work
things out and I would respectfully say
if all of you don't think this is really
about discriminating against trans kids
then you know what you got about 40
lines of text you can remove from this
bill right now that will no longer
Target trans kids and lgbtq kids so if
this is just about parents being able to
join a PTA or go to the school board
Carla Garcia
let me start off with saying I was a
transgender woman for over 20 years
I'm a d transitioner
I am a gay man not queer queer's a slur
and I'm going to address the elephant in
the room
I was a member and an advocate
of the lgbtqia trans queer gender cult
for over 30 years
this coat destroyed me mentally and
physically and emotionally
so I can call it a cult
I was the suicidal trans kid that we've
heard about all day
I was also a suicidal trans adult
because transition affirmation and
acceptance does not take away depression
angst and suicidal ideation
as a child I was targeted
I was desensitized I was groomed
molested abused conditioned sex
trafficked by this cult
my proof is my past thank you for
talking about me earlier I am a
registered sex offender because directly
because of what this cult
has done to me for over 30 years
I became an agent for this movement and
for my sex traffickers
at age six molested for the first of
hundreds of times
age 13 and mind you this is all by my
own community
age 13 I over overdosed on pills age 14
I was The Runaway prostitute sex
trafficked suicidal trans kid we all
hear about I began wrong sex hormones at
age 14. also was on drugs alcohol I was
also had HIV AIDS at age 14. age 15 my
mental deterioration started from
directly from the hormones
age 16 I attempted suicide again
I was also sterile and had and have
severe Progressive osteoporosis
strictly from the wrong sex hormones
everyone that knew me thought I was
content happy and secure in my identity
as my true self
none of them knew that I was miserable I
was broken and I was suicidal
hurting and depressed
had I not been groomed by this cult
I wouldn't have destroyed my life and I
probably wouldn't be here today
desensitizing children with explicit
materials is grooming
these materials along with keeping
personal and sexual secrets
with vulnerable impressionable children
is grooming
and let's really I need to address this
elephant in the room I had gender
dysphoria your time is up thank you
you're welcome
Carlos
Cardona
good afternoon ladies gentlemen and
other my name is Carlos e Cardona LeBron
I'm from Laconia New Hampshire born in
Puerto Rico I also served on the New
Hampshire Commission of Native American
Affairs and I'm proud to be here as a
gay man and a father of two beautiful
little children that I fear for their
future based on what I've heard here
today
I'm going to tell you a quick story
about a
young man named Enrique and Jonathan
Enrique figured out that at the age of
12 he was gay
at the age of 14 Enrique and Jonathan
at the age of 14 Jonathan was forced out
of the closet
by his Protestant parents he was forced
into conversion therapy
Enrique finds him
Enrique is forced to live with that
image for the rest of his life
at the age of 15 Enrique comes out to
his algebra teacher which ironically
he was failing that class but he trusted
and loved that teacher that teacher
guided Enrique to become the man that he
is today
I am Enrique
I was forced to watch from a very young
age
parents that did not accept me
when I came out to my parents I was
kicked out of my house in Haverhill
Massachusetts I was a gold medalist in
the debate team president of Whittier
Vocational Technical High School
great student only failing math
and I was forced to be homeless because
somebody did not love me or accept me
I am grateful today that my parents have
come a long way and because of time and
age and the information out there my
parents love me and my mom today lives
with me and I take care of who's
fighting cancer
but this is the real story happening out
there this is what we're forcing trans
kids to face every single day so you
have a choice you can be the hero in my
life story
or you could be the monster that
continues to perpetuate this Injustice
and this unfairness that lgbtq students
are having to face every single day
so for the rest of my life
I will have to remember Jonathan and
keep his life and his memory alive
I hope you all understand how painful
this was to share with you
but I hope you take it more seriously
the job that you have at your hands
today
lgbtq students need you and as a parent
let's protect our children thank you
oppose this Bill thank you
good afternoon Mr chairman and committee
members
I just want to extend a heart felt with
gratitude to be able to
speak
I am a long time a New Hampshire
resident 25 years
and the first person in my life
that modeled parental rights on my
behalf
was my father Israel
he modeled with respect
I hear a lot of words and
um
that describe feelings and
I don't come or approach this place
with a heart of judgment
but I do approach this place
with ears to hear and have a heart of
discernment
and because my father modeled for me
what a parent and how a parent should
walk
I too walk that for my kids
my eldest will soon be 23. to this day
she calls me and says mom do you
remember that time when this happened to
me in school
and Mom do you remember how they said
I'm not perfect
but I do stand on behalf of my god-given
right as a parent
because I've been giving children and
that's a blessing and I take it with the
utmost respect
and fervent reverence
and I trust that this committee
would please support this bill it
matters to me and it matters to the
other parents who have had this similar
experience
and to those who have suffered I get it
I walked the streets of Boston and
methadone Mile with my husband
who right now serves Ministry to the
homeless and the drug addicted and those
that are in outside of the city Gates
our hearts are for them
so that they can be restored
let's keep that in the back of my of our
minds when we enter in the school system
it's a heart of restoration and respect
and honor first to the parents
and then to those
we've all been students
your experience may be different than
mine and I just leave you with this
honor the place in which God has given
you the right you will be voting your
conscience and you will first be before
him
thank you respectfully Rosa Couture
thank you
good afternoon and thank you for your
taking the time to listen to me
my name is Jama Wilder I am the mother
of five children and last year I removed
my two oldest children from the Hollis
Brookline School District
I attempted to voice my concerns at the
town meeting in March about the
curriculum and the programs they have
been implementing
we were voting on the school budget and
it was very relevant for people to make
an informed decision
the moderator shut off my microphone
because extremists at the meeting were
yelling that I wasn't speaking to the
article which was an outright lie
I wasn't out of time but I was silenced
because I contradicted The Narrative of
the radicals
parents and families are the foundation
of this society and this bill protects
god-given rights that should not have to
be defined
I was completely shut out of my child's
education I was refused curriculum
I was told I could not meet with
teachers without an administrator
present
denied access to my children's classroom
and the library
I blame the administrators not the
teachers for this
parents that love their children and
have concerns are being actively pushed
out of having a say in what is happening
in their children's education
in many cases parents don't even see
books or assignments because of the way
technology is used today
if a child is sent to school the parent
is entrusting the teachers to educate
their children not to indoctrinate them
I am shocked that so many people would
be in opposition of this bill
children are impressed impressionable
and can be easily swayed into believing
things that are not true it is our job
as loving parents to guide them and
raise them in the way they should go
I personally think it's disturbing to be
having conversations with children as
young as six years old about gender they
are planting seeds and causing children
to question things they should not even
be considering
it is every parent's right to know if
statements are made by their child at
school or anywhere that they would
question anything regarding concerns or
Life Changes they want to make if this
bill is not passed I will begin a
campaign to pull children out of schools
and have parents start homeschooling
there's a lot of us out here that are
already doing it and there's going to be
a lot more if you don't give parents
rights thank you
thank you very much I'd like to invite
hi that's me Holloway testerman I'm here
to speak in opposition to the bill and I
just want to say I really hear the last
couple people that have spoken because I
was actually raised in a very
conservative religious community I was
homeschooled K-12 I went to a private
Christian College so really you know for
people who support this bill my parents
were involved in every facet of my
education
um I I mean I will say I do love and
respect them deeply and you know they
also impose their religious and moral
values
including the idea that queerness is a
sin over my entire academic and social
life and yet I'm still bisexual and this
is actually the first time that I've
come out in public
um parental involvement did nothing to
make my queerness go away it only served
to make me repress my identity and it
created complex PTSD from being in a
consistently homophobic environment that
I've been in treatment for for years
um I'm now blessed to work with trans
and queer kids every day I'm a mental
health professional in school for all
the parents here I will say that I'm a
mandated reporter if your kid is in
imminent danger or has experienced abuse
or is about to hurt themselves or other
people you will know about it
um and you can request your child's
entire treatment record
um that's your right you can do that
um I've never had anyone do that though
um but what brings me joy is that these
kids that I work with they they have
information and Power about who they are
and who they want to come out to I
didn't know if it was possible to like
both men and women and non-binary people
until I was in my early 20s like I
didn't even know who I was and they know
who they are and what the options are
early on and that just brings me so much
joy but I will say you know we don't
have mental health issues because we're
queer and trans we have mental health
issues because we have to experience
trauma from living in a transphobic and
a homophobic Society
um and I would just really urge you to
oppose this bill
thank you very much
ing
good afternoon honorable chair committee
members uh I'm Kate Cook and I'm a city
councilor from Portsmouth New Hampshire
I'm here in my personal capacity today
as a mom to a non-binary teenager
my husband and I have worked hard to
have a very open and loving home word is
okay to be who you are whomever that may
be
my child has identified as lgbtqia plus
since the early their early teen years
and is an active participant in the
gender and sexuality Alliance at school
while I knew all of this because my
child is very comfortable sharing most
everything at home with us
I did not know that my child identified
as non-binary and used they them
pronouns at school until this year
why didn't I know that especially if my
child is so comfortable and feel safe in
my home
because my child was nervous about
telling me not because I wouldn't accept
them as non-binary but because they did
not want me to know that they were not
going by then they were going by a name
other than the one that I gave them
they knew that it was important to me
that I had named them after my beloved
grandmother
and they did not want to upset me that
they they were not using that name and
they were using a different name at
school
I was actually stunned to find this out
but we're a very loving and caring we
have a very loving and caring home where
we are completely accepting of all
people
we have long had family and friends who
are transgender
so again my child was not afraid of
letting me know that they were gender
non-conforming they were afraid that
that I would be upset that they weren't
using my grandmother's name
and to find something out like that was
upsetting for me but what it told me was
that my child felt safe at school
felt safe being themselves in the school
setting and that made me feel good about
my child that my child was happy
and well adjusted in school that's the
most important thing to me as a parent
that my child is a happy person
and has a happy life
not what I know or don't know about my
child we can't ever know everything
about our teenagers
if my child was nervous about sharing
with me imagine a gender non-conforming
child with parents who did not accept
their gender identity or sexual
orientation
it would be impossible for that child to
trust any adult at school with their
identity for fear of disclosure of their
identity to to their parents who would
reject them or Worse abuse them
emotionally or physically for not
conforming to heterosexual gender norms
this bill will drive gender
non-conforming students back into the
closet because they will fear they will
have to be outed for whatever reason if
your goal is to make young people feel
unsafe you're at school time is up
to feel they have have no one they can
trust then you'll succeed if you pass
this bill if you care about all of our
children then you'll oppose it
thank you
thank you for hearing us today
I wanted to bring to your attention
something very disturbing that was
posted on social media it reads as a
third grade teacher I keep a cross on my
wall it often provokes questions from
the children
most are excited to hear about my faith
they point to the cross on the wall and
I tell them about the resurrection
you need to understand I'm not
indoctrinating these children they come
to me and I follow their questions back
to its source
some have even gotten baptized in the
sink as long as they don't tell their
parents it's our secret I tell them guys
it's important that we keep this a
secret
these kids feel something is not right
inside them and I help them to
understand that possibly Jesus is what
they're missing
another teacher writes during summer
school I have a holy closet
where my Curious students can get
religious books and dress-up clothes
yasmine's parents are Muslims but she's
always felt more like a Catholic and is
afraid to tell them
here she is free to read the Bible and
be sister Yasmine All Summer Long
how incensed are we that a teacher would
use their position to indoctrinate the
children they are paid to educate and
then add insult to injury by teaching
them to keep it a secret from their
parents
here's the most important part of this
story those posts weren't real they were
satire those teachers aren't really
doing those things they were pointing
out hypocrisy
thinking it was real many people
responded with outrage
overall the thing that made people the
most angry was children being told to
keep secrets from parents many of them
equated secrets to grooming and yes they
actually used that word when they
thought it was being used against a
Christian
what if teachers decided their proniums
were child of God daughter of the king
and students had to use them
you know it would lead to discussions
about Christianity from children
people were outraged when it came to
parents not knowing what their children
are being taught outraged about a
teacher discussing their personal
beliefs and Lifestyles to their children
outraged about being left in the dark
about a philosophy or lifestyle being
discussed behind their back
how did you feel when you thought a
teacher was actually baptizing children
or displaying symbols of Christianity
Christianity in his classroom knowing it
would lead to conversations if that made
you angry and yet you opposed this bill
then ask yourself if you in fact are a
hypocrite
children should never be taught to keep
secrets from their parents in fact they
should be taught that anyone who tells
them to keep secrets from their parents
is dangerous please support this bill
there's a couple of things I'd like to
address your time is up okay thank you
thank you very much Roger blow
bleau
I'm very much opposed to this bill I
just want to tell you all I I think I'm
a very good dad
and when my daughter turned 20 after
having been out in college for a couple
years she
realized that she was a lesbian
her dad was homophobic at the time
she was afraid to tell me the rest of my
immediate family knew but I didn't know
so when she came out to me she says Dad
I want you to love me or who I am not
who you think I am
so I don't know what adults she confided
in who she needed to have support for
all that time but I'm glad they were
there for her because I think it does
take a village
I just wanted to say another time I was
coaching Little League
and another coach and I decided to go
see this the parents of this kid because
he was a nice kid but he missed a lot of
practices and we really emphasized that
so we went to the kids house together
when the father opened the door our
sense was this guy was unsafe for this
kid so we kept it secret from him that
his his son was missing practices
because that was too dangerous I believe
in teachers so much they give so much I
had an act that was never married I said
do you feel bad you didn't have any kids
she said I had thousands of kids she
loved all those kids she did everything
they could they have all these IEPs for
Teacher they have to teach one kid one
way they'll teach another kid another
way there's different races religions
genders they have so much and they love
these kids they try they're hired us to
do this and I want a kid to be able to
go to a trusted teacher a guidance
counselor to to keep their secrets to
help them until they're ready my
daughter waited till she was 20 to come
up to me how about these kids what are
they going if they're confused they want
to know and and I really think that this
is kind of a cultural War you know I
think the
um the legislature is getting in the way
of teachers is getting away at Medical
things we don't want to teach CIT we
don't want to teach lgbtq et cetera et
cetera I think it's good if if kids know
all about their world when I was in
Vietnam
I had r r in Australia when we when we
got to uh Australia we had the chaplain
talk to all of us and he said in this
country if you're caught with drugs
you're going to jail they taught us
about the culture that we had to go into
well our cultures are all over the place
in the United States but that doesn't
mean one family loves their people more
than the others so I think this bill
will hurt kids and I have lgbtq family
and I don't want them hurt and I don't
want them being ratted on like another
kid says oh you know what tell the
teacher that this this person might be
gay oh let's get this person you know
what I mean it's gonna be all that kind
of stuff it reminds me of when I I when
I read about uh Hitler having children
ratting on different people you know I I
really think that's bad so I just want
to say thank you for listening and
please vote against this bill protect
people thank you thank you
thank you for calling me I thought I was
going to miss work
so
the uh
I'm I only have a couple of minutes so
I'm going to get to the chase I I've uh
I'm a Christian
I worked in human services for 45 years
I also was chair of the school board and
on the school board in Fremont as well
as a budget committee and my last job
well before I retired I'm working
temporarily now I was a liaison with
correctional facilities
and if you want to hear about abuse
people suffered
I could make your blood curl
but that never was an excuse for the
crime that they committed
I held them responsible
and the reason is is because as a
Christian I believe that there is a
right and wrong
we have a moral
responsibility before God and before
each other
and parents the Bible tells parents to
train up a child the way they should go
and he will not depart from it
it's a parent's responsibility to impart
the moral the right morals the morals
that kids need that we need to to work
and abide by to remain a free Society
what we have here is two competing
philosophies
we have the philosophies of Classical
liberalism which says we live in a a
universe Guided by both physical and
moral rules
and we have the philosophy of the
philosophs of France Revolution
who taught that Civilization is bad
the civilization was a problem of all of
all Humanity
because it prevented them from living
and experiencing and living the life
they wanted to live Rousseau thought
marriage was a waste of time
because it prevented him from having fun
and he loved the French orphanages
because the place he could put his
children
that he had out of wedlock
the the philosophs yearned for a
philosopher king
right now they yearn for a all-knowing
bureaucracy
that knows everything it can take care
of us
it can make decisions for us
and yet God did not imbue a bureaucracy
through the responsibility to bring them
up our kids
think about that
Joshua when he about to die confronted
Israel
I think it's up for our elected
representatives too I offer that same
challenge to you
choose you this day
which kind of society do you want
a sign a society based on physical and
moral rules
or one that's based on
Nancy
okay let's see if I can
how's that
good
uh for the record I'm Nancy Marland I
live in Sugar Hill the lovely mountain
town
I have a PhD in child development and I
spent my entire working life working
with Children and Families
and I have to say SB 272 is fascinating
it enumerates a long list of parental
rights most of which are already enacted
into New Hampshire statute as we've
heard repeatedly today
so what problem exactly are we trying to
fix with this bill
I have an opinion
there's been a lot of talk about honesty
in this room today
and I think that the honest truth is
is a deceitful attempt to give cover to
harassment of transgender kids by
including it in an otherwise benign list
of Legally existing rights that schools
already observe and everyone agrees with
the only specific behaviors named in SB
272 relate to transgender youngsters
if the legislature is so concerned that
parents be informed of their kids
behaviors why is gender identity the
only one mentioned
sexual activity sexual assault bullying
risky Behavior depression SB 272 is
silent on these matters
surely if the state's interest or kids
welfare
these areas of concern would be included
as things parents should know about
if transgender kids choose not to inform
their parents of their gender identity
there is a reason we have heard that
fully explored all day
parents who cannot accept a child's
identity can reject them abuse them harm
them physically and emotionally
and I have to say in my experience when
a child comes to a teacher
with an issue
one of the first things that a teacher
will try to do is encourage that child
to speak to their parents about it
that's just standard practice I don't
know where people are getting this idea
forcing School Personnel to betray the
trust of these kids by outing them to
their parents is cruel and infringes on
the privacy of the minor child
for vulnerable youngsters the presence
in their lives of a trusted non-family
adult can make a Monumental difference
this is supported in study after study
in the psychological literature
SB 272 removes trusted teachers coaches
and counselors from this role your time
is up can I conclude with one last thing
I can only assume that the sponsors of
this bill have never had a beloved
grandchild come to them Terror and hope
in their soft young eyes and say
nanny I am non-binary because if they
had there would be only one course for
them to take and that would be to
protect time is up that grandchild by
voting against this Bill thank you
good afternoon we made it okay I am a
mother and a former teacher of 15 years
and I have a question for all of you
have you ever wondered where the line is
and speaking of the line in society that
we never crossed with children when
adults were talking the children were
told to leave the room because some
topics were not for young ears topics
such as religion politics and sex were
not discussed at school teachers never
discussed their viewpoints on any topic
and we never knew anything about their
lives in fact some of my students
thought I lived at school
slowly over the past 10 years that line
has been blurred and even erased some
teachers have decided to become students
friends and confidence
with that comes power influence over
what a child thinks and feels while
they've been sitting here I have seen
two news articles of recent arrests and
convictions of school personnels and
teachers and of sexual assault on
children
please teachers are human beings they
should not be put up on pedestals and
all I've heard today is a lot of attacks
on parents but we do still have a
problem in the schools
and no a background check is not going
to secure that a school Personnel is
safe because they have not been
convicted
as a former teacher of grades K to eight
with a master's degree I can speak
freely today
many teachers out there would like to
stand up and support parent rights but
fear for their jobs and repercussions
against their own children if they do
speak up
School Personnel do not want to insert
themselves into a role as a parental
proxy and hide important facts from a
child's parents they only want to teach
the academic skills that they were hired
to do
there have been many times where I've
had to call parents about what their
child has confided to me I did this
because it's the right thing to do many
times a student would rather I not call
but that's not the role the teacher to
come between a parent and their child
no school employee has the right or the
privilege to keep any information a
child shares with them from a parent
except under rare circumstances
School Employees who only know a child
for a blink of an eye versus a parent
who has known their child for years are
not a child's friend or parent that line
should never be crossed you may be
wondering how the line was blurred or
even erased in New Hampshire the New
Hampshire School Board Association sends
out suggested policy for member School
boards to adopt and in 2015 the School
Board Association proposed a policy
called jbab Dash R would propose that
schools were to lie to parents about
their child's activities and discussions
with school personnel
the School Board Association is a
non-profit organization that is
supported by your tax money through
annual dues that your school board pays
this organization has over 2.5 million
dollars in assets that's your tax
dollars to spend on lobbying not for
your children but to protect School
Administrations
some would say parents have these rights
listed in SC 272 already and that
current law protects these rights so far
that is not true as parental rights are
being denied by multiple School boards
across New Hampshire please pass SB 72
for parents thank you
hello my name is Chris ribbett and I'd
like to to testify in support of of 272.
I am a parent of an elementary child in
New Hampshire I am also a high school
science teacher at a public school I
will read part of an activity that our
local school conducts without notifying
parents and I would like you to imagine
that I am speaking to your child or you
at age five this is the care for kids
now that we have talked about our bodies
and our public and private parts we are
going to do an activity we are going to
trace our bodies and then you can draw
your body just as it looks when you come
out of the bathtub or shower
our school is asking our five-year-old
children to draw themselves naked
to say if a child is hesitant about
drawing you can gently suggest adding
more parts
can you add your elbows how about your
fingernails a penis
another useful approach is to offer to
draw for them
where would you like me to put the
nipples
when my wife and I brought up our
concerns that not notifying parents
about this activity in advance is in
violation of state law 186 9 section 9.
the guidance counselor acting principal
and superintendent dismiss them and
assured us that this program was age
appropriate not sexual education and no
notice was necessary
we brought up her concerns to the
Department of Education and they
recommended we resolve our issues
locally
the school said that they would notify
parents about this and they never did
there was no accountability
one of the problems with this bill is
that proponents and opponents disagree
on the definition of abuse
would you consider an adult asking a
minor to draw themselves naked abuse I
do I would be horrified to participate
in that activity today but at age five I
would not even be able to decline
participating no matter no matter how
uncomfortable I was
isn't it abuse abusive to foster a
relationship with a minor and encourage
them to keep secrets from their parents
there are many examples of abusers doing
just that
in the same way that we should encourage
students to not keep secrets about what
goes on at home to prevent hiding abuse
we should not keep secrets at school
I'll read all this curriculum defines
grooming
there are five main categories The
Grooming process may include building
trust testing boundaries desensitive
desensitization manipulation and
confusion and I ask you does this
curriculum do those things is it
grooming
thank you thank you
thank you Mr chairman and committee
members it's been a long day and I
appreciate your staying and listening to
all of us the essential question here
today really is should a child be the
one who gets to decide when they're
going to tell their parents about their
identity if you think that should be the
child's decision then you'd be opposed
to this bill
I'll offer you two arguments that might
just to help out first is children's
rights
the argument was made way back earlier
in the day I think it was speaker
Packard who said parents should be 100
involved in their children's life
I don't think you can hold that to be
true throughout a child's life when
they're a baby yes by the time they're
17 they have a life of their own there's
a balance there our courts and our laws
recognize this all of the Supreme Court
cases that were read to you don't deny
the fact that children have rights for
example a minor of sound mind and
sufficient maturity can get a
prescription for birth control without a
parent's permission if so deemed by the
health care provider anyone 14 or over
can get tested for STDs or HIV if you're
12 you can voluntarily admit yourself
for treatment for drug dependency that's
RSA 318 B12 the age of consent is 16.
there are many exceptions in New
Hampshire law where children have rights
to operate without their parents consent
the New Hampshire Supreme Court has
repeatedly said that children become
mature look at all the divorce cases
from the 1980s provencel said by 14 the
child's preference is crucial buttrick
versus Butler chief judge king said
Common Sense tells us that a child
though still a minor will often be
sufficiently mature to play a large part
in 2005 chief judge Duggan in a case
where one of the parents wanted to look
at a child's mental health record said
minors have rights which they can assert
themselves in their own best interest
without the involvement of their parents
this could be today if you in other
words the point is there are many
examples in New Hampshire that parents
don't have 100 control of their children
right up until the day they turn 18. a
better solution would be to table this
bill and for the 20 of you to sit down
and come up with a bill called the
children's and parents Bill of Rights
where you balance everything this bill
says parents 100 percent children zero
percent that's doesn't make sense with
anybody's experience growing up or being
a parent the other problem I have with
this bill is specifically with the
compelling straight intersection because
those are where the exceptions exist
you've all you've heard many people
today say oh well if there's a problem
at home we have this section to protect
the kids that only works if it works
under the RSA 169c which is the abuse
and neglect standard that does not
include two very common situations
number one is homelessness and number
two is Potential Threat of suicide if a
school counselor knows that a child is
either going to be homeless or might
commit suicide David your time is up
okay I finish that's not sufficient
grounds for for the school to act in
that case that section of the bill is is
is not sufficient thank you very much
for your time thank you
good afternoon Mr chairman honorable
members of the committee my name is
Kenneth Tassie Jr a resident of
Manchester New Hampshire I sit on the
board of Manchester's Board of school
committee but I'm giving testimony
testimony today on my own behalf
and I'm standing here and strongly in
support of SB 272.
not too long ago this bill
would have been
Unthinkable not really even a thought
parental rights are a really common
sense
this bill arises
out of a necessity
because there's an emergence
of a new reality
where
Up Is Down and right is left and there's
a confusion
I think in our in our society about
you know what direction we need to what
direction we need to go in
case in point I received an email
yesterday
from an advocacy group called new
futures
encouraging me to vote against this bill
for the reason that quote SB 272 would
prioritize parents rights above
children's
which could prevent youth from
establishing support networks outside of
their family and I think the
the operating phrase here is would
prioritize parents rights above
children's
in this statement
tells me
that the this organization and probably
many similar to it who are with good
intention trying to Advocate on behalf
of of children
believe that children have
children's rights are Paramount
Paramount to their their parents right
simply by those words prioritize parents
on the contrary
SB 272 does not put a parent's right
above the child's right
it puts the familial relationship
between parents and children
above the relationship between the
student
and government employees
so I disagree that this is a hundred
percent for parents and zero for
children this is a hundred percent for
family
and this is not to diminish the precious
and important relationship
um I have a personal belief that
teachers and nurses are are two of the
greatest uh members of our community
and they're all underpaid and and should
be highly respected
I'd also like to be clear this is uh
this policy or this this bill is not
um
a bill that is anti
trans or anti-lgbt your time is up thank
you I encourage all of you to please
vote Yes for SB 272 thank you thank you
thank you for being here
my name is Cynthia young I use she her
pronouns I live in Exeter New Hampshire
and I teach in a New Hampshire Public
School I'm a cisgender straight white
female who teaches Western sieve
couched as a parental rights bill
my kids and I understand full well that
laughs
specifically on my non-binary
transgender child
when my kid came out to the family we
also learned that they'd come out
friends six months earlier teens do this
they express things with friends and
eventually let parents know I trust my
kid
I had a lot of questions when they came
out I started with how much I love them
the way just the way they are
if my kid had been outed to me before
they felt ready it could have done so
much damage
they deserve this time to think
SB 272 also presents an attack on my
profession as a teacher
without a child's express permission I
will not out that child to anyone their
story is not mine to tell
forcing teachers to out our children
will send a chilling message it
represents a gag order on children
especially those who don't feel safe at
home
lgbtq kids end up homeless at an alarm
alarming rate you've heard a lot about
that today
I don't want children to end up in an
unsafe living situation and possibly
dropping out of school which will happen
if this bill becomes law
transgender youths commit suicide at a
much higher rate than the general
population but that rate is lower if
they have just one just one trusted
adult in their lives
children need to be heard by people they
can trust
children will die
if this becomes law
my oldest kid who's now in college
called me the other night and asked if
we could go on a road trip together
for a few days this summer I said I'd
love to
as we talked my kid let me know of a
list of states that we can't travel to
since they wouldn't be safe to go to the
bathroom or feel safe to even exist
feel safe to even exist
please do not start down the slippery
slope that other states have been going
to not in New Hampshire
I have enjoyed living here thank you
my name is Bonnie Linda velk
I you can explain who I am I was 25
years ago
I've been in an educated for 25 years
I've been in 25 school districts and I
was my children are 25 years old or more
I as an educator am retired now but I
could not
not tell the truth to parents I'm a
parent
I did everything I could to communicate
with parents I had newsletters I showed
up early at school I showed up late at
school if parents wanted to communicate
I communicated
my hottest day that I ever taught was
the day I had to go in after a third
grader shot his sister by accident
I've been through turmer but we need to
forgive and go and move and do the best
we can to love those children
and to support parents
we've got a lot of great parents out
there we need we need help for some
parents I'm not saying no but we have a
lot of great parents that really want to
be a part of the school
my son because I advocated for him
graduated from Bentley
he got four years of education at New
Hampton School because the regular
school couldn't do it and that's okay he
just had a different learning style
but we got a lot of great parents and a
please
listen that parents need to know what's
going on thank you
thank you
welcome thank you finally
uh good afternoon chairman and members
of the education committee my name is
Michelle Clancy I'm mother I'm a Dover
School Board member and I'm a ward chair
for the Dover Democratic committee but
I'm representing only myself today in
voicing my strong opposition to SB 272
while much of SB 272 makes sense parts
of section 189 Overlook basic safety
concerns and specifically Target trans
and gender non-conforming students
specifically in section U what is the
definition of a reasonable person whose
definition is that because my definition
of a reasonable person is someone who
accepts people for who they are allows
people to exist as they are regardless
of how it makes me feel
I know without a doubt that that is not
the Bill's definition of a reasonable
person
this bill forces teachers counselors and
other school officials to interfere in
the family Dynamic instead of allowing
young adults who know their family
Dynamics better than any school staff
member to decide when to or not to share
their feelings with their parents or
Guardians
if a student is uncomfortable discussing
a personal topic or issue with a parent
the answer is not to use the government
to force teachers and counselors to
report that student to that parent
the answer is to have mechanisms of
support in place to enable better
communication between the student and
their family the answer is not to take
away a child's choice or their privacy
I'm asking you to look out for the
children who aren't comfortable sharing
personal thoughts and feelings with
their parents for the children who are
afraid to be open with their parents
please don't take away the one safe
place that these children have please
don't presume to understand their home
lives better than they themselves do
it is vital to have safe places in our
communities where adolescents can turn
for answers and support when they are
too afraid or embarrassed to talk to
their parents please don't leave these
children unprotected and alone please
allow public schools to continue their
mission of educating serving and project
protecting our youth SB 272 is a bad
idea that will make it more difficult
for teachers parents and students to
trust each other and will only serve to
further divide our already beleaguered
communities thank you thank you Nancy
Richard
Anthony
good afternoon Richard Anthony of
Plaistow New Hampshire I want to speak
in support of SB 272 in principle
on the idea of transparency in
government
and also parental rights in the sense
that as a parent I have a vested
interest and am the primary
shareholder shall we say in my child's
well-being in all considerations about
that I understand that there are
peripheral or even maybe concurrent
arguments that have been brought up here
today but
I look at as a function of government
that anyone that's
basically even saying not to be truthful
not to be forthcoming not to be
transparent these are all words that are
incompatible with the fact that it's a
government it's our our money our
children the most precious things to us
it's incompatible
all right
I've in my own limited way I've I've
I've become involved in in local
government
on a lease on a planning level on a
budget committee and My Credo has been
one of transparency and advocacy for the
people that I represent
all right and
what I basically see here if there's
anyone that's saying things like
dissembling observocating or make using
or weaponizing the process to make it
difficult for someone to get answers I
find that very problematic
I understand that there are various
regulations rsas and such that have
already been that are probably already
in place and we're at the point now
where it needs to be reiterated that
these rsas are here and we as parents
if we have questions if we want to be
involved if we want to know what the
curricula is
we should be able to readily have access
to it readily have it provided to us in
a meaningful intelligible fashion
and not have to fight for it we
shouldn't have to sue somebody we
shouldn't have to expend time money and
effort to go through a process that's
basically weaponized because
most people won't pursue the process
they will just be worn out they'll say
that they did what they did or they'll
accept the answer that they have and
maybe they don't have the discretionary
money to go to court all right to go
through the three four months to turn
around and spend some money to compel a
bureaucrat that might have a differing
opinion about saying this is what the
curriculum is
all right and it's not a hardship to say
that providing the curriculum or you're
going to be spending a lot of money to
do that
you were able to turn around say this is
the curriculum on demand and I shouldn't
have to sue for it
transparency is what it's all about
thank you very much
thank you Mr chair and thank you to all
of our education committee people who
still have ears and can still hear thank
you thank you and thinking about the 400
people that sat in this room this
morning what an education that has been
for them the folks that stayed all day I
have served in New Hampshire schools for
very many years I was a certified
guidance person for a K-12 I worked in
three different school districts I did
run a family service organization and I
did at one time sit in the state
legislature I know what a tough job you
have at this point trying to figure out
who knows what they're talking about I
never in all my days in school I never
heard
an employee of the school district say
to a student don't tell your parents
this I never heard that I heard kids say
it to kids don't tell your parents this
but I've never heard it from an employee
of the school district I want to say too
that as we talk about this professional
staff have the obligation to report any
abuse or neglect the suspicion of abuse
or neglect and that's where I would
fight with your bottom line that says
there's no expense to this bill there's
an incredible expense to this bill if I
hear something from a student that is
any kind of a serious I'm going to run
away I'm going to burn the house down
I'm going to do it and I don't report
that to Child Protection
I'm in big trouble and if that youngster
something happens to that youngster here
we are facing lawsuits and lawsuits and
lawsuits and malpractice insurance talk
to the social workers Association talk
to the guidance people how much does it
cost for malpractice insurance because
certainly all School employees are at
risk
what I heard today many things were
talked about that just were violation of
Ethics where is our school board where
is our School principles Association
where is our school administration why
are we not talking to the people who can
make a difference who can change things
why are we sitting here talking about it
in this room when we should be talking
about it with the officials who know
what they can do I just I'll end by just
saying
I want you to visualize what it's like
if you or someone you know a child does
not know how to swim and they get pushed
in the water and they can't get out what
happens where is the personal flotation
device that's going to save that adult
or that child that personal flotation
device for many people happens to be
School Employees that
the work that's done in
parent teachers thank you and let me
just say we can't legislate love we
can't legislate caring but if we all did
our part we would live in a different
kind of world thank you
my legs are asleep I imagine yours is
too it's been a long day I appreciate
you all sitting here and enduring and
listening to any uh everyone's testimony
I learned a lot I learned that there is
sadness
I learned that there is Success my
husband was a teacher for 38 years
grandmother
and I homeschool my youngest grandson
there is a great division because when
my children went to school I was a
parent volunteer within the school
system I worked along teachers and I got
to keep an eye on my kids and learn
what's going on The Great Divide that
was just spoken is the Divide now that
has become
a wedge between parents this is not a
trans issue if indeed there are some
trans
issues within the bill maybe you guys
can hammer it out I found out today that
there is a law to protect these
vulnerable people against abusive
Behavior very good there's also services
to protect
youngsters from being abused and taken
from households
may not be a tremendously efficient but
every now and then you have to treat it
when I'm talking about
is like my Bill of Rights my rights as a
parent or as a grandparent that if I go
before the schools
and I ask that I'm told
I'm told and I can work within that
framework
not all parents are bad parents
not all teachers are bad teachers
work within our school board and get
truthful answers from our school boards
we need protection too
I thank you for your diligence and I
appreciate it I support the bill
if it needs a little tweaking
but I support the Bill thank you
good afternoon
my name is James Reardon
last time I was here was nearly 20 years
ago
I was invited by Senator Jack Barnes and
representative Frank Bishop
and I was presented this by the general
court
this joint declaration for service as a
U.S marine
in operation enduring freedom
never thought I'd be back
and certainly not for something like
this lots of people said a lot of nice
things on both sides but
that's all been said and I'm going to be
more direct
I have gone through the school system
here personally and during a time when
several teachers from the Raymond School
District were sentenced to state prison
for pedophilia
one of which is still serving out the
are those the people that are the safe
spaces
are they the lifeboats
the kids have to have access to
one can't help but wonder what
punishment he would have received today
in 2023
makes me sad to think that
given where we're at as a country
some might consider him ahead of the
Curve
a presidential medal of freedom from the
current Administration doesn't seem out
of the question
here I have with me is a communication
via email with the Raymond Elementary
school nurse regarding our child in the
first grade
at the bottom
she found it necessary and appropriate
to list her pronouns on the signature
line of her official school email
it's a dog whistle signaling she's in
the radical gender ideology which begs
the question
what conversations did she have with
six-year-old children in private
what types of questions does she ask a
month ago I promised I'd find out
I made my concerns known on a local Town
page via social media someone decided to
report me to the police
the police contacted me asking for
clarification on my intentions and I was
happy to tell them that's how I came to
be here with you today
I support this bill and it's unfortunate
to say I find it necessary in today's
sick political climate to ensure the
protection of children against radical
gender ideologues who are hell-bent on
the sexualization and grooming of
children parents should be aware of
everything going on with their kids in
school and be the final decider of what
is and is not okay anyone who disagrees
is a supporter of pedophilia and will be
judged accordingly
I will not rest until I'm sure that
these degenerates are hamstringed from
doing any further harm to our children
and with this law they can be identified
held accountable
should they violate it your time is up
thank you I support the bill and thank
you for your time
thank you for taking my testimony I'm
Mary Wilke I'm a resident of Concord I'm
a former retired public school teacher
and I don't want to repeat what other
people have said so
um
I oppose the bill
um I oppose Parts TUV and W of the bill
those are the parts I'm addressing those
have to do with trans those are the ones
that Target trans and lgbtq people I
haven't really studied the other parts
but all the other parts seem to be
rights that that parents already already
have
so I'm particularly focused on those I'm
concerned as a human being and as a
former teacher and as a parent and
grandparent I'm concerned about a bill
that seems to me to be dangerous to
young people who are very vulnerable
already in our communities and I want to
just mention something that hasn't
gotten as much attention
um
I just there's been a lot said about
public school teachers here today and
some of it's been positive a lot has
been pretty negative I taught for many I
taught in four different schools my kids
went to three different Public Schools
the teachers I knew were kind and caring
people who had nothing but the best
interests of their students at heart
they were not radicalized they were not
indoctrinating anybody they did not lie
to parents they did not tell children to
lie to their parents no administrator
ever told me to lie to a parent and I
never in a million years would have lied
to a parent and I have to say as a
person who dedicated a good part of my
life to Public School teaching it's very
painful to hear allegations like that
and in my own experience I see nothing
like that yes I have heard of teachers
being arrested I've heard of hundreds of
teachers who have who get honored by
their students years later to say you
made such a difference a good positive
difference in my life I just wanna
I just want to point that out too
because we haven't heard a lot about
that I just would like to say that when
you become a teacher you go through
training that emphasizes how important
it is to work with parents and that the
best success you know you'll be more
likely to succeed with students they
were more likely to succeed if the
parent and teacher are teams work as
teams and that's the teachers I worked
with that's how they saw it
um
another thing most teachers are parents
teachers also the ones I know believe
that parents do have the fundamental
right to raise their children most
teachers I know are respectful of that
um but parents rights are not absolute
and children do have some rights and
even the educator code of the ethics
that commissioner edelblue oversaw when
it was signed requires that Educators
eat reach ensure that every child is
treated with dignity and respect and if
a child comes to a teacher and confides
something and
and then the teacher says have you let
me back up if a child had come to me and
said something in confidence about their
gender
my first response would have been have
you talked about this with your parents
if they were looking for advice or help
if they said no I haven't and if I do
I'll be kicked out of the house
I'm in a quandary that is not clear in
convincing evidence that will protect me
if I don't tell the parent which is what
the law requires the law says oh I'd be
fine not telling the parent if it's
clear and convincing evidence well we
know kids sometimes exaggerate but
sometimes they don't we heard somebody
today from your time is up okay thank
you I'm totally opposed to this to that
portion of the bill and thank you for
hearing me thank you
Liz Gabbert
okay
chair committee thank you very much
Mike Thornton District 43 Milford
today I'm going to use two Latin phrases
one e pluribus unum think we all know
what that means
where we would eat Pluribus Unum today
where's our Unity
I'm speaking in support of Senate bill
if I offer a a minor
to a school system and I
I expect two things I expect them to be
in loco parentis when they're not there
in my home the school is in place of the
parent
temporarily
I'm unconcerned with anyone's sexual
choices
right now
I want to know why isn't their family
counseling if there's a problem that's
perceived with a child why the parents
how's any child served
by teaching them that their parents
can't be trusted
and that they don't have to tell the
truth
I was
going to stay simplified to the Marine
who left I was also a Marine
was also an Air Force officer
we were taught honor
you did not
distort the truth
we
send our children to school for one
reason
education
in our schools we're lucky to get
English proficiency up to 70 percent
math proficiency
parents love these children they gave
them life
parents have 100 percent of the duty
to shelter clove feed and guide our
children
education
185 days a year about six hours a day
parents
760 hours a year
the schools have our children 12.5
percent
who knows these Children's Medical
Records fears pains aspirations your
time is up please support
272. thank you thank you for your
service you're welcome
Judy
good afternoon thank you for hearing us
today my name is Emma savini I'm the
children's Behavioral Health policy
coordinator at new Futures new Futures
is a non-profit non-partisan
organization that Advocates educates and
collaborates for the health and wellness
of all Granite Staters today new Futures
is here in opposition to Senate Bill 272
because it prevents students from
establishing support networks outside of
their families which has been shown to
be a mitigating factor for adverse
childhood experiences adverse childhood
experiences affect approximately 61
percent of our population
61 percent of adults have experienced at
least one adverse childhood experience
in their life even if you have great
parents
life circumstances may just
happen to shake out that you have at an
adverse childhood experience it can be
something like a divorce a parent
entering the prison system
um severely
domestic violence or just severe mental
these Aces can accumulate and lead to
severely negative mental physical and
behavioral health outcomes notably back
pain can be caused by Aces so these are
really things that are pervasive in our
lives and get but the good news is they
can be mitigated by having just one
adult in our lives that we can trust and
and talk to outside of our families
the granite state has done an excellent
job emphasizing this with their one
trusted adult program
our fear is that with this bill that one
trusted adult program will be unable to
continue and that children will be
discouraged from forming these
relationships that can help mitigate
these problematic events in their
childhood
as such we would strongly urge this
committee to vote Senate Bill 272
itl and you should have all my testimony
uh next speaker would be Rebecca
non
n-o-n-n
hi my name is Jen and I'm speaking on
behalf of Rebecca non Rebecca Rose
who's not able to be here today
uh their testimony
I'm a global racial and social
inequality lab research intern a UNH
student studying sociology and a parent
I've held membership in numerous lgbtq
clubs and support groups both on and off
school campuses and as both a minor and
an adult in these groups there is an
essential agreement that all
participants make to preserve
confidentiality this is because most
lgbtq plus people understand that safety
is one of the most important issues for
a community during a Time
of Nationwide anti-lgbtq plus
legislative efforts and epidemic
epidemic levels of
anti-lgbtq hate crimes
when I was in eighth grade at runlett
middle school I gave to my school
counselor a t-shirt covered in blood my
blood and an undeveloped role film
containing photos of my beat up face and
asked for help
dcyf was contacted and soon I was
interviewed by a social worker at my
school I told her every detail about the
abuse I faced at home later that weekend
she came to my home and interviewed me
again in front of my abuser my mother
I was terrified of what would happen to
me so when she asked me the same
questions this time with my abuser
staring into my eyes I panicked and I
lied the case was dropped and the abuse
continued
the following summer I was arrested for
defending myself against my abuser I was
put on probation and bounced around
group homes for years when I told my
probation officer I was being abused she
said nothing and changed the subject
when my court ordered psychologists
reported that she suspected I was being
abused my mother simply changed the
mental health provider and nothing came
up the reports child abuse is a serious
social problem that multiplies
exponentially for lgbtq children the
systems put in place to protect children
from abuse at home are inadequate and
deeply flawed SB 272 does not protect
lgbtq children but increases the
likelihood that they would be abused at
home this bill opens up lgbtq children
to unnecessary trauma I'm speaking to
you not only as an lgbtq Survivor of
child abuse inflected by a parent but as
the mother of a New Hampshire student
lgbtq students who choose not to come
out to their parents do so for many
reasons and all too often that reason is
related to fear for their own emotional
and physical safety I implore you please
hello I'm Lee and I oppose this bill as
a trans man who uh transitioned in New
Hampshire
and I was fortunate to have a relatively
positive experience and a lot of that
was due to coming out on my own terms
like six or so years after the fact
after I started socially transitioning
and
the wording of this bill
directly targets
kids invulnerable situations trans kids
kids who may I don't know cut their hair
short and suddenly their teacher is
having to report on all of these little
details that it's frankly none of their
business it's
that's not a great example I'll admit
that I have no notes because I wasn't
expecting to be here this is supposed to
be a bill about parental rights
bolstering support systems within the
school and that's not what this is
there's no compensation for outing these
vulnerable children already at risk
there's there's nothing to compensate
for that
and we've seen today supporters of this
bill are relying on just like unfounded
graphic claims stories which
multiple are true in some cases it
doesn't really matter because
they're relying on
accusing people of being groomers and
pedophiles and being cult members things
like that and it's just unnecessary
when
this should just be a matter of
again bolstering a student's support
systems and
this is kind of the Line in the Sand
where you have to decide
whether you are going to support a
person's right to defend the right for
self-determination defend the right to
for self-expression and this bill would
interfere with that and again could put
a lot of kids in danger so I would
just highlight
that from my perspective as a citizen of
New Hampshire being accused of of all
these things when I just want
kids in my community to be safe in this
bill
directly is in opposition to that and
that's all I have thank you thank you
yeah hey there uh pretty late to the
party here uh pretty much everything I
wanted to say has been said by someone
probably much more articulate than
myself so shout outs to them uh thank
you for everyone who shared a personal
story uh people here were very brave to
express themselves I know it's very
difficult to come up here and tell a
very personal story about yourself
uh well one of the things I just want to
uh
uh say is that teachers are a very
valuable function to society you know
like uh it can generally like go into
the realm of like public health you know
I I never lived through it but I know I
can see a lot of people here would have
lived through like the age pandemic in
the 80s and the 90s and that's an issue
that could have been solved like tens of
thousands of people didn't need to die
just for like teachers being able to say
like hey you gotta you gotta wrap it up
bud like you got to do something about
that
um
and uh like I think that we the the
constant undermining of teachers and the
culture and just the fact that like I
know so many teachers is personally I'll
see them just like they work you know
the high school and then I see them
waiting tables it's like what the hell's
with that like shouldn't they be
shouldn't they not need another job
speaking mostly to you guys right here
maybe maybe that's something you can
look into but uh
yeah no I think it's kind of just
disgusting and I think that for the few
of you who are still uh in support of
this bill you have people in your life
that you can talk to and be like hey uh
you probably had someone in your life
who wasn't completely cool with you
how'd that go for you how did that feel
to talk to someone like that like to
have someone that you care about someone
you love who not a completely okay with
that how would it feel to that person
before they were okay to meet you on
your own terms just was told was by a
teacher like that suck and that's all I
have to say thank you
10 weeks
Catherine
Morrell
good afternoon chair and members of the
committee my name is Morgan my pronouns
are she her and I'm from Dover
I'm here to represent myself today and
testify in opposition to SB 272.
in addition to the many threats to
student safety and privacy that you have
heard from others opposing this bill
today
I want you to also think about kids like
me
I've been in the New Hampshire School
System since I started Pre-K and once I
got to elementary school I remember one
of my parents asked me
why I didn't like to dress pretty like
the other girls
why did I wear running sneakers instead
of the cute pink sandals like all my
friends why did I choose short instead
of flower printed dresses and skirts
you know what my answer was
I like to play at recess
I don't like the wood chips in my shoes
and I don't like when my skirt flies up
this was a pretty common occurrence for
me through elementary middle and high
school yes even after recess ended
I still preferred my sneakers and shorts
I wrestled with that for many many years
I asked myself why don't I want to have
cute outfits like my friends why why
don't I have the same interest as them
am I non-binary
I push myself to wear clothes I didn't
feel comfortable in so the questions
would stop
traded my running shoes in for ballet
flats in my shorts and pants in for
dresses
I stared in the mirror every morning
forced myself to smile knew that I would
be told that I looked pretty today
and I fit in with my friends a little
bit better
I expressed myself a little bit
differently than the traditional
feminine standards but I've always been
what everyone is so worried about the
straight kids I've always been the
straight kid
I've always known that that's always
been in me so
what makes it any different for lgbtq
plus peers
the only reason I ever began to question
myself was because the people that I
trusted began pushing their perception
of what was considered right onto me and
my personal preferences
so my question for you is
would you perceive me dressing in
athletic shorts and running shoes at
eight years old as being gay versus the
rest of my peers
would your perception of me mean my
parents needed a phone call to let them
know that I might be trans because this
bill
does include teachers reporting students
that they perceive to be trans
perception
this bill SB 272 cannot be implemented
without discrimination
there is no way around that you would
not be treating every student in that
school the same that is discrimination
there is a very clear line there and the
youth in New Hampshire deserve a
legislature that protects their rights
not infringes on them
I urge you to vote itl on SB 272
thank you for your time thank you Alex
Frazier
hi my name is Alex Frazier and I'm a
student at mvms
I'm currently about to finish my seventh
grade year I'm a daughter a sister and
an aunt
when I was hearing this when I decided
to come to this hearing I did not plan
to speak but after sitting here for
hours listening to everybody's testimony
I finally decided that I would put my
opinion in on this matter my age group
and those older than me and younger than
me are being affected by this one thing
I'd like to emphasize is honesty honesty
is something that simply can't be argued
I'm sure everyone here can agree that
honesty is very important this bill
promotes honesty between the public
education system and parents as well as
honesty between parents and children
this this has been turned into a battle
between oppression and the lgbtq plus
Community but that is not what this
should be about this is about the safety
of children in public schools and
parents knowing what they need to know
about kids children's children like me
are vulnerable as well as our minds are
developing and are at a mental health
risk on this topic every child wants to
fit in with others or be cool with all
respect to all lgbtq
lgbtq plus community members most kids
transition to be cool or popular
teachers don't always do teachers don't
always understand this and socially
transition children confusing children
more more than 45 percent of the
transgender people commit commit suicide
after being affirmed in their new
identity most kids go through or this
around my age when we are all
uncomfortable with the changes in our
bodies children think this is a way to
fix that uncomfortable feeling in
addition there is a school counselor who
anyone can go to and say hey I smoked
pot this weekend with my best friend
over in the fields across the school and
she is not allowed to tell the parents
this
right now is the most crucial time for
honesty and not having secrets between
kids and parents and having the people
teaching your children lying to you the
one raising that child isn't a good way
and for the record I'm okay with having
the lower percent of control as a minor
child still developing please vote Yes
on this bill for the children of New
Hampshire thank you for your time thank
you
okay
yes
Stephen scar scare
s-c-a-e-r
good afternoon and thank you for your
patience I'm Stephen scare from Nashua
New Hampshire and I'm here to urge you
to support this bill we've heard a lot
about transgender children but I have no
idea what one is is it someone whose sex
was misassigned at Birth someone who
somehow was born in the wrong body and
has a gendered soul or a gendered
identity
or is it someone who's just
non-conforming
traditionally and why it's in the DSM is
that it's a mental health disorder that
we need to treat
most people I talk to assume that when
Physicians and therapists treat
childhood gender dysphoria they go
through a really regimented process for
years evidence-based treatment and work
with the family
but our school policies show us
otherwise that a school can be socially
transitioned before receiving any
Psychotherapy for underlying issues and
that makes a diagnosis of gender
dysphoria inevitable and that's why
parents need this law and that's why
they need your help in New Hampshire a
14 year old girl with autism and PTSD
can identify as a boy the school
facilitate her social transition with
clothes and pronouns and hide her new
identity from her parents when she's 18
she can get testosterone on her first
trip to the clinic without ever having
had a psychological evaluation
New Hampshire's gender affirmation model
has been abandoned by England Norway
Finland and Sweden as dangerous and
ineffective gender affirmation lets kids
diagnose themselves and choose the
course of treatments any coexisting
mental health problems that might be at
the root of the gender dysphoria are
dismissed as being part of the minority
stress of gender dysphoria that's
concerning because
over 97 percent of trans identifying
youth are diagnosed with real leader
problems and a third have moderate
severe autism according to data from
England's largest gender Clinic
social transitioning isn't a neutral
intervention because it pushes kids
towards irreversible medical transitions
that can result in cardiovascular
disease osteoporosis and fertility
sexual dysfunction increased cancer risk
and thrombosis
if we give children the love and support
they need and allow them to go through
natural puberty most boys and girls will
outgrow their gender dysphoria no
chemicals or scalpels needed
and please don't be blackmailed by the
astronomical suicide figures from the
Trevor Project
these figures are solicited from online
self-report surveys solicited on social
media the best figures that we have is a
suicide rate of
0.03 percent
as the number of de-transitioners Rises
and the medical scandals unfold will
eventually ban medical transitions for
children in the meantime please help
children's protect children parents
protect their children from an ideology
that teaches they might have been wrong
in the born in the wrong body and
there's a right way and a wrong way to
be a boy or a girl thank you
thank you
uh Louise Spencer
I gave testimony for some
okay
uh
Mr chair and members of the committee
Ian Hewitt appearing for Cornerstone
some of you might have heard just within
the past week about a lawsuit filed by
Amber Levine a mother in Maine When Miss
Levine's young daughter began to
identify as male the school not only
concealed this from Amber but gave the
daughter who had just turned 13 a chest
binder when the mother found out about
this and withdrew her daughter from the
school she was immediately reported to
and investigated by Maine's equivalent
of dcyf for alleged low severity
emotional abuse I.E disagreeing with the
government secretly giving her daughter
a chest binder this is important to us
because the policy that this main School
District used to do this to Amber
Levine's daughter is based on a Model
created by a national organization
called glsen that's gay lesbian and
straight Educators Network and that same
model is also the template for the
so-called policy jbab jbab that's been
enacted by dozens of school districts
all over New Hampshire now as you heard
quoted in Senator Carson's testimony
these policies in New Hampshire will
typically just come right out and say
explicitly that a school should not only
conceal social transitioning from
parents but should affirmatively lie to
parents to prevent them from finding out
about this and these school districts
will also lie to parents by falsely
claiming that these policies are somehow
required by state or federal
non-discrimination law even though
there's been no cases holding this
anywhere
of course the drum beat that you'll
usually hear against this bill is that
if parents are allowed to learn that
their child is transgender then they
will abuse their children
but in every other context parents are
presumed innocent and retained their
parental rights unless there's at least
some small Quantum of evidence of
specific wrongdoing it's only in this
context that we presumptively declare
all parents guilty take their rights
away by default and at the same time
assume that government employees are
somehow inherently trustworthy and good
the last thing I'll say about this is
that Cornerstone much preferred 1146 H
which was the amendment to hb10
introduced by Chief Justice Lynn
relative to that Amendment this bill
does actually provide a fairly wide
latitude for courts to allow secret
transitioning under a broader definition
of abuse nonetheless this bill would be
a tremendous improvement over the status
quo where parents all around New
Hampshire are discovering they have no
rights against schools secretly
transitioning their children and lying
to them about it thank you and I'd be
happy to to take any questions Mr chair
thank you thank you
thank you so much for taking the time
today it's been a long day to hear
testimony I'm with the ACLU of New
Hampshire to
Echo opposition to this bill because as
we've heard through all of these
statements SB 272 isn't about parental
rights it's about singling out a
specific historically marginalized group
of people our lgbtq community and in
particular trans students
the singling out is in the plain text of
the bill
and it's in the intentions of the
proposed legislation because in order
for educators or for any school staff to
comply with the text or else potentially
face litigation
they're going to have to surveil their
teens behaviors and preferences that are
linked to gender expression and gender
identity
and we've heard from testimony from the
office of the child advocate and child
welfare service providers that this can
open
lgbtq teens to hostility rejection and
even violence from their parents if this
information is shared before they're
ready
these are not just merely conversations
that are uncomfortable there's a real
risk of harm and we've heard that from
Advocates time and time again about this
legislation
we know that SB 272 also undermines
existing state and federal protections
for granite Staters
it violates
constitutional and statutory protections
for transgender individuals to be free
from discrimination on the basis of sex
and gender identity and there have been
numerous Federal and State Court rulings
Nationwide that set precedent that
individuals of gender identity should be
free from discrimination
I urge legislators to respect that
students have free expression rights
when they're at school and that this
targeted surveillance and Reporting will
only make transgender students feel as
that they can't be their full selves
I'd also like to underscore that the
disclosure requirement or the right to
know regarding extracurricular
activities can also leave lgbtq students
without access to safe or affirming
environments and that this disclosure
could result in lgbtq students in
particular who attend gsas and other
clubs to no longer view those as safe
places to get the support that they need
and this is really unfortunate because
students with access to gsas are through
research less likely to hear negative
remarks about gender expression or being
transgender to feel unsafe about their
Identity or to miss school because of
safety concerns and students with access
to gsa's often experience lower levels
of victimization related to their
identity and report a greater sense of
belonging to their school and community
it's important that we maintain your
time is up thank you so much I encourage
you to itl this Bill thank you
well good afternoon my name is Deb has I
am president of the American Federation
of teachers New Hampshire and I am here
to speak in opposition to SB 272
particularly because of Those portions
that um
would affect our public schools and how
they deal with LBD LBT G cute students
aft stands for public schools they are
safe and welcoming and inclusive for all
students and that includes our
lgbtq plus students this so-called
parental Bill of Rights SB 272 has very
little to do with actually helping our
students learn and thrive in school
instead it would force schools to divert
their limited resources from teaching
and supporting kids into spying
reporting on and in some cases actually
outing and endangering children or just
trying to be themselves and live their
lives
it would
Force students to act as surveillance
agents but only on certain students
particularly students that are perceived
to be or engaging in behaviors that
might mark them as members of the LG
btq community
and because of that it's discriminatory
so you'll be asking teachers and School
staff to discriminate against some of
their own students and much earlier
today I heard someone speculating on why
teachers are leaving the profession
ask us to discriminate against our
students
you'll drive us out
I mean you add that on top of the low
pay and everything else ask us to
discriminate against our students ask us
to violate the code of conduct and the
so
SP 272 would impose chilling
mccarthyistic Broad and vague restraints
that will hinder schools from providing
the safe welcoming learning environment
that promotes learning and success for
all kids and welcomes all children and
families this bill tells teachers and
School staff they must put aside any
obligation to the student it Outlaws the
human courtesy and kindness that can be
as simple as treating students with
respect
and that's what we
always strive to do
to help run our classrooms in a a manner
that functions well so our students can
learn
it puts Pages stuck together because I'm
just sitting here way too long it puts
education no wind bind when they try and
teach any District approved curriculum
that conflicts with the Bill's
requirement and as our social worker
colleagues have pointed out in some
cases this bill will put some students
in danger at home in cases where parents
are unsupportive or actually abusive to
our child who is lgbtq plus Deborah time
is up okay so I would just urge you to
itl this Bill thank you
right
okay thank you John desjore
Holly Stevens Tammy
good afternoon chairman Ladd and members
of the committee my name is Holly
Stevens I'm the director of public
policy at Nami New Hampshire the
National Alliance on Mental Illness on
behalf of Nami New Hampshire I'm here
today to speak in opposition to Senate
bill 272. over the past decade already
high suicide rates have been rising in
the United States and in New Hampshire
today in the granite state suicide is
the second leading cause of death for 10
to 24 year olds
and we know fifteen thousand youth ages
12 to 17 have depression in our state
recent results from the 2021 yrbs survey
showed that 24
.7 percent of New Hampshire High School
students seriously considered suicide
that's one quarter that's not a trans
kids that's of all kids
19.3 percent made a plan for suicide and
9.8 attempted suicide in the 12 months
preceding the survey this is a
significant increase over the 2019
numbers
according to the CDC lgbtq youth
represent a significant high-risk
subgroup as evidenced by higher rates of
suicide attempts and more lethal
attempts
we know that for transgender individuals
lack of school belonging internalized
stigma and emotional family neglect
significantly contribute to suicidality
Senate Bill 272 only serves to create a
less welcoming and affirming environment
for these kids in their schools and may
potentially expose them to dangerous
family rejection
Nami New Hampshire actively works with
schools on suicide prevention through
the Nami New Hampshire connect program
by way of background Nami New
Hampshire's connect program has been
designated as a national best practice
in suicide prevention intervention in
postvention and has trained in over 40
States and 35 tribal Nations
as a part of the connect program youth
are encouraged to connect with a trusted
adult if they are feeling sadness
hopelessness or having thoughts of
suicide
the language contained on page 4 line
17-25 could create a chilling effect for
all students in approaching School
Personnel when they are a friend or in
crisis
it may also disconnect Educators from
their system of support and paralyze
them when questioning what steps need to
be taken to ensure a student's safety in
a time when youth suicide rates are very
high New Hampshire needs to take any and
all measures to prevent suicide deaths
and suicide attempts
Senate Bill 272 legislatively creates an
atmosphere in schools that discourages
youth from seeking the assistance of a
trusted adult
causes confusion for school Personnel
about what steps to take of a student
comes to them in crisis and is counter
to the suicide prevention work that is
being done in our state
in a time when creating accepting and
affirming spaces is Paramount your time
is up thank you simply put certain
provisions of this bill would be
damaging to students and we encourage
the the committee to itl the bill
thank you Sebastian Fuentes of the
rights and democracy is going to be read
by representative representative go
ahead thank you so much
um Sebastian asked if I would read his
testimony he is also a father of four
and to go home and take on Daddy Duty
um
so he asked me to read the following it
is the responsibility of schools
Educators and every person in this room
to take proactive steps to protect all
students including lgbtq students from
discrimination harassment bullying and
to create a supportive and affirming
space for them to learn and grow
schools should be a place where they
find safety in a nurturing hand
creating the space means implementing
policies and practices that address bias
and promote acceptance and understanding
providing resources and support for
lgbtq students and their families and
fostering a culture of respect and
inclusivity throughout the school
community
let me on his behalf share a radical
idea instead of advocating for the false
premise of quote parental rights that
actually harms lgbtq students we should
be advocating for a student's Bill of
Rights this would include the right to
an inclusive and honest education the
right to no cost School meals for all
students the right for protections to
protections for educators who offer
students a safe inclusive and honest
environment it would also include the
right to a great education and proper
fundly regardless of zip code and most
urgently the right to protections from
this tragic epidemic of gun violence
that should be a priority improving
Family School relationships should start
with an ask for all parents to put down
their weapons and show up to the
discussion with schools ready to engage
constructively
there could not be a more urgent time to
promote learning environments where
students feel safe supported and ready
to learn word a critical movement moment
for families and schools to work
together to develop strong Partnerships
to support Student Success academically
socially and emotionally
I'm here on Sebastian's behalf to ask
you to oppose SB 272 because this bill
will cause direct harm to our children
and our Educators and it is harmful to
us parents who care deeply about all
children not just the ones we raise it's
time to do what is right to save lives
thank you please itl this Bill thank you
Alan RAF New Hampshire AFL-CIO
Sean McDowell Donald
my name is Sean McDonough I'm a student
attorney from the Harvard Law School
lgbtq advocacy Clinic here representing
Seacoast outright
I would like to focus specifically on
this bill's invasive requirement that
schools design and Implement a tracking
system to surveil and report to parents
on what extracurricular Club students
attend and how this provision threatens
School gender sexuality alliances or
gsas
gsas are incredibly beneficial to the
well-being of lgbtq Youth these
student-led groups provide a safe
accepting Place away from parents for
students to come together outside of
class hours and consider their
identities
as you just heard lgbtq students in
schools with gsas feel safer are more
likely to come to class and feel a
greater sense of belonging in their
school communities these benefits aren't
just for members even students who
aren't members benefit as studies show
that schools with lgbtq inclusive
environments including gsas
have safer overall School climates with
less harassment and violence for all
students
gsas can be particularly effective in
preparing students to talk to their
parents about their gender or sexual
orientation
they also provide a comforting place for
students who aren't accepted at home and
that support from peers can be crucial
to those young people's Mental Health
to effectively perform these essential
functions gsas cannot be forced to track
and report to parents on student
participation
a GSA that is subject to surveillance
this GSA surveillance requirement also
conflicts with a federal equal access
Act
in the 1990s New York a group of
Christian students formed a Bible club
and wanted a club ruled that only
Christians could be officers the school
objected saying that their
non-discrimination policy was
inconsistent with that and wouldn't
permit the Bible Club to only have
Christian leaders the students sued and
in the resulting Court decision the
second Circuit Court of Appeals ruled in
favor of the Bible Club
the court found that because Christian
leadership was essential to the Bible
Club the district couldn't prevent it
even though the non-discrimination
policy was neutrally applied the court
provided a helpful analogy to elaborate
a role requiring students to wear
appropriate Footwear at all times might
effectively ban after-school meetings of
the yoga Club
similarly it is an essential function of
gsas to prepare and support lgbtq youth
to talk to their families about their
gender or social sexual orientation when
the student is ready and not sooner
gsas would not be the critical safe
spaces we need them to be if they were
forced to surveil and report on their
members accordingly SB 272 is in direct
conflict with the federal equal access
act for this reason along with many
others I ask you to stand with lgbtq
youth once again and vote itl thank you
thank you
uh Hayden Smith a New Hampshire youth
movement
Lynn's Jack house
hi there I am a queer non-binary person
and I represent 603 equality and
emerging Statewide lgbtq advocacy group
I oppose this bill because it directly
attacks lgbtq especially trans young
people at school the writers of this
bill could have chosen not to written
lgbtq people into this bill we're not
making anything up by pointing it out
a small but loud group of people
committed to misunderstanding this do
not speak for all parents we won't be
fooled by them saying this is about
parental rights parents can and do have
many rights and educators will tell you
that they are regularly notified of them
every lgbtq person should be able to
come out on their own timeline in spaces
that feel safe to them we know ourselves
best no one made us queer Trans in fact
the world tries very hard to make us fit
in straight and CIS boxes where we don't
fit
believe us when we talk about our own
experiences and when we tell you that it
is not safe for others to know that we
are lgbtq including family members and
even when we are younger than 18.
many of us have experienced harm from
being outed to parents or other family
members before they we were ready
whether that's conversion therapy or
other abuse my father emotionally abused
me when he found out that I was queer in
high school before I felt safe to tell
him and my relationships with supportive
friends and teachers at school kept me
alive through that daily abuse
he regularly told me that I was
disgusting immoral and going to hell
unless I changed who I was on a regular
basis if he had been notified that I was
a member of a GSA he would have made it
his mission to go to the club pull me
out and keep me from attending
like many of the speakers here today he
told me that he didn't judge me he was
do not be fooled by the transitioners
transition is not for everyone the vast
majority of trans people will tell you
that the long Maze of about the long
Maze of Hoops we have to jump through to
access basic health care d-transitioners
can have complex feelings about their
bodies just like any of us the problem
comes from when they try to deny trans
and non-binary people the same bodily
autonomy that allowed them to say
actually this isn't for me
this bill is not based in reality it
claims to have loopholes for situations
of abuse and neglect but rights a higher
legal standard into the law past the
existing legal standard for abuse and
neglect that is based on assumptions of
information and training that teachers
simply do not have thank you
out of Boston Mass
hi everyone you have my um written
testimony submitted by by my colleague
we submitted it jointly
um 500 500 bills that's how many bills
targeting lgbtq people have been
introduced in state legislatures across
the country this year in 2023 500 bills
and more than 30 of them have been
passed into law already Senate Bill 272
could add to the list I want to mention
this partly to create a context to
understand the emotional energy in this
room to understand people's passion fear
confusion and anger that's been
permeating this discussion today I also
want to mention it to highlight to
underscore that it belies what's
actually motivating this piece of
legislation make no mistake that
parental bills of rights are being
introduced across the country and
they're all doing the same thing which
is targeting transgender youth
especially for a special level of
surveillance for a special level of
reporting back to parents and this bill
does not exist in a vacuum
I've heard a lot of misinformation today
including crazy things like blockers are
being distributed at schools which is
absolutely false
um but one of the biggest falsehoods
that has been repeated multiple times
today I really want to draw attention to
policy jbab
I really encourage you to look up Nash
OS policy Manchester's policy the policy
in Milford the policy in Guilford
they're all basically the same thing the
Hallmark in each one of those policies
is flexibility the policy lays out at
the beginning guidelines these are
guidelines that are meant to meet the
individual needs of individual students
and apply it in an individualized
fashion these policies are not
brightline rules in any sense beyond
that there is no directive you can find
in these policies that tells that tells
schools anything about how they have to
give misinformation to parents that is
false or how they have to conceal
information from parents that is a false
reading you have to do mental gymnastics
to get there out of respect for parents
and in deference to them unless
instructed otherwise School staff should
use the students enrollment name when
talking to the student's family that's
it that's just basic respect it's not a
directive to lie to parents
school policies like jbab are adopted
democratically by democratically elected
school boards with public input at
public meetings they're not this
directive that comes down from an uh
from an autocratic School Board the way
that it's been portrayed here in this
room uh these if people have problems
with the policies that are being enacted
by their school boards they ought to and
they do participate in that process and
that's how we get policies that reflect
the values of a community in the school
district
uh this bill ties the hands of school
policy makers and it ties the hands of
Educators it makes it so that
trusted adults in schools can't help
facilitate encourage and promote
conversation with families it puts them
in a box where they have no choice but
to surveil and Report or otherwise not
take information I'm going to stop now
but there was a question about the
fiscal note asked earlier and I'm happy
to like answer it because I believe I
can pretty thoroughly give a better
explanation than what you might have
heard earlier thank you very much
no question so thank you no question
okay
that it was the last pink card we have
up here is there anybody out there that
believes they submitted a pink card and
if not not seeing any uh I'm going to
close this hearing on 272. thank you for
okay